senator wayne morris of oregon left the
republican party to become a democrat in
a 1957 interview with morse mike wallace
called him the most controversial man in
the united states senate
moore spoke with wallace about why he
switched parties his criticisms of the
eisenhower administration and about his
views on political immorality this
program runs about 20 minutes
the mike wallace interview
tonight we go after the story of the
most controversial man in the united
states senate
his opinions which you'll hear in a
moment are his own and not necessarily
the american broadcasting companies the
sponsors philip morris or my own
you see him there behind me he is the
republican turned democrat from oregon
way morse who last week charged that
president eisenhower was quote the same
kind of immoralist as teamster boss dave
beck
why did the senator make that charge how
does he answer the republican
counterattack that morse's entire career
is riddled with contradictory charges
and deception
these stories in just one minute
and now to our story
senator wayne morris of oregon has made
headlines since 1944 first as a
republican attacking the democrats
now as a democrat taking off on the
republicans
since he turned on the republicans back
in 52 he's been called president
eisenhower's worst enemy in the senate
last week he seemed to earn that title
with a vengeance
in a speech in detroit senator morris
criticized the administration's domestic
policies
and called the president and teamster
union boss dave beck two
of the same kind of immoralists
he repeated that attack in the senate
last wednesday let's try to find out
among other things if the senator
believes that
that is
responsible politicking
senator first of all let me ask you this
about your charge of political
immorality
in your own words
dave beck is suspected of either
embezzling or stealing about three
hundred thousand dollars in union funds
he may face a criminal indictment and if
convicted he could be sent to jail so
much for mr beck
now few republicans dispute
your right to criticize the president
but they have objected to the way that
you did it
senator stiles bridges of new hampshire
says
it is the most shocking thing to compare
the president of the united states
with a man who has pleaded the fifth
amendment more than 200 times when asked
about his handling of union funds for
his own benefits
what about that how why
did you get yourself involved with that
kind of well mike let's get the record
straight first as to what i said
because you have quoted what you read in
the newspapers not what i said in the
detroit speech or what i said on the
floor of the senate
now what i said in the senate on april
29th what i said in detroit what i
repeated in the senate the other day is
this
we make perfectly clear that i never
said that president eisenhower and dave
back were the same kind of immoralist
what i did say was that in my book of
political ethics i see no difference in
principle
between the dave back putting his hands
into the pockets of the rank and file of
teamsters in this country
and taking out
thousands of dollars of interest-free
money which amounts of course to denying
the teamsters the interest income on the
money they ought to have
and an eisenhower administration headed
by a president that puts its hands into
the pockets of the taxpayers of this
country
and turns over to the idaho power
company millions of dollars
of interest-free money which constitutes
an essence taking from the taxpayers of
this country a giveaway of millions of
dollars of interest money belonging to
the taxpayers of the country i said i
went on let me finish the statement and
i went on mike to point out
that of course the taxpayers get hit
with a monster sort of a two
barrel shotgun approach on this they not
only lose the interest that this
administration has given to the idaho
power company but they have to pay
interest on money that the
administration has to buy for the
treasury but they wouldn't have to i
mean has to borrow for the treasury that
they wouldn't have to borrow if they
hadn't given these millions away to the
idaho power company then i said in my
book that's political immorality and
then i proceeded to document it on the
floor of the senate by saying and that's
been the chief characteristic of the
eisenhower administration since
inauguration day in 1953. and then you
went on to document what you believe is
other instances or there were other
instances of immorality of the
eisenhower administration i read the
record i read the congressional record
what i'd like to ask you is this though
essentially you did compare
the immorality what you call the
immorality of dave beck to the
immorality of the eisenhower
administration the immorality of dave
beck taking an interest free alone
streets and the immorality of this
administration taking an interest-free
loan away from the taxpayers of this
country i would like you to square if
you will
your comparison of the president of the
united states
uh with a statement that was made on the
floor of the senate back on march 18
1949 by you sir
in answer to an attack that was made
upon you
by wisconsin senator alexander wiley you
said as follows
i would say to the senator from
wisconsin that he needs to learn the
lesson
that calling either a proposition or its
advocate names
proves nothing against the proposition
or the advocate and i repeat that
statement tonight but you see when i
characterize the eisenhower
administration as an administration of
great political immorality i document it
and i'm perfectly willing to document it
on this program but let me make
perfectly clear here you see that i
think there's going on in this country
among too many people
the idea that a president can be put
upon a pedestal and you must not
criticize him as i said on the floor of
the senate have we gone so far down the
road of a police state in america that a
president shall not be subject to
criticism if an elected official of a
free people believes his record deserves
criticism so you need to describe it for
what it is let's discuss immorality
one moment in russia i realize you're
put in jail or you're liquidated if you
criticize the head of the state but i
hope the time has never come in this
country that the senate of the united
states will not remain
that parliamentary body in which an
elected official can tell the american
people a criticism of a president or
anybody else that he thinks ought to be
criticized no one really none of the
senators and i read the record suggested
that the president should be above and
beyond uh criticism they rather took
issue with what they called the manner
in which you did it and the words poor
taste were used many times
because there wasn't a republican that
would vote for it if it were offered
let's discuss immorality for just a
moment and the motives behind immorality
now dave beck
has been accused of taking union funds
this would obviously be and you've said
it here tonight for his own financial
gain if he has done it
now
how in your
now let's put it this way what in the
world
does president eisenhower stand today by
what you claim is his political
immorality what is his motive i want
money is it power i want to be very
frank about that i think a good many of
the giveaways and handouts that the
eisenhower administration has given to
big business
been given to men that have made heavy
campaign contributions to this
administration because this
administration has been dominated by
american big business and what the
american people ought to stop to realize
is what has this administration done
against the taxpayers interest in this
matter of big business handouts and
that's what i discussed on the floor of
the senate the other day you're then
saying that president eisenhower is in
the position of paying off campaign
contributors i'm saying what i'm saying
the effect is that his favoritism to
american big business is one of the
reasons that american big business has
been so strong in supporting him and i
want to say that i think the president
doesn't fully realize what he's doing i
do not think that the advisers of the
president for example have told him what
the basis for the accelerated tax
amortization law is i doubt very much if
until this issue arose that the
president realized that the tax
amortization bill was passed not to help
private utilities not to help industries
that are going to be going concerns
after the war read the congressional
debate when the bill was passed the
reason for the fast tax write-off was to
encourage industry to build war plants
that would be of little value when the
war was over that's the point i make and
when president eisenhower lets these
millions of giveaway and interest-free
loans go to private utilities he is
he's not
proposing what was not supporting what
was done when the bill was passed he is
giving the taxpayers money to going
concerns
knowingly to pay off campaign
contributors
i'm not saying to pay off campaign
contributors i'm saying the interesting
thing is his favoritism his acts as far
as his administration are concerned of
political immorality have accrued to the
benefit of american big business in the
senate last wednesday senator
i beg your pardon you said as follows
you said this administration is
honeycombed with political immorality
end quote wayne morse
you said this as a democrat
when you were a republican you said the
following the democratic administration
is honeycombed with corruption and
malfeasance in office same message
virtually the same words
different parties and i proved it to the
president at that time and what did the
president that time do
in december 1951 he offered me the
attorney general of the united states to
help clean up some corruption that had
kept him crept into his administration
quite a difference isn't it well my
question the question that i'd like to
put to you is the one that republican
senator barry goldwater of arizona asked
on the floor of the senate
he asked you he said what does it take
to please the senior senator from oregon
just clean wait just a second please sir
he has gone through two presidents and
he's unhappy he's run through two
parties and he's unhappy what does it
take to please the seniors just clean
government and i'm going to continue to
raise this voice for clean government
whether there's a democrat or a
republican in power if i think under
that administration there are evidences
of injustices and unclean government and
i take you back to the truman
administration and i say to the great
credit of president truman when he
became aware that there was some
corruption that had crept into his
government he proceeded at once to take
the steps to see to it that was cleaned
up and that's why he called me down and
said he wanted an independent to take
over the attorney generalship he said he
didn't think we'd find very much
corruption but to the extent that there
was anything he wanted it cleaned out of
his government and why didn't you take
over the attorney generalship because i
explained to the president that i
thought the greatest service i could
perform was in the center of the united
states
let's touch on just one more thing that
you said in the senate last wednesday
after more than a dozen republican
senators had criticized your attack on
the president you said
i may say facetiously that it is rather
interesting to note so many republicans
rallying around the president on the
floor of the senate in response to what
they consider to be a personal attack
upon him
and then you went on
i'm always interested however you said
i'm always interested in the differences
in the discussions in the cloak rooms
by republicans about eisenhower and
those on the floor of the senate
now what do republican senators say
about mr eisenhower in the senate cloak
room that they don't say well mike let
me make clear to you that i'm not going
to violate any confidences of my
colleagues in on this program
respect to what they say in the clerk
room but i want to tell you that there
are many of them not complimentary of
the president many times in the clerk
room and the interesting thing was that
some of those that were criticizing me
on the floor of the senate were rallying
to the president because i had
criticized the his conduct in this rapid
tax write-off or amendment in the clerk
room in some instances had made some
pretty bitter criticisms of the
president but that's their privilege
criticisms on what score i'm just the
kind of scorers that i have criticized
him for shocked at his reactionary
policy shocked that he's given these
handouts to american big business
of course a good many of the senators
whom he would like to support him are
not supporting him as much as he would
like to be supported in the case of the
budget sir
well that's of course his problem with
those republican senators the
interesting thing is that
when it comes to
a voting record on those things that he
has proposed that i'm satisfied in the
public interest he hasn't had anybody
supporting any harder than i have in the
senate or speak out more strongly in
support of his sound programs but i will
not go along with a president for
example as i documented on the floor of
the senate that appoints a talbot
secretary of the air force and only show
up his conflict of interest is
responsible to support that he gets the
highest civilian medal that can be given
the man that works in the pentagon
building but from what he ought to have
done as i said again the other day he
ought to have given him a chisel not a
medal
senator morris you say that you told
president truman that you felt that you
could be more valuable in the senate
than as attorney general is that correct
well then i'd like your answer to this
criticism of wayne morris
by political analyst raymond molly in
newsweek magazine back in october of
last year
mr moly wrote of what he called
the utter sterility of senator morris
and his ineffectiveness as a
representative and a statesman and molly
added
the net for oregon after 12 years has
been words more words and scores of
dribbling resolutions and bills which
have come to nothing
with the possible exception of a 1945
world court resolution morse has earned
credit for no important legislation what
about let's say well mike let me say
good nationally first i can't imagine
anything that would concern me less than
raymond molly's views on anything
particularly his views on me and i know
him pretty well because he's a very able
spokesman for the reactionary big
business forces of this country
but in my campaign last fall the people
of oregon answered ray moly
because i ran on the campaign platform
he gets things done for oregon and we
documented throughout the campaign the
record of 12 years of dedicated service
to the people of oregon connection with
project after project appropriation
after pro after appropriation service
for hundreds and hundreds of individuals
in respect to their business with the
federal government the people answered
the raymonds and they answered them by
giving me a resounding majority vote on
november 6 and i just dismissed the
raymonds because i know that i can
expect if you seek to stand out and
exercise an honest independence of
judgment you can expect the predatory
forces of this country to try to get you
and they've been trying ever since i've
been in the senate but i'll leave my
case rest with the people of my state
let's turn now for a minute or two to
the current jostling for power within
the republican party with an eye toward
the 1960 elections vice president nixon
being a leading contender
i'd like to ask you what you think of
him as a contender for the presidency
and i ask that having in mind the charge
made by some republicans that one of the
reasons that you quit their party was
because mr nixon was nominated to run
with ike back in 1952. well mike i think
it's up to the republicans to pick the
candidate in 1960 and if they picked
nixon in 1960 i'll campaign across the
country against him i think he's a very
able representative of reactionary
forces in this country he's an ultra
conservative and of course if you want
to understand my political philosophy
here's the basic tenet
i think the job of a united states
senator
is to seek to translate in the
legislation
values that promote the welfare of
people because i taught constitutional
law and advanced carson legislation for
many years and i tried to get my
students to see that the keystone of the
constitution
is the general welfare clause and the
wealth of america is its people not its
materialism and my job as a senator is
to try to be a pacemaker in proposing
legislation that will advance the
interests of people and in my opinion
nixon on the other hand represents a a
political philosophy that represents
primarily the vested interests of this
country
in your opinion and you feel
you feel that you feel differently from
a conservative let's say
about human beings about life about good
and bad is there that much of a palpable
difference i think the legislative
record of the liberal and conservative
approves the point
just take my voting record and compare
it with the voting record of the
reactionaries and the senate united
states and you see exactly what i mean
why'd you get into the republican party
under those circumstances in the first
place because only because you could get
elected in oregon only not at all now
that's that's part of the of the attack
against me mike i'm used to that one too
i came up in wisconsin as a progressive
republican i was brought up in the bob
lafollette tradition i went to oregon as
a progressive republican i hope we can
liberalize the republican party i tried
hard to do it and when it was perfectly
clear that they're out to destroy me i
just left them and i let all the people
of the state not just the republicans
but all the people the state vote on my
qualifications and the result of
november 6 was my re-election all right
now senator in just a minute
as we have time i'd like to get your
opinion on two controversial issues
playwright arthur miller
was indicted for contempt of congress
for refusing to testify about communists
he once knew and the late senator joseph
mccarthy
whose record in the senate bears a block
which some senators want to remove but
which you insist remain there
we'll get senator moses opinions on
these issues in just one minute
now senator morse for your opinions on
two controversial issues first of all
playwright arthur miller he was indicted
for contempt of congress because he
refused to name the people he met at
communist meetings nine years ago
he told a house on american activities
committee that he refused to name names
on grounds of conscience how do you feel
about this should a man face trial as he
has just done and possibly jail
for refusing on grounds of conscience to
inform on others before a congressional
committee well there's another case mike
it's before the courts and i'm going to
let it rest there perfectly willing let
the judgment of the court determine that
legal question
i know nothing about the evidence i
haven't followed the case other than
what we read in the newspaper as to the
joe mccarthy case let me state it to you
in this fashion
you attacked proposals made in the
senate on may 8th to white from the
record books the senate's censure of the
late senator mccarthy you said that
expunging the censure of certain of
senator mccarthy's actions would be
quote a great disservice to the history
of the senate
end quote
why would it be well let me say what i
said mike i said be a great disservice
to the senator from wisconsin now dead
because he wouldn't be there to defend
himself
i pointed out that that is history
and it ought to remain the charge was
made that we'd passed the mccarthy
resolution in hysteria and emotionalism
i pointed out that we had passed it
calmly
objectively
after a fair hearing and judiciously and
my judgment rightly but let me make very
clear my position on the mccarthy case
because i opposed the proposal to try
mccarthy in connection with his conduct
as a senator and i took the position in
the speech i made out when i objected to
the first resolution that came in
i said we have no control over the
senator from wisconsin as a senator only
the people of wisconsin have control
over him but our power over him is
limited to his conduct as an agent of
the senate and he's an agent of the
senate when he carries out the
chairmanship work of a committee and
therefore the bill of particulars i
drafted dealt entirely with mccarthy's
conduct as a chairman of a committee and
it's interesting to note that the final
action was really taken upon that
conduct and of course i shall vote
against expunging that from the record
because that's the official record of
the senate and i want history to be the
judge of it and i made one other point
in my speech on mccarthy the other day i
said remember when god puts his hand on
a colleague here in the senate that
colleague then stands before god's bar
for judgment and the son of the united
states should leave senator mccarthy
before the throne of god and leave the
record in the senate stand
after the senator's death his fellow
republican from wisconsin alexander
wiley said as follows he said there is
no one to doubt that mccarthy deeply
loved his country and would have given
his life for it
do you doubt that sir i don't think
there's any question about it joe
mccarthy certainly loves his country but
that doesn't make his opinions right in
regard to the procedures that he
followed in his desire to protect what
he thought was the best interest of his
country because in my judgment those
procedures violated some pretty precious
rights of freedom dear to all of us
two
ten-second opinions and we'll let you go
senator first
continued h-bomb tests for or against
why i agree with dr schweitzer we owe it
to future generations in our generation
to stop this threat that is created by
h-bombs not only to the health of
millions of people in parts of the world
where we're dropping these bombs when
we're not endangering americans but
we're endangering loans abroad and we
owe it to future generations of boys and
girls that we stop the test now and
carry this fight to russia by putting
her on the spot and challenging her in
the united nations to follow our
christian example this is a question of
christian morality as far as i'm
concerned
thank you very much senator morris for
coming and spending this time with us
here this evening been a pleasure
since 1944 senator wayne morse of oregon
has put personal conviction above party
politics
at the cost of being called a political
traitor he deserted the republican camp
in 1952 1852
and he now levels at his former comrades
his most withering criticism
but as his recent election as a democrat
proves he's one politician
who changed horses in the middle of the
stream
and made it to the other side
next author david law
[Applause]
ralph lapp was among those who helped
develop the atomic bomb
mike wallace talked with lapp in 1957
about his belief that the atomic bomb
threatened mankind his concerns that
nuclear bomb tests would result in new
cases of cancer and his reaction to the
use of the atomic bomb in hiroshima and
nagasaki this program is about 25
minutes
good evening what you're about to
witness is an unrehearsed uncensored
interview my role is that of a reporter
i've asked my guest dr ralph lap to
express his true feelings
his opinions are not necessarily mine
the stations or my sponsors philip
morris incorporated but whether you
agree or disagree we feel that none will
deny the right of these views to be
broadcast
the mike wallace interview
tonight we go after the story of a man
who helped to unleash the nuclear energy
which he now claims threatens the future
of mankind
our guest will be dr ralph lapp who
helped develop the atom bomb
dr lap charges that
the nuclear bomb tests like the one you
see pictured behind me have already
caused cancer and will deform thousands
of children in generations to come
if you're curious to know why the atomic
energy commission continues these tests
in nevada and what scientists like dr
lapp think of the moral social and
political issues surrounding the use of
nuclear energy in war and in peace
we'll go after these stories
in just one minute
and now to our story
from atomic physicist dr ralph lamb
the scientists who split the atom have
now been split themselves into opposing
camps over the issue of continued
nuclear bomb tests
the atomic energy commission says the
tests are not unsafe
but 2 000 leading scientists charged
that these nuclear blasts reign deadly
radioactive fallout on our entire nation
one of those scientists is dr ralph lapp
who gave up research several years ago
to write and to lecture
in a one-man crusade against further
nuclear bomb tests
dr lap
first of all let me ask you this
one group of scientists yourself
included
tells us that we're in grave danger from
present nuclear radiation
another group just as prominent says
that we're in no particular danger at
all yet both groups
apparently anyway based their opinion on
the same body of scientific facts
now how do you explain
this wide open disagreement that is
bewildering and i may say alarming the
united states
well mike i'd first like to say that
i wouldn't split the groups into those
inside the atomic energy commission and
those outside that would be unfair
because during the past week we've had
some excellent hearings before the
hollifield subcommittee of the atomic
energy committee
of the congress and it is quite clear
that scientists within the atomic energy
commission
uh differ themselves
i think this is one of the really
gratifying things that emerged that we
were able to get really healthy
testimony from people of different
viewpoint within the atomic energy
commission but the fact of the matter is
that willard libby the scientist member
of the aec says does he not
that there is a clear and present that
there is no clear and present danger as
he sees it and your group more or less
says there is a very serious danger and
i thought put to you again the fact that
certain
well-known leading scientists
claim that there is no real danger
another group of scientists say there is
a real
a present danger and yet you both base
your theories on the same body of
scientific fact
how come the split
well i think the split and i agree we
now base it upon the same uh data the
split comes from a difference in
viewpoint let me point out it is the
difference between relative
and absolute numbers for example if i
say that the risk of inducing leukemia
in a population is one hundredth of one
percent uh that may seem a relatively
small risk but if we multiply one
hundredth of one percent by a total
population of two billion eight hundred
million
then you see we have a very large number
of people although the relative number
is small the absolute number is large i
think here we come to what is the
difference
in the outlook of the people we come to
schweitzer's point we have a humanist a
man who holds human life in great regard
even one life
so he views the absolute number as most
significant well are you
let me understand now if if any group in
this nation has access to all the facts
both classified and declassified may i
say now that the facts are out in the
open oh dr debbie has testified that the
facts are now out in the open all right
certainly the atomic energy commission
has all the facts at its disposal yet it
continues to give approval to these
nuclear tests now are you prepared to
say dr lapp
that the aec either doesn't know what
it's talking about or that they are
evil men callously ignoring a real
danger to the united states they are not
evil men nor are they unintelligent men
the however i would point out to you
what is i think an injustice to them
you have the same agency the atomic
energy commission which is charged with
the developing testing of nuclear
weapons
and it is now doing the evaluation of
the hazard
that is basically unfair to them well
are you suggesting that willard lead a
libby dr libby is a captive of another
group that he does not believe what he
says no in this particular case i'm
pointing out that dr vivi is a scientist
member of the atomic energy commission
as such
he is
uh in a position of more than just a
scientist he's on the commission itself
and this commission is charged with
developing more and more weapons i
believe is unfair to ask these people to
evaluate the risk it is just basically
wrong there should be a group which is
quite neutral well that has no
responsibility for testing weapons that
suggestion is certainly a reasonable one
except i cannot escape from the fact
that dr willard libby certainly would
not suggest that these tests should
continue would he
if he believed that there was any real
danger
well i noticed uh in the morning herald
tribune which i just read this evening
that doctor libby stated that there was
not one single case of a person who was
injured where you could prove injury
now that statement uh is both uh it is
true that we have not one single case uh
the remote fallout with which we're
concerned where you can prove injury but
we will never i think even though 50 000
people be killed and that is our
estimate of the number who will die in
the next generation the next 30 years
let's say
from the fallout from bomb test to date
yet when that happens this will be 50
000
but they are scattered among 10 million
who will die from the same type of
disease but caused by a different source
do you see the point now
statistically we can't find it just as
statistically for example we can look
till the cows come home but it doesn't
look like we're going to find anything
in hiroshima which will tell us about
the genetics i still believe though that
dr libby's conscience would probably
dictate that he would suggest the tests
be stopped if he felt there were a real
danger but not for the sake of arguing
well that is i cannot speak for dr david
i know that
let's for the sake of argument say that
we do run the risk
of some physical harm from radiation
now which do you prefer
you ralph lap
do you
prefer that kind of risk to your body
and that of your children
or the risk the possible risk
of moral and spiritual slavery
which could result if we stop the
nuclear tests and thus lower our guard
against russia well let me point out
that there are two things that i would
like to um
snap back at you with the first
is that you said we
if we were making the decision for
ourselves if these risks were not
inflicted upon other people then i think
i could answer the question on the basis
of a calculated risk for myself but this
radioactive fallout is global it comes
down on brazil it comes down on all
continents so in this sense we are the
united states assuming
uh the judgment for other nations
so this is one of the things i would say
the other is that you are giving me a
very black and white choice
and i want to make it very clear that
the scientists of the united states
who have petitioned uh and the many who
haven't petitioned
uh with whom i've talked the scientists
are not for a unilateral a one-way
street type of cessation of nuclear test
we realize and i have made this
statement many times that if we the
united states were to cease our tests
unilaterally
that i believe would be interpreted as
as a weakness by the soviet union and i
think eventually we would be ground
under their heel in other words you are
saying that you do agree with president
eisenhower that nuclear tests are vital
until we and the russians
can agree to stop them simultaneously
and inspect i agree
now dr lap obviously we're going to
settle no further issue as to the tests
here tonight so but i think we've
introduced a degree of understanding
mike here which is important namely the
relative versus the absolute numbers
namely the business that the scientists
have not recommended that we stopped
uh i feel that in with respect to
example this petition
whereby scientists petitioned the in
this country one might ask why didn't
the scientists petition the russians to
stop their tests
uh i believe this would be uh
people might look upon this uh and say
the scientists were just looking at the
united states and not at russia but in
that sense the scientists would be
exceeding
the bounds of their responsibility they
would be going beyond the borders of the
united states in an area where i believe
they would have no uh real
responsibility well if their if their
creature if their frankenstein as you've
pointed out goes beyond the borders of
the united states even when the testing
is done here it would seem
reasonable
but scientists of the world should get
together and petition governments around
the world to stop the tests
well in in this case i think one has to
be very precise with respect to what the
responsibility of the scientist is and
mike i'd like to point out that this is
a relatively new field namely
science is new in terms of being
important to our government
to the world itself and so the scientist
does not really know his place in
society and society does not know his
place either
well
on that score dr lap tell me this when
you and other scientists
worked on the atomic bomb at the
manhattan project and elsewhere
did you
as a group never sit down at night after
work in a bull session and talk about it
and say
this is an evil thing that we're doing
we are planning mass murder
mike we did think about this i must
confess that uh i myself was very busy
on the technical end i had three jobs
all rolled into one so i was working
from eight in the morning until midnight
but we did hold
especially toward the end of the war we
held meetings behind the guarded area
when we talked about what the
consequences of this would be we
realized that we could not keep this
as an atomic monopoly for ourselves that
it would get out other nations would
have it
and we realized then that we would be in
a very serious situation so we thought
about these things
uh we as a matter of fact i remember
very clearly some of these discussions
they led to the founding of a
magazine which is called the bulletin of
atomic scientist and i don't know if i
wasn't going to do this mike but uh if
you don't mind my doing it i'll just
show you the this little magazine which
has turned out to be one of the most
reliable news sources on atomic energy
and we founded this magazine as a means
of communicating with ourselves
and then when we
uh found others were interested
sociologists political scientists we
brought them into the fold too so there
were scientists among you dr lapp who at
the very time that you were making the
atom bomb said to yourselves maybe we
ought to pull back
maybe we should go no further with this
bomb we really do not know what force we
are
unleashing
the thought was given to this but we
felt on the basis of intelligence which
was made available to us
uh through the army intelligence we felt
that we were in a race
to beat the germans to this weapon
and and such and so the evidence did
indicate at the time we later found out
that we were incorrect but the germans
didn't get the first base but
nonetheless we felt we were in that race
and our worry was where would the united
states be if hitler turned up with this
weapon and we did not have it of course
so here was our dilemma drew pearson
wrote back on january 23rd in 1950
about the tormented group of scientists
who made the atomic bombs used at
hiroshima and nagasaki and he added that
when these scientists saw photographs
of these cities after the atomic attack
quote
their souls were on fire
do you remember sir how you personally
felt
when you first heard about those
bombings
i'm trying to recall now mike it is a
good long time ago and i think that my
uh feelings were one of release that
here we had been working on something
that we couldn't tell anybody about as i
recall at the time i was one of two
people in chicago who knew that the bomb
would be dropped that week
and i had a feeling of release that at
last we could talk about this thing and
expose it to the normal process of
democracy and see uh what the
reaction would be i myself did not have
a guilt feeling at that time but i'll
tell you mike i had a pretty traumatic
experience last month
now i have a moment to tell you surely i
was in the city of hiroshima
it
was my first visit
and i uh the director of the museum
kept it open he had some school children
going through and kept it open so i
could go through and see the museum was
late
and as i went into this museum and saw
these horrible pictures of people lying
on the floors with terrible burns i saw
these little japanese children
and my wife and i stood there obviously
americans and these little children five
years old looked up at us and i couldn't
help but feel a sense of of guilt about
this
it was for me a traumatic experience
now you dropped your scientific research
several years ago to go on a kind of a
crusade to warn against the perils of
radiation
are you doing this and have
and do other scientists
do this perhaps to save
a guilty conscience for having helped to
create this destructive power
that's that's a really
deep question mike i have in talking
with a very famous science yesterday uh
he explained something of what i am he
said you're a mutant
um i guess i am kind of a mutant but
frankly when i saw the power of this
weapon and saw the conditions in the
world i felt that we ought to discuss
this thing in the open to tell the truth
about it and so i guess i did start out
on kind of a crusade to tell about these
things there aren't many people doing
this
and i feel that really with these
hearings that have uh ended
this week in congress i feel that
there's kind of a big cycle in my life
is over
let's talk
your life in this regard is over you
mean yes
let's talk about what drives not just
you
but what drives a scientist
h.l menken once wrote he said what
actually urges the scientist on is not
some idea of service
but a boundless almost pathological
thirst to penetrate the unknown the
scientist makin said is not the
liberator releasing slaves not the good
samaritan lifting up the fallen
but a dog sniffing tremendously at an
infinite series of rat holes
how do you explain this thirst for the
unknown in the scientists the the
snipping at rattles that men can talk so
mike it is difficult i think to explain
this to a person who has never done
creative research
to explain the thrill that you get when
you do something for the first time when
you so to speak unlock a door of nature
that has never been opened before there
is a reward that is given to you a
feeling of fulfillment
that is the uh i think one of the
greatest rewards that a scientist can
can have i remember the first time i
really got a real concrete original
result of my own i was up in the it was
kind of like the mad scientist scene i
was up in the top of a botany building
it was late at night i had to change all
of my film and this cosmic ray equipment
late at night and i had this film going
through and i have about a hundred
geiger counters all of which were
rattling away and i was looking for a
connection between two events that
hadn't been related before and all of a
sudden while i looked into
this machine this very rare event
happened as i watched the needle of the
scale swung over and the geiger counters
clicked at the same time and i had
actually observed a coincidence between
events which had never been connected
before and i had a real feeling of
elation this is the kind of thing that
of tremendous power yes it is a feeling
of penetration which may consent it it
is also i think the the motivation of
the scientist here is that of a small
boy he has an intense curiosity
which he must fulfill
not for the end result that is in what
it will do to uh humankind eventually
but rather just the battle itself
yes i think the penetration of the
unknown all by itself
you know you're actually touching upon
the title of a new book i'm going to do
two years from now it's called into the
unknown
i'd like to touch now if i may on the
conflict between science and religion dr
lapp with a question that uh i'd like
you to think over for a moment before
answering the british scientist and
nobel prize winner brooklyn russell once
said
religion is based primarily and mainly
on fear and he added
science
has forced its way step by step against
the christian religion against churches
science can help us get over this craven
fear
in which mankind has lived for so many
generations
i'd like to know your opinion
of that charge by brethren russell
and we'll get dr lap's answer to that
question in less than 30 seconds
and now dr lap for that question
again berkman russell says religion is
based primarily on fear science he says
has forced its way step by step against
the christian religion against churches
and then he goes on science can help us
to get over this craven fear in which
mankind has lived for so many
generations
what do you think of that mike this is
an area in which i don't profess to be
uh at all well grounded i have longed to
have the time to study more about this
and i think i shall have soon
but i would like to say that i think
both strive for the same thing which is
the search for the truth
i was as a matter of fact thinking about
this in church this morning when i heard
a dr davies in washington speak last
week he'd spoken about radioactive
fallout and this week he spoke about
civilization
and what he said i've just jotted it
down here in the back of this church
announcement he said civilization is the
story of catastrophe and senseless
destruction
now i think
that science has brought into this this
world picture in which religion has
played such a dominant part at times a
chaotic part
i think now science has brought into
this world picture a new force
i think that the means of destruction
which are now present if we can foresee
them are such
that we have for the first time in the
history of this planet a real reason to
avoid war may i say that this can be
pretty well spelled out by this i just
happen to bring this along its life
magazine for this week and on the chat
on the page on radioactive fallout they
had a map
and this map shows what the united
states would look like if you had a
number of bombs not a very large number
said to be within russian capability in
a few years you would have a radioactive
fallout over the united states
the impact of this upon the united
states is the thing that has always
worried me
let me ask you this are most scientists
whom you know
religious men god-fearing men
there was a survey i'll try to answer
that there was a survey taken some time
ago back in 1921 by professor james luba
of grynmore college now this wasn't the
one i was thinking of dr milliken took
one too i happen to have been close to
uh professor arthur compton uh who
as you know comes from a deeply
religious uh family
my feeling is that scientists are not
much different from anybody else
i believe that
the uh
that they are no more or less religious
than ordinary groups but my own feeling
is that a scientist ought to be
i've often felt that that a scientist
ought to be a religious man
perhaps not in terms of church going
but i believe that when one penetrates
into the mystery of science you see so
much the scientist has
the key to open the door to a vast
understanding let's talk about one
specific conflict between science and
religion dr lap just last week you
proposed the establishment of a sperm
bank
now according to your plan healthy male
sperm would be stored like blood is
stored now
so that in case of a nuclear war would
be able to propagate the human race with
healthy sperm rather than with sperm
that has been exposed to radiation sperm
which
uh might breed deformed infants yes we
asked a spokesman for the roman catholic
church jesuit father john lafarge
for his reaction to that proposal and he
said the catholic church would be
against that idea it's merely a form of
artificial insemination which the church
opposes
isn't this an instance
of irreconcilable conflict between
science and religion
so tough one let me tell you first of
all that when i made this proposal
before the congressional committee i
interpolated into my prepared testimony
because
my feeling was that we have
very uh little chance after a war like
this to keep the human race alive
and that i really wanted to point out to
to to kind of jolt the senators who were
sitting up there in front of me with the
great seriousness of this problem and i
pointed out that the only thing you
could do to help yourself would be to
protect the one side of the human
equation in reproduction that it's
possible to protect which is
the human sperm now you weren't really
serious about your proposal for a sperm
bank but you were using it just a
dramatic effect i said that i introduced
it because of the bizarre nature that i
found it very difficult to propose this
but if you were serious about saving
human uh to propagating
our particular
form of civilization then i think you
would have to take account and my own
feeling and by the way i've had two
years of just political training myself
my own feeling is that we would have to
adjust ourselves to the new
circumstances
one final question this is a really
tough one
it is indeed
one final question
suppose conceivably science could
invent an instrument
a source of fantastic energy that would
be a great good
to mankind but that also
might enable the scientist
literally to destroy the entire world
with the push of a button
as a scientist
would you help invent that force
i would not
i think this is a case where we are
finding that scientists are coming more
are becoming more and more socially
conscious
i think in this case i would refuse i
might tell you that some of my friends
very good friends at the end of the war
1945
looked at this atomic bomb and they said
i would rather do my research somewhere
else and they went off and became
biologist radiobiologist and went off
into this field they made the decision
for themselves but my own feeling and if
i can come back to where we started mike
for just a second my own feeling is that
some people may argue with the
scientists and their arguments about
radioactive fallout but how would you
the people feel
if we as scientists did not speak out
and thank you dr lap for coming here and
speaking out tonight
the father of the atomic age dr albert
einstein once told his students concern
for man himself and his fate must always
form the chief interest of all your
technical endeavors never forget this
in the midst of your diagrams and
equations
for dr ralph lap the diagrams and
equations that led to the awful atom
bomb led also to soul searching
and to a deeper compassion programming
please email us at
c3history at c-span.org
cory margaret mcbride became known as
the first lady of radio for a pioneering
radio career in which she conducted over
30 000 interviews in 1957 instead of
asking the questions mcbride answered
them on the mike wallace interview
program
she considered her long career and spoke
on subjects ranging from tv commercials
to bull fighting to prohibition this
program runs almost 25 minutes
the mike wallace interview
good evening i'm mike wallace what
you're about to witness is an
unrehearsed uncensored interview my
guest
has been called the first lady of radio
you see her behind me she's mary
margaret mcbride
she has interviewed on radio some 30 000
persons since 1934.
tonight we'll try to find out what mary
margaret thinks about her housewife
audiences
about religion spinster hood politics
and bikini bathing suits
their opinions are not necessarily mine
the stations are my sponsors full of
mars incorporated but whether you agree
or disagree we feel that none will deny
the right of these views to be broadcast
we'll talk with mary margaret in just a
moment
and now to our story
mary margaret mcbride has been a gentle
trailblazer all her life
while most of her friends were looking
for husbands
she left paris missouri to track down
news beats as a reporter in new york
city during the roaring twenties
beginning in 1934 she spearheaded radio
journalism by interviewing ex-convicts
and statesmen
burlesque queens and society matrons
with a single-minded dedication that
gave her virtually no time at all for a
private life
let's try to find out among other things
why
she has done it
mary margaret according to the kansas
city star
on march 13 1955 you said on the evening
of march 12 1955 out in kansas city
you said the following
had i married the first man i was
engaged to and settled here in missouri
i would have made my children miserable
i would have reminded them that if it
wasn't for them
i'd be famous in new york
now then
why
seriously now why was
being famous here in new york city so
all out important to you
don't you understand that any any uh ham
understands that
you know very well you understand it
you're confessing to being a ham and
you're calling me one as one and the
same we're both hands honey we're both
hams
and
that was it how i got to be a ham born
on a farm in missouri i don't know but i
did and it was the one thing i wanted to
be famous and yet
at the same time you were willing to
sacrifice a lot of other things for that
hamdon but i didn't know i didn't know i
was sacrificing
it was so important
you don't know
at the time the drive was there and you
stayed with it yes
well now chances are
some
30 35 years later
that you're typical of a good many
career women who have chosen that career
instead of a family you once said mary
margaret and this was in the women's
home companion back in april 49 you said
my programs are my whole life
and though you admitted that it was a
temporary kind of thing you described
your interviews on radio as
conversational love affairs
now then have these conversational love
affairs
been worth
devoting virtually your entire life to
you've worn me down mike what do you
mean well
you had me on one other time when you
were local
and
i said that there had been enough
now i'm not so sure i think you just
wore me down what do you mean
i had you on the local show about uh six
months ago yes at that time you were
convinced
that everything was fine it had been
worth it now you really mean that you've
changed your mind
i really mean that i i wonder about it
and i suppose i always did wonder about
it i suppose any woman wonders
but as you know my life has changed
somewhat
i had a business partnership
that
well that kept me going at the kind of
thing i was doing
made it possible
you know i'm not a tough person you're
not i'm the kind of person mike who
absolutely says to you or anybody else
what i really think at the time
and in business
and on television and radio 2
you don't you say a dozen other things
first and then finally you come to
whatever is your real answer i don't
know how to do that well now very much
but i think perhaps we're arriving at
something here you said six months ago
one thing you've changed your mind a
little bit is it television
that has got you down here was a woman
who for a period of a quarter of a
century talked to virtually everybody in
the united states of consequence had a
chance to talk to draw them out and so
forth you were
the first lady of radio
is the
the feeling of a lack of fulfillment now
due simply to the fact that television
has not proved to be your great golden
road
i think probably
but i think just the thought you know
stericon
fended off the blows the things that you
have to take stella khan of course was
your good friend and manager for years
and years and years who died about two
and a half months ago
and
when i uh when i
talked to you i knew she was very ill
but i i didn't know that she was fatally
ill i thought she'd beat the thing she
had cancer
and
i i was talking then about what i really
love i i do love
the job i love interviewing people i
love those
love affairs on the air
the kind of fame the kind of career that
you pursued mary margaret
was it not at all a lonely life for a
woman yes has it not been and has the
one been worth the loneliness has the
career been worth the lonelings
it was up to a point now i'm not sure
that's what i'm trying to say i'm just
in a very uncertain state of mind
and i'm not sure
whether i think that those 20 years
when i was interviewing people
it was very worthwhile
i worked till all hours and the amount
on people were pitting me that says how
do you do this you never have any fun
why don't you have fun what's life for
and i would and i would kind of pity
myself for a lot of things gee why do i
do this and then one time i just
analyzed it and i suddenly knew this is
what i like
i do this because it's it's the thing i
like i used to have my office in my home
i used to broadcast from my home and it
was wonderful for me when they all got
out and i was there along with my books
for the next day and
the dress
they weren't there of course in prison
but they were there with me and for 24
hours
they were my study they were everything
to me sure and then i could
put them on the air and out there i knew
were my real friends who
wanted to hear about these people they
write me to this day my that they now
know famous people
better than they ever would have known
if i hadn't had them of course now that
that means a lot to me mary margaret
on the surface
and i'm not so sure that it isn't well
built beneath the surface too but on the
surface you seem a good deal less
sophisticated much gentler than most
people in radio and television but some
people who know you have different other
and other ideas for instance
syndicated columnist robert ruark
good friend of yours yes
he wrote this about you back in 49 he
said behind this frilly facade
she has a head as hard as a paving block
and a canny brain
that could tangle with andrei gromyko
and come out at least even
is the merry mother that we've seen
through the years and that we see here
tonight just to facade an act by a
shrewd businesswoman mary margaret oh my
dear my it's unworthy of you
you know very well it isn't an act
maybe i have some brains somewhere but
if they don't show then maybe i haven't
why did barbara walk right back do you
think was he just having fun well he he
always has fun he says that uh that he
was really mayor margaret and brad all
these years he said that the other day
on the air now he's a comedian
you know he he writes funny columns
i i i think that everybody has tried to
figure how i could do it
you read those early pieces i did about
me they called me a phenomenon and you
could just tell that these sophisticated
people were thinking how does this
female do it
here she is really dumb they thought and
she stutters and stammers around and
stumbles all over the place and yet here
are these women that'll buy the things
she says for them to buy and they never
took in account the men and i had a lot
of men listeners too though
well what has happened to all this now
tell me
[Music]
yes
well three years ago or we gave up the
interview programs and we didn't because
of stella
because she was no longer able to fight
as she'd been
fighting
to to carry this on and
she didn't want to talk about it and i
certainly didn't want to talk about it
and people didn't know at all
they we said that i was tired that i've
been on the air 20 years and it was true
i was tired i'd worked hard and i hadn't
had very many vacations
so that was the truth that there was a
deeper truth
and i don't tell you that those three
years were
very difficult years because i am a ham
and during those three years there were
times when i couldn't turn on radio or
television because i wanted so much
to be part of it
so here's a an extraordinary situation
really here's here's a woman in her
middle 50s who's had a wonderful and a
distinguished and
a an exciting and a worthwhile career
who is now in a sense
all dressed up with no place to go i
asked bob york the other day uh if on
the air too
whether he thought i would have to take
the conflict now
i was thinking of you of course because
you know you're supposed to be a person
who needles
and i never was supposed to kneel and
yet there you know there are people who
think we got somewhat the same results
i was struck by that in reading old
material of yours stories about you
about that fact people often said things
that i didn't know they were going to
say and that i'm sure they didn't know
they were going to say is because they
forgot where we were don't you imagine
do you ever get sued mary montgomery no
never did
did you
not yet
you're right
tell me this mary margaret uh
when i talked to you on the local show
again last winter you said something
that i didn't have a chance to follow up
on this is a pure gossip column item but
i have to get it straight
you said something to the effect that
some years ago when you were in rome
you seriously considered having a child
you know yes well you you nearly warned
me in missoula
i love my inactive a very nice man
indeed
said quite seriously and
soberly and sadly
that in one hour i
tore down everything i had spent my life
building up
because he thought it sounded so
depraved
no of course you'd like to tell us
the complete story and let's find out
well i went to rome and i met this nice
man
neapolitan
and i fell a little in love with him and
it was about the period in my life when
i decided that of everything in the
world i'd rather have
that i didn't have it would be a
daughter so i seriously considered
marrying this man and i thought if i
marry him in rome
i can
well get pregnant and go back to new
york and have the baby and have it all
to myself
this was my idea but i assure you i
meant to marry the man marry him and
then leave him marry me yes i did
that was what i meant to do but i didn't
do it at all what stopped you
well
he
he seemed to have different ideas about
marriage than i did i mean he wanted to
marry you and then have you stay there
in rome and come back to new york
it was just about the time when
mussolini was
going strong and i didn't think i'd like
rome do you think really no i'm quite
sure do you think that would have been a
good idea though seriously to marry a
man just for the purpose of having a
child then coming on first i don't know
you know why i said that to you that
night i i just suddenly we've been
talking long and i've been having fun
and i just remembered how much fun it
was when people said unexpected things
and it just came to me and i said it
i've regretted it a few times it sounded
a good deal more emancipated than it
really was yes i'm afraid mary marvin
you once said according to sidney fields
column in the uh daily mirror
back in 53 you said age teaches you
that the values you once thought were
corny are not corny
now specifically what values did you
mean
well i think perhaps i told you that
when i first came to new york
the people i liked did all sorts of
things that i thought were
almost wicked and yet i thought because
these people did them they're the things
i must learn to do
[Music]
and they
gossiped and they
were often uncalm they were sarcastic
there were all kinds of things you did
all of those things too
i tried
i don't think i succeeded very well
because even then i i
haven't i have a guilty conscience
i always feel guilty about things
and now i know that kindness and decency
and
and that the kind of things i was taught
are the real things
as you get older you just know that i
don't care if i'm called corny now at
all
you have apparently lost at least one
value
from your missouri upbringing you come
from baptist stock don't you yes
your grandfather was a preacher that's
right but i understand that you almost
never attend church how come this is
true
i think it's because i remember asking
you the same question about me looking
and you said you don't go to church
either
but you're not very much no
i i
i think i'm religious
but i i
church
i i hate to say this because church is a
comfort to a lot of people
and i'm not one to be copied in this
respect at all but for me church doesn't
help my religion
now and then yes and if my if i had a
chance to go and hear my grandfather
again in salem missouri i'd go in a
minute and and i think i'd come away
with something but formal religion as
such doesn't do much do you pray may i
yes i do by yourself yes
i couldn't live without that
do you
tell me to stop if you if you want me to
marry margaret do you ask for things
when you pray
not anymore
what do you mean
because i don't think that that is
prayer really
prayer is getting in touch with the
power that's greater than you are
and trying to get to the point where you
can relax
and lean back as if you were in a
hammock and let things happen to you now
don't think for a minute that i have got
to that point because i haven't but
that's that's what i'd like then i'd be
the poised serene
kind of person
who
wouldn't be second grade ever wouldn't
have a single second rate ambition
because hams were second grade what i
don't understand about you mary margaret
is this you keep talking as though
as though you don't have much confidence
in yourself no man but why here is a
woman here you are
a person who has contributed so much to
so many people through so many years
you've gotten personal acclaim you've
had professional success you have good
friends you have the respect of your
peers in this business
and the respect of your friends out of
the business and yet you
you seem to feel unfulfilled why
you wouldn't watch those or
psychiatrists would say it's something
that i've never resolved something that
happened to me when i was young we were
poor i worried about my mother i'm
worried about mortgages i worried about
everything i was the oldest child
in the family and the only girl
and i think that had a lot to do with it
i i'm sure i told you
that
i i always have the feeling
that they'll find out that i'm not as
good as they thought and it'll all end
and it went on and on and they didn't
so couldn't fall
mary margaret i imagine you've sold more
products for more sponsors than
virtually anybody else in the business
now i'd like to talk to you
about something totally different now
about
commercials
the park carl sandberg said last week
about television commercials according
to time magazine june 17th he said more
than half the commercials are filled
with inanity assimility silliness and
cheap trickery
do you agree with mr sanders
i'm afraid i do you do what is a good
television commercial
i think that honesty is the first
principle of a commercial
honesty
i could never
talk about a product that i didn't
believe in but can't you dress honesty
up in an appealing
in a different uh facade in a different
costume and still have it honest can't
you make it entertaining and honest at
the same time
i didn't say that it couldn't be
entertaining i don't know what he's
talking about did he go and say what he
did but i don't have all of it of course
he he went on he railed against
television for a considerable length of
time on the speech before i believe it
was before a ladies club down in
virginia or west virginia somewhere well
lots of people think the commercials are
too long
i used to have a phone system with mine
sometimes they will i have been known to
do 15 minutes of commercial all at one
time but then the next day i might do
one minute for 17 products
so i kind of evened it up
i think it just depends but of course i
realize you can't do that and that's
what somebody my old kind of thing you
can't do it now you couldn't do that on
television yes you could
i could and yes you could and it's
criminal truly it's criminal but the
television audience of the united states
doesn't have a chance to see you doing
it all right now mary margaret
you've quizzed others in the past i quiz
you
bullfighting what do you think about it
well i went to one bullfight in spain
and i'm afraid i got sick did you
i can't see it i can't even see hunting
mice yet uh new york we certainly are
giving him a lot of publicity he said
he'd state don't you which is the
trite
uh accusation
what about boxing on television
i can't even look at that
and no not until they told me that they
don't really hurt each other
what well that's what somebody told me
whoever told you that is wrong oh well
then i won't look at it
prohibition
well i
i was in new york you know during
prohibition and was pretty awful a
bathtub gin that people went around
drinking the way everybody felt first to
drink it was a matter of honor with him
no i'm against prohibition
you you'd think my grandfather's
granddaughter would be for it wouldn't
you but i'm against prohibition it
didn't prohibit that's why right
legalized gambling
i'm against that
why well i'm just against gambling
of any country yes
do you know why
not a question of religious scruples
well i'm afraid it is
i think that it was just that i
we couldn't even play cards we could
play flinch and offers which i found out
later resembled card playing you know
and i couldn't dance
and i was very strictly bought up and a
lot of it has stuck
and the gambling thing is stuck it's
funny how a good deal of that has a way
of hanging on
bikini bathing suits
now what a question to ask me about all
i know about them is that the young
girls look pretty in them old ladies
look horrible in them and i could never
wear one
how's that
uh
you know talking about missouri let's go
back there for just an instant
profile of you in the new yorker
magazine back in 42 1942
noted the contrast between you and
the often worldly guests that you
interviewed on the air the article said
it is not irrelevant to remark that in
paris missouri where mary margaret was
born husbands and wives
sit next to each other at parties what
is your opinion mary margaret of the uh
somewhat more emancipated manners
of your friends in show business the
arts
well don't you think
that things have changed even in paris
missouri now
communications has done that
they know
they probably never sit next to each
other anymore
and a lot of things happen there
divorces happen there all kinds of
things happen there now that never
happened when i was a little girl
growing up
about your friends people in the
business in show business and the arts
and so forth who are your good friends
mary margaret when you see a good deal
off
they mainly aren't
in
a newspaper people artists a couple of
artists who live
you know the haters lord and elmer hater
they've been my friends all these years
since i've been new york i never i never
cultivated these love affairs that we
talked about that i had before the
microphone
somewhere there was never time
sometimes people would ask you to do
things and i would think it would be
wonderful to do it but
my friends are the people that i've had
all these years
can i persuade you to have a cup of tea
with me tonight after we get through you
certainly may
i think you're doing a wonderful job i
don't think this is the thing i'm
permitted to say but well then don't you
say it i'm for you
mary margaret thank you mary
you're now 58 years old
not quite not quite
we have just a minute for this answer
as i said before you have personal
acclaim professional success
good friends
what do you want for yourself
from here on
i want
i would like
work that i love
and that i enjoy doing and that will
give service at the same time i would
like
personal relationships that satisfy me i
think i would like to be very important
to
somebody i think everybody wants to be
very important to at least one person
i'm sure of that and i i would like very
much to
to be doing things that give
that help the world to be a little bit
better place
as you get older that that matters to
to my surprise really
bless you mary margaret and thank you
for coming here tonight thank you
a girl from paris missouri mary margaret
mcbride
took on new york at the height of the
bathtub gin era and in the past 30 years
she's traveled the world she's met the
international set she's dealt with
high-powered sponsors
but the unusual thing about mary
margaret
one writer has observed
is that she is still a wide-eyed
innocent
in a world of radiant marvels
roy morris junior's book fraud of the
century rutherford b hayes samuel tilden
3 history at cspan.org
journalist mike wallace once described
senator james eastland of mississippi as
the voice of the white south when
senator eastland appeared on his
interview show in 1957
a civil rights bill was then pending in
the u.s senate mr wallace talked with
senator eastland about southern
opposition to racial integration this
program runs about 25 minutes
the mike wallace interview
tonight we go after the story of racial
conflict from a united states senator
who has been called the voice of the
white south
you see him behind me he's senator james
eastland of mississippi
if you're curious to know what senator
easton thinks of the ku klux klan
the law of the land slavery
and segregation in the north
will go after those stories in just a
moment my guest's opinions are not
necessarily mine the stations are my
sponsors philip morris incorporated but
whether you agree or disagree we feel
that none will deny the right of these
views to be broadcast
and now to our story
tonight rather than explore the details
of the civil rights bill now pending in
the senate we're going after the story
behind the south's opposition
to the integration of the races
senator james easton of mississippi
speaks for a vast part of the white
south
which believes negro and white should
live in peace but separately separate
schools separate restaurants separate
theaters
now and forever
let's try to find out why
first of all senator let me ask you this
i think the thing that is hard for some
northerners to understand
is that southern whites apparently have
no objection
to everyday contact with one kind of
negro
that is the necessary contact with negro
handymen maids butlers chauffeurs
and the like
yet the white south doesn't want contact
with negroes as social equals in schools
theaters restaurants on buses and the
like now
what is the logic behind that
mike the
your premise is wrong how so southern
people believe
in absolute economic equality
between the races
and i think you will find that in the
southern states
you find more negro property owners
more professional men
more school teachers
and more business well let's understand
the fact that they have made more
progress than they have
in any other section of the country
now this doctrine
of
except of the separation of the races
has been evolved over many years by both
races
it's not something that one race
has imposed upon another race
it's not a badge of inferiority
or superiority
when you're talking about economic
equality center what i'm talking about
is social equality now i'm getting to
that
uh
it's found
throughout the years that you have more
harmony and that the races can
make more progress
under a system
of separate
white might interest you to know this
now
uh
after the south was defeated
when the white people were disfranchised
and could not vote
the first reconstruction legislature of
my state
controlled by members of the naval race
past three laws
one
that there be segregation
on trains
and in public transportation
two
that there be a separate school system
three
they levied a poll tax
four
they made the the they made it a felony
for the races to innovate and provided a
life sentence and penitentiary
for one who crossed that line
in south carolina during reconstruction
wait wait just a second if i may
interrupt adjustments
the only thing is we have a good deal of
material to cover and i don't want to
get bogged down on this one but what i'm
talking about now let's take south
carolina well now senator they passed a
poll tax
they operated dual schools all over the
south
now that's all i have to say senator
that is not responsive to the question
that i put to you what i'm driving at is
this if a negro maid or nurse
is good enough to care for a white
infant in the south live with that
infant feed that infant and so forth
why is not that same negro maid allowed
to eat in the same restaurant with
southern whites i want to know the
reason behind it it's a matter of choice
choice by the white no it's a matter of
choice by both races are you suggesting
they have just told you that they
that a reconstruction legislature con
composed principally of negros
enacted our segregation statutes are you
i'm suggesting that the vast majority of
the negroes
want their own schools
their own hospitals
their own churches
their own restaurants their own buses
well now it would be impractical to
operate two
two sets of buses certainly martin
luther king martin luther king told us
that for nearly a year senator 95 of the
negroes in montgomery alabama walked or
rode in car pools rather than ride in
segregated buses evidently you're
suggesting me now that that wasn't that
wasn't the fact that uh
the trouble in montgomery
started cause of mistreatment
on the buses
now there is no law to uh to date that
that will would force
integration on buses
and yet the races segregate themselves
on buses you are you suggesting i'm
saying you just might want segregation
too oh but certainly the negro in the
south wants 99
yes and then a man
i've tried to make it clear that they
enacted the segregation laws
martin luther king we talked about this
problem with him a few days ago the
reverend martin luther king he's the
negro minister who led that montgomery
alabama bus boycott as you know and he
told us as follows senator eastman he
said
most southern whites
will associate with the negro in a
master servant relationship only it's an
attempt to keep the majority of negroes
as menials he said southern
reactionaries he went on want to
maintain a system of human values that
develop during slavery days now what
about that well that's absolutely
incorrect now the biggest business in my
home is a negro insurance company
i employ a [ __ ] in an executive
capacity
uh
no that that is not true as i said we
have more negro professional men more
businessmen
we have substantial negro cotton
planters
in fact they have made more progress in
the south and in the north
the master servant relationship today is
largely a northern product
the master servant is largely in my sure
you because you have more of negroes in
business and then the professions in the
south than in any other area of the
country senator let me ask you this
question a hundred years ago
southerners owned slaves
they bought and sold human beings from
an auction block
do you think that those slave owners did
something that was morally wrong
well certainly i think human slavery
is morally wrong now
you know it slavery was not a peculiar
southern institution by no means this
whole country had slavery
and it's very interesting that when the
constitution of the united states was
adopted
that the southern delegates to that
constitutional convention
wanted to stop the slave trade
immediately
and it was a delegates from new england
who protested
and so they wrote into the constitution
of the united states that the american
congress could not stop the slave trade
prior to december 31st 1807.
they did it over the protest of the
southern delegates to that convention
who wanted to abolish it at that time
but i think that you'll agree that there
were very few abolitionists in the south
time of the war between the states well
i think the war between the states was
caused by
other reasons
other reasons and the abolition of
slavery why certainly
dare i ask you when i say dare i ask you
i i mean that we only have a half an
hour tonight and i wanted to get to some
rather more pressing issues so maybe i'd
better forget about that and we can take
that up another time so all right
now that we we've been talking about
momentarily about the race issue from a
national viewpoint
let's look at it from an international
angle center eastland at what it does to
our prestige abroad
the official communist newspaper the
soviet union proud
had this to say about negro white
tensions in america back in september
9th september 10 1956 they said
how can one measure the bitter cup of
humiliation and suffering
from which the negro people in the
united states have been forced to drink
at schools in buses and trains
everywhere there are restrictions on
negroes imposed by the whites alone
and they went on to say there is the
much praised democracy and freedom for
you it is this democracy which
washington dc is trying to export that's
the quote
now that we won't comment upon the
believability the credibility or what we
feel about pravda but i'd like to put
this question to you
here is propaganda sent around the world
how do you think that propaganda like
that
affects our relations
with millions upon millions of colored
persons in africa and asia countries
whose friendship we want and need well
here's what i think about that
now that is of course you'll admit
communist propaganda
they have said
that the laboring man in the united
states is a safe
they have charged that we have slavery
in the united states
they have said the president of the
united states
plans atomic war
they have called the american people
thieves
murderers
butchers
i say it's communist propaganda
and nobody in the world in the free
world pays any attention to communist
propaganda
are you suggesting that this does not
have a certain effect upon the colored
peoples of the world senator i couldn't
i couldn't see where the colored people
of the world would fall
for propaganda
i certainly they're all statements
from the soviet union
and i'd like to call your attention to
this fact
there are more segregated schools in the
soviet union
than in any country in the world
now that i'd like to hear more about
there are more segregated schools
segregation of what kinds
on racial lines
you mean colored people they don't have
colored people
you've certainly read the reports from
people who have been in the soviet union
on that point there's no
case no doubt about the more segregated
schools in the soviet union and in the
united states yes
they practice racial segregation in
their schools but that's not the point
the point is that that's propaganda
against this country just the same
propaganda is when they say that we are
butchers and thieves and murderers when
you say propaganda there is certainly
more than an atom of truth in this and
if we want and need the friendship of
the colored peoples of the world will
they not pick upon this and say this is
the way we treat our colored people in
the universe to begin with is not an
atom of truth in that statement it's
just communist propaganda in other words
when they say it couldn't affect any
intelligent person he's spotted for what
it is communist propaganda all right
senator false words were on the part of
the soviet union
let's come back here to the united
states you obviously oppose integration
of southern schools
so vigorously not only because you feel
it would be a bad thing but because you
feel i understand
that it could never work properly is
that not so
well i don't think it will work you
don't
in another southern area louisville
kentucky the superintendent of schools
omar carmichael had this to say about
integration in his city
he said we expected desegregation to
work
but it's worked beyond our fondest hope
now if it can work in southern
louisville kentucky why can't it work in
mississippi
well to begin with
they have very little racial integration
in louisville kentucky
now if he says it worked there
it certainly didn't work a few miles
from there at clay kentucky
or at sturgis kentucky
or at clinton tennessee
and if i read the new york papers right
i see on yesterday that there was
announced a zoning plan for schools in
new york city by the superintendent of
schools
and a statement from the chairman of the
urban league of new york city that that
was de facto segregation in the schools
of new york city well that has nothing
to do actually sir with a question that
i asked you well if it can be made to
work raise a question as to the south
yeah that's one thing but you say
when the same thing is happening in the
north then that's something else
no i'm
in a sense here i'm the fellow who's
supposed to ask the question
i've i i have asked you
and i put it to you candidly if this is
a very serious uh appointed issue here
if superintendent carmichael can make it
work because of the way he's prepared in
louisville kentucky then it is possible
that it can work in other places in the
south
well i think uh no i think well you have
a real racial problem
that it will not work
now and you feel there's no real racial
problem i feel this is as to my state
neither race wants it
i think there are those who would say
your name let's take another look at the
problem of the negro in the south and
that is voting
we read in national publications like
time magazine for instance the negroes
in the south turned down for
registration to vote
because of unfair literacy tests
questions like for instance how many
bubbles are there in a bar of soap or
how many persons are there in the
payroll of the united states government
the negro who wants to register to vote
can't answer it successfully therefore
he's turned down on the basis of being
illiterate
what knowledge have you of this kind of
test senator eastman well i have enough
knowledge
of those allegations to know
that there's nothing to them
now your first statement was how many
bubbles in a bar soap
that was a fable
that was published
in the magazine the nation
more than 30 years ago
and was exploded at that time
senator senator according to today's
let's not go back to the nation magazine
30 years ago according to today's
washington sunday star
such tests came to light when negro
leaders gave quote sworn testimony
before the senate judiciary committee
unquote of which you're the head
yes and uh
one of those witnesses
who gave testimony like that
was asked by senator irwin the chairman
of the
subcommittee which was conducting the
hearings
to come back the next morning and make
his statements
when he on the road
when he could be cross-examined
by senator irwin you know the right of
cross-examination
is vital to elicit what the facts are
this witness agreed
to do that
his mentor the naacp agreed
in the hearing to have him back
that night he was spirited out of the
city of washington
did not return
at those hearings uh which a witness
also
listed
two murders three murders
in the state of mississippi
that he said were caused by from voting
the press of the country carried it
allured accounts all over the country
condemning our people
yet the facts were
that in one of those cases
no such thing had ever happened well
senator are you sure
here's what i'm saying let me get
through now all right
another there was a road running down by
the side of a lake
a negro woman and her two children were
an automobile driving down by the side
of the road
down by the lake
she lost control of a car
and ran in
they went in and got her two children
out but were unable to get her out
now
that was charged
as a murder
in voting
let me just clean up one question let me
just clean this up this way all right
the leading negra editor in my state
in a front page editorial
after
that testimony
said that if they send somebody to
washington
they should send someone
who would give the facts
all right sir you're trying to bring the
facts to us tonight
let me ask you saying that no such
things have happened let me ask you this
are you suggesting
that your people down in the state of
mississippi
encourage negroes to register and vote
well we have no rate no voting
qualifications based on race
well under those circumstances
and anybody who's qualified can vote
well under those circumstances how is it
that only four percent four percent of
the qualified negroes are registered to
vote in your own state of mississippi
approximately twenty thousand negroes
out of a half a million of eligible well
now those statements are incorrect
we have over twenty thousand neighbors
who vote in the democratic primary in
the state of mississippi
but we have many more than that many
thousands more than that who are
registered i think
wait a minute let me get through now oh
no wait a minute now they do not vote
because they have a long history of
being of republicanism they are members
of the republican party and of course
they cannot vote in the democratic
primary which is the election in our
state the republican party doesn't even
run candidates
as far as your concerns
as far as you're concerned then you
would like to see every eligible negro
in mississippi vote
i would like to see
just what we have
four percent and that is well that's not
correct and i have said that was an
untrue state four percent vote you said
the twenty thousand vote and that's four
well i said in the democratic primary
in the primary but that we have many
thousands who don't vote in the
democratic primary because they are
republicans
and you'd like to see as many as
possible vote i would like to see is
just what we have
that everyone who is qualified
should vote qualify by reason of
our qualifications that are written in
the law that apply to all races alike
and you think that no tougher literacy
tests should be given let's say to a
negro than to a white right on our
gilbert all right
i'd like a couple of uh opinions sir
about
following
what is your opinion of the ku klux klan
well mike
i am against any organization
which indulges which promotes
racial and religious
prejudice
hatred and bigotry and you think the
clan does that i do from what i now the
only thing i know about the clan is what
i read there's not a ku klux klan
chapter in the state of mississippi
what is your opinion of john casper and
the seaboard citizens councils
well from what i read in the papers the
seaboard citizens council is an
anti-semitic organization
and i am very strongly opposed to it
now as for casper i don't know mr casper
i've never seen him
he's been sentenced to jail
he's got two sentences and i'm not going
to kick a man
who's down but i have no patience
with his tactics
senator you say that segregation in the
south is not a matter of prejudice or
caprice but a vital measure to protect
the white race
nor to protect both races to protect
both races
in view of that i'd like to know what
you think the north
should do about segregating the races
well what we are fighting for is a great
principle
and that is for each state to handle its
own domestic affairs
if the north wants segregation the
integration it's sarah fair
if new york wants it it's arafat
under our system of government the
genius of the american system is
controlled by the states of the domestic
affairs of the state
and we just want the right to handle it
in our states for the best interest of
all concerned and the way it is handled
is endorsed by 99 of the people of both
races
who live in peace and harmony and we
have more peace and harmony
than any section of the country we have
later i think we have less racial
prejudice i think mike i was in hawaii
last fall
and i talked to the wife
of one of the leading businessmen there
who had lived many years in the south
and had lived many years in new york
city and it lived many years in honolulu
and she made a statement that was very
significant she said that she really
learned racial tolerance in the south
i think that you could do the country of
great service sir by
presenting documented facts
to the effect
that 99 of the people of both races of
both races sir want segregation in your
state well i don't like there's any
doubt about that
it's very strange that we've never had a
suit file
for school integration in the state the
naacp has been unable
to get people to sign
bills of complaint or to authorize them
to bring suit
they're satisfied
you know
that's a question
of where every amateur is an expert
and where experience counts for no
we've worked out the system
that is harmonious i have just about a
minute left and i want to get
two quick answers if i can from you at
the outset we said that we didn't want
to get involved with the details of the
civil rights bill pending there's one
question that i would like to ask though
about this bill if the south does not
get what it wants in the way of
modifications i'm talking about section
40 trials will the south filibuster
mike i've been in the senate for many
years and i've never engaged in a
filibuster
the southern senators have never
filibustered
but
we have shown already the grave faults
in this bill through a campaign of
education and there will be a long
campaign of public education a long
campaign of public education will raise
the facts to to the to the people might
take as much as long as two or three so
they started this was
reconstruction bill number two
this is reconstruction bill number two
when it started that's what it was that
is now pending before the senate
one yes or no answer to this one if you
will sir do you think senator the day
will come in your lifetime
when we will see an integrated self
yes or no
no
thank you very much senator for spending
this time with us here in
washington
senator james easton of mississippi
speaks for a vast part of the white
south on the race issue
in the north senators with equal
conviction speak their lines
somewhere between these two polls
a compromise civil rights
[Applause]
arkansas governor orville falbas invited
the mike wallace interview program into
the governor's mansion in 1957
even as he continued to defy a federal
court order to integrate little rock
central high school in this interview he
explained why this program is about half
an hour
good evening what you're about to see is
an unrehearsed uncensored interview
i'm mike wallace and tonight we bring
you a special interview with governor
orville forbus
from the governor's mansion
in little rock arkansas
for the past two weeks governor porter
has defied a federal court order to
integrate little rock central high
school and he has thereby brought to
ahead the conflict between
state and federal power in this nation
governor paul has called out the
national guard to as he put it maintain
order
they will not act as segregationists or
integrationists he said
but in effect they were there to bar
negro students from the school
since then federal judge ronald davies
of the district court
has repeatedly ordered integration to
proceed forthwith and governor thought
us has defied this order
in an effort to resolve the conflict
governor forbes requested a face-to-face
meeting with president eisenhower that
meeting took place yesterday at newport
rhode island
the president emerged from the
conference with these words he said
the governor stated his intention to
respect the decisions of the united
states district court and to give his
full cooperation in carrying out his
responsibilities
in respect to these decisions
in view of this governor farmers first
of all let me ask you this and although
uh
people in arkansas don't talk much with
strangers as you said last week on
television
i hope that you'll talk some with me
tonight
well mr wallace will make an exception
in your case
a federal district court has already
ruled that little rock central high
school
should be integrated
and that reasons for preventing
integration now are anemic
in view of your promise to the president
will you respect this decision and give
your okay to integration beginning
tomorrow morning
uh previously given my okay to
integration
the
guard was not called out to prevent
integration
but to keep the peace and order of the
community and of course i disagree with
your preliminary statements that we are
in defiance of a federal court order
based upon the premise that the peace
and good order of a community is
paramount to all other issues i
understand that for a time
it would not be possible to
integrate without disorder and violence
i understand that but the specific
question
will you give your okay to integration
tomorrow morning
if it could be accomplished in a
peaceful manner without any disorder and
without violence i have already so
stated as a witness in chancery court
and so now do you believe that that can
be accomplished peacefully and without
disorder tomorrow morning not at the
present time you feel that violence is
still a possibility yes therefore will
the national guard troops continue to
surround
central high school tomorrow morning
well the troops will still be on duty in
the morning
they will be
do you foresee their being taken away
from the school
this week it is possible
under what circumstances
under a condition of trans tranquility
and general acceptance by the people
which would then lessen
the possibility of disorder or violence
we will determine the state of
tranquility yourself
that has to be my responsibility because
the paramount obligation of the chief
executive of any state
is to maintain the peace and good order
of his state and communities how do you
determine when tranquility has been
arrived at governor
on the basis of facts and information
that are available to me
these facts and information
are they available only to you sir
no many of the facts and information are
known to many people in fact in a poll
of the little rock area
82 percent of the people agreed that
disorder and violence would have
occurred had not taken the action which
i did
why did not then the city officials
of little rock
agree to that
is it not true
is it not true but to begin with not one
city official was apprised of your
action
in placing the national guard around
that school ahead of time
no but the most of the city officials do
agree with me
only mayor mann
has spoken any disagreement
ahead of your putting the guard there
governor this is the point that i am
trying to make
as far as i have been able to gather
from the work that we've done here this
week
and that i have done here personally
there was not one city official not one
elected official here in little rock who
believed
that violence was about to break out you
seem to be the only official
who believed that well i have here you
have said many times that you have
documented evidence to the effect that
violence was about to break out
therefore
you put the national guard around the
school do you have that documentary
evidence here with you tonight sir
certainly that evidence has already been
turned over to the federal bureau of
investigation in my pledge of
cooperation with the justice department
to make it available
do you have any further evidence here
tonight who for instance you talked
about caravans converging on on little
rock he talked about armed troops and so
forth
groups of citizens who were coming here
to start violence who were these people
were they whites were they colored
people both
both and who were their leaders
i want to wait
this may be a matter of litigation in
the courts
well nonetheless you are an elected
official
of the state of arkansas right is it
therefore not your responsibility
to give to the people of arkansas and
now to the people of the nation this
documented evidence to prove that you
are right and that they have been wrong
all along in castigating you the people
of the state believe i am right
you say the people of the state believe
that you are right how in the world can
you tell that sir
well by a scientific poll for one thing
which has been taken
a scientific poll taken by whom
mid-south surveys
when do they take this survey
uh early last week in little rock and
then statewide
and they and and the results of the poll
of what 82 of the people of little rock
itself
concur
in the belief
that disorder and violence would have
occurred had i not taken the action
which i did and therefore you will take
the word of a survey to the effect that
82 of the people thought that you were
right and defy a court order no i in
order of the federal district court
we're not defining court order how do
you say that sir because the paramount
obligation is to keep the peace and good
order of a community if it interferes
for a time with certain other liberties
then that has always been the case in
the case of floods when we used to have
the great floods on the arkansas the
federal authorities could make a
decision to
dynamite and breach the levees and flood
hundreds of people out of their homes
weren't those people deprived of certain
privileges and liberties for the benefit
of the whole in that particular case
let's confine ourselves to this specific
all right but i'm giving you a parallel
governor tell me this you've called out
troops
to prevent a handful of negro children
from integration no
well
if you let me state my premise and then
you can answer it all right all right
you say that you did this to prevent
bodies
now let me ask you this why did you not
instead
assign a dozen troops to escort each
negro child to and from classes
thereby preventing violence and obeying
the order of the court at the same time
because the best way to prevent the
violence was to remove the cause
you would not have removed the cause
by that type of activity
you would have had the eminence of
disorder and violence within the school
and outside the school
and whether or not it breaks out in the
school it could break out in other
sections of the city
governor the plan for gradual
integration in little rock arkansas was
drawn up by the little rock school board
back in 1955.
now how is it that in the past two years
you as governor
have failed to see to it that the road
was properly paved for integration here
in little rock as other cities
throughout the border states of the
south have done our school districts are
an autonomous
part of government they're an
independent part of government in
themselves
and there are eight public school
districts within the state that have
integrated the state colleges
of which i report appoint the board
members
have integrated
the university has integrated all the
public transportation system both city
buses and all have integrated you've
said that man that has been left alone
to the decision of each one that was
affected but this you would not leave to
the decision of education carefully
because there was the imminence of
disorder and violence but called into
you according to you sir according to
you're preparing for me and according to
the belief of 82 of the people but
according to the belief of no city
official of little rock
well i have here a statement from eight
of the alderman signed after the fact
with their signatures saying that if i
had not taken the action which i did
but there would have been disorder and
violence
governor what's your opinion of the
crowds of white adults
who gather outside of central high
school each week day morning they curse
at any negro who happens to pass by
they call negroes animals
and almost to a man they say governor
thomas has done the right thing
what do you think of these people well
malice
in the
hate is deplorable
in any place or in any circumstances
but as president eisenhower has said
himself you can't change the hearts of
people by law
now in view of the progress that we have
made all i ask for in this situation and
all i've ever asked for is some time for
the situation to change for it to become
acceptable so that there would not be
disorder and violence
and if so be that this right
which was ruled as proper by the supreme
court for 80 or 90 years
and then was upset uh how it was in 1954
if it is right it will come about
so why should we be so impatient as to
want to force it because force begets
force
hate begets hate malice begets malice
but if time is given for an adjustment
of the attitudes and the feelings of
people then it can be peacefully
accomplished which will be better for
all concerned you mentioned president
eisenhower may i ask you just what was
accomplished
during your conference yesterday with
president eisenhower has your conference
for the president changed your mind your
attitude in any way regarding
integration here in little rock
no not as to the situation that exists
locally uh certainly i think that any
far-minded person will grant
that i would know more about that
or the citizens here would that any
outsiders from anywhere or any worse
anyone has far removed from the scene
or the city officials a little rock
would know
don't fail to see any i have to repeat
who failed to see any real evidence well
i have to repeat that you're wrong
all right sir
your attitude then has not changed as a
result of your conference for the
president did the president after the
situation yes there were certain areas
of agreement
what were those areas
well mike
i am not free to discuss in detail
the
uh
subjects of the conference i don't think
that it would be proper for me to do so
uh in view of it's just
having transpired
and effect we hope to accomplish in a
spirit of cooperation and mutual
endeavor did the president give you any
assurance the justice department will be
more
moderate than in the past regarding
integration here in little rock
no the president made no commitments to
me on any specific item such as that i
think that it would be impossible did he
express personal concern to you
regarding the problems that you as
governor face well now i'm afraid if i
keep answering your questions in
relation to that yes that we will
eventually get into the conference which
i feel that it is not proper for me to
discuss at this time
governor fathers in trying to get
to the root
of the white south's opposition to
integration
let me quote from this morning's new
york herald tribune which sums up the
feeling of many southerners
they said the negro these whites feel
is little better than a savage animal
intellectually and morally inferior
childish and irresponsible
and supposedly unable to control
allegedly excessive sexual and
aggressive impulses
do you believe that no
mr wallace i do not agree with that
some of the finest citizens we have in
arkansas are negro citizens
and many of them have most responsible
positions and have carried them out with
credit to themselves in the state and
the nation and the citizenry as a whole
then friday i believe that each person
should be judged upon his individual
merits and that it should not apply to
races or classes or groups well whether
we like it or not it is applying to a
race why then
why why the violence why did you expect
the violence what would be the motive
of potential violence
on the part of these whites
now naturally the negroes are not going
to be violent they simply want to go
ahead and go to school
with the fights according to the order
of the supreme court of the united
states
the violence therefore would have to
come from the whites why would they be
violent about it if they do not feel the
way that you suggest that they do not or
certainly that you do not feel i said
that i did not feel that way do you feel
that there may be that some people feel
that way i cannot be responsible for the
feelings of any people anywhere
we have to take things for what they are
not what we would like them to be now
that if the situation were reversed
and let's say the negro race
were in the preponderance
then perhaps the violence would come
from the other quarter if the same
situation existed as to the races as
they are now that of course isn't
imponerable and it's speculative and
perhaps has no place in the discussion
since this whole thing started governor
fathers newsmen have asked you time and
again something to this effect they've
asked you wasn't your action
a put up job
isn't this a test case for the rest of
the south to see how far
the states can go in resisting the
federal government
no that is not true
it's even been suggested sir
oh yes i know many things have been
suggested many things have been
misrepresented it's even been suggested
sir that you are a puppet
dangling from strings held by governor
griffin of georgia
well
if you knew me
as the people know me who have been
acquainted with me all my life
you would entertain no such thought and
neither would anyone else governor
griffin was here in the uh governor's
mansion
uh the lattice the last week in august
was he not
i do not recall the date was some two or
three weeks before uh
about three weeks ago again about three
weeks ago
and you said i believe last week that
all you talked about when he was your
guest here was duck hunting
no not everything i said pleasantries he
was my guest here as has been governor
anderson nebraska and others who have
visited
it's a courtesy which is extended uh
almost our ways by the chief executive
of one state to the chief executive of
his party of other states you regard
yourself as a preservator of the police
is that correct
yes a preservative that's my obligation
now that is a word which i am told has
crept into your vocabulary
only since governor griffin was your
guest
in the mansion here and it is a word
preservator which governor griffin has
used for a considerable length of time
i'm suggesting of course that it's mere
coincidence that perhaps you did talk
about preservators
no we certainly did not uh if that is
true then it is a coincidence because i
wasn't aware and i'm not aware yet until
you said so and i have no reason to
doubt your word
that he has used that language but that
is a natural word for the chief
executive i'm sure that under summer
circumstances it might have been used by
the governor of any state
let me read you a statement by a white
southerner
professor of sociology at cornell
university
robin williams by name he says
governor farbes has encouraged those
groups who violently oppose
desegregation
he has given them reason to believe that
they might be right
the effect of his official action
gives violent opposition a sign of being
legitimate
has that ever occurred to you sir
no
sure it's possible but uh
good comes from many things
and bad comes from many things
and what's the point that you're trying
and it is quite natural that from this
incident here
that round views and misinterpretations
could give encouragement to those who
oppose
and perhaps in the final wind-up it
might give encouragement to those
who
feel otherwise under those circumstances
sir why do you not disavow
in a public statement
violence on the part of whites why do
you not disavow
certain
incidents that have taken place not only
in cities throughout the south let me
ask you this why did you not go down to
central high school and tell the crowd
to disperse it would seem to me
that because you wanted peace and quiet
no violence
that it might have been reasonably
suggest that the governor himself would
appear on the scene
and try to disperse the crowd well
that's a very far-fetched idea i've
never known of a governor of any state
in labor trouble which sometimes results
in violence or any other to appear
personally on the scene
well there's never been i shouldn't say
that there's never been but this is an
extraordinary situation which
may merit extraordinary measures
governor well the state might lose a
governor
how do you mean certainly not certainly
not the violent segregationists that are
down there in front of the uh in front
of the high school they're not going to
take off after you are they going
it would depend on my actions
governor
we of course all know that the supreme
court has ruled that there must be
integration
you have said that you respect that
ruling
tell me this personally
do you favor
negro and white children sitting
together in classrooms
i have never expressed any personal
opinion as to the matter why not i felt
that it is best not to why i'm the
governor of the state pledged to uphold
its laws to keep the peace and order
and also the laws of the nation
my personal
views uh
are not relevant to the problem
i have no objection my son is now in an
integrated college at russellville
do you
you will make no further statement than
that no you've talked to great length
over the last two weeks about the fact
that arkansas is well ahead of many
other states in the south in proceeding
with integration you've said it again
today tonight here
but is it also not true
that you yourself have been responsible
for none
of this integration
but this integration has not been
initiated by the governor's office but
rather has been initiated by local
governments and what has been done in
the state was done before you became
governor no aren't you taking credit for
society
well that isn't true in what sense have
you integrated anything in the state of
arkansas all of the state colleges
during my administration and were they
not integrated before you became
certainly
only the university
and all of the state colleges have been
integrated under your aegis during my
administration during your
administration and you've been
sympathetic to it and all of the public
schools the eight districts that are
integrated well those are done by local
publishers well that is true
how else could it be done it has to be
done by the local governments they have
control of their school affairs
through their elected board members
you and i all of us have seen
photographs governor of negro children
being turned away from little rock high
school and behind them white people
jeering and cursing at them
let me read to you what communist
propagandists are making this
several days ago radio moscow said this
the shameful spectacle of negro children
confronted by guns and ugly mobs as they
tried to enter schools
which racist elements are determined
shall remain all white
does it not give you pause to know that
communist propagandists leap upon your
actions
to try to discredit the united
of colored st
and that is why
i want it to occur peacefully
with general acceptance so that there
will never be any such incidents as that
sure you're quite willing now as others
to point out the occurrence of little
rock
but have you thought of the other
currencies across the land
can i change the hearts of the people
what did william boris say one of the
greatest liberals and the progressive
republicans of longville you've been
reading me some statements may i read
you what indeed you may say
if a state may not be entrusted
exclusively with the authority
and relied upon the exercise the
authority to punish those who violate
its own laws public or private persons
then there is no such thing as local
government because the state is deprived
of the very instrumentality by which it
maintains state integrity
we are dealing with the race problem
we need not blind our eyes to that fact
and the race problem is a problem which
does not readily yield to legislative
solution to the rigid demands of the law
only the patient process of education
the uplifting power of religion
the tolerant noble-minded men and women
who give their thoughts to the cause can
remove or modify such injustices are
such harshnesses and that is being done
governor is being done in the south
that
that result the south is achieving the
record so shows and the people of the
south are entitled to our commendation
and not our condemnation how long
as much support
our progress had been achieved as now
how many years ago about 20. i didn't
say it's a good many more than 20 years
ago sir for senator laura to upset it
governor do you ever sit in this
executive mansion now and read
newspapers with your name in the
headlines and say to yourself
horrible fathers
kill billy from greasy creek arkansas
who got out of high school just
23 years ago at the age of 24.
who would have imagined this
and do you say to yourself
i wish i weren't here
well one sometimes reflects
of course as we used to say in the war
we are sometimes the children of faith
and
circumstance i think i am such because
uh
i've always termed myself a liberal and
been so termed
by my associates in the
conference of governors both north and
south
it is the simple fact
that these things cannot be done
overnight
time is the healer of our wounds
and the solution to many problems
and we just can't do this thing at once
force begets force one of the things
that makes it so unpleasant about all of
this
is that when people feel that it's being
forced down their throats against their
will when they naturally react
the american people have always been
that way mr wallace
governor farbes i wish we had another
half hour to continue with this that's
the end of our time and i thank you sir
for extending to me the
courtesy
i beg your pardon i'm getting a stretch
sign which means i have a little more
time
a quick answer if i may sir
to
a couple of questions
do you intend to run for a third term as
governor of arkansas
no one has ever been able to find that
out and i don't know myself
your
opponent shall i say your detractors in
this particular issue
say that you were looking for an
emotional issue
and that you are motivated strictly
politically
in everything that you have done for the
past two weeks oh yes uh mr wallace your
detractors and your enemies say many
things which reminds me of a statement
of abe lincoln one time when he said if
i tried to answer all the charges that
come to this office that i might as well
close up shop for any other business
that if i am right then all the things
they say won't matter in the end and if
i am wrong then ten angels swearing i'm
right wouldn't change it so i feel that
same philosophy
again i thank you sir
governor orville faubus guaranteed
himself a place in american history when
he ordered national guardsmen to bar a
handful of negro children from a high
school in little rock two weeks ago
he exposed for all to see the basic
conflict that exists between state and
federal power
this conflict must inevitably be
resolved
and if american history is to deal
kindly with governor falbas
he must help to resolve it peacefully
and with dispatch
[Music]
[Applause]
in 1957 pioneering birth control
advocate margaret sanger appeared on the
mike wallace interview program and
engaged in a wide-ranging discussion
from the use of birth control
to the incidence of divorce this program
runs about 25 minutes
good evening what you're about to
witness is an unrehearsed uncensored
interview on the issue of birth control
it will be a free discussion of an adult
topic
a topic that we feel merits public
examination
[Applause]
the mike wallace interview
[Music]
tonight we go after the story of the
woman who violated convention and bucked
powerful opposition to lead the birth
control movement in america
you see her behind me she's mrs margaret
sanger who was thrown into jail eight
different times for her efforts
if you're curious to know why mrs sanger
has devoted her life to the birth
control movement
if you'd like to hear her answer to the
charge that birth control is a sin
and if you want to get her views on
politics divorce and god
will go after those stories in just a
moment
my guest's opinions are not necessarily
mine the stations are my sponsors philip
morris incorporated but whether you
agree or disagree
we feel that none should deny the right
of these views to be broadcast
and now to our story
when mrs margaret sanger opened the
first birth control clinic in the united
states back in 1916 birth control
was a dirty word
the police threw her into jail as they
were to do seven more times during her
crusade
a crusade that still faces the reasoning
but unalterable opposition of the roman
catholic church
that crusade kept mrs sanger away from
her children for long periods it helped
to break up her first marriage
and she suffered constant harrowing
social abuse
mrs hanger in view of all of that
let me ask you this first of all
why did you do it i realized that
you had an intellectual conviction that
birth control was a boon to mankind
but i'm sure that others have that
conviction too and so what i'd like to
know is this what
events what emotions in your life
made margaret sanger a crusader for
birth control
well mr wallace it's hard to say that
any one thing
has made one do this or that
i think from the very beginning
uh i came with a large family
my mother died young
11 children that made an impression on
me as a child
i was a trained nurse
went among the people
i saw
women
who asked to have some means whereby
they would have to have another
pregnancy too early after the last child
last
abortion which many of them had
so does a number of things that are one
after the other that really made you
feel that you had to do something there
are some other possible reasons that
suggest themselves on reading your bio
your biography by lawrence later your
mother as you say
died prematurely after bearing 11
children she was born a catholic was she
not she was born a caster cast and
you're in ireland your father was a sort
of a village atheist who clashed with
church authorities and because of his
atheism his earnings dwindled under
community pressure you and your brothers
and sisters were known as
quote children of the devil end quote
could it be then that in part at least
you were driven emotionally toward the
birth control movement because of
antagonism toward the church because
that was a way to fight the church no i
don't think i had anything of a kind in
mind
i was i was what i would call a born
humanitarian
i don't like to see people suffer
i don't like to see cruelty even to this
day
and in nursing you see a great deal of
cruelty and unnecessary suffering
at that time there was no opposition
as far as the church was concerned any
church
it was mainly the law the federal law
and state laws that one had to uh to
think of the church was not in my mind
at all
well in going after your motive then
and i will press you just a little bit
more about that and then get to the
specifics of this evening but in your
motive in the movement
is it possible that the movement itself
the feeling of wanting to do
anything that you felt was important
that perhaps that moved you a good deal
because the fact remains that you let a
movement against
overwhelming pressures that stemmed back
for centuries and in doing so according
to your autobiography you even left your
first husband and you wrote this to a
friend
mrs sanger you said
where is the man
to give me what the movement gives in
joy and interest and freedom now what
was this joy this freedom that you
craved
well i don't remember that letter
it was written but i think that it was
not a question of
of marriage at all
there was a certain satisfaction
in uh doing something that was going to
alleviate the sufferings of women in
particular and i was quite a feminist
at the time
and uh yes and uh
i naturally didn't want to see women
take all the suffering of childbearing
and of pregnancies
so it was a pleasure in a sense i think
that you were
striking
uh at an archaic law
which it was
put in on the statute books by anthony
comstock some years ago
and no one had stood up against it no
one had had tried to
to change the laws
and at that time not even a doctor had a
right to use the united states males and
common carriers for books for learning
for anything that he had to do with this
question it was considered obscene
the whole question was considered
obscene mr sanger you have helped to
spread the birth control movement not
only here in the united states but in
europe and the orient as well why why
is birth control of such vital
importance internationally is it just to
save women suffering is that the only
reason in your mind
well not entirely the population
question is a great concern today
and the the rate
at which uh the birth births come in to
the
we're saving them now at one time when
children died they didn't have the food
today our population
all over the world is getting certainly
better
consideration and better conditions than
they had at the time that i was there i
went
to every country because i was invited
and i didn't spread go into the country
myself i was invited to go to japan
and to speak there have eight lectures
on the question of birth control and
peace well do you believe that birth
control is essential if we want to keep
millions of people across the world from
starving is that your thesis
say it again
do you feel that birth control is
essential to keep millions of people
across the world from starving
well i think the birth control will keep
your population uh
more or less static until you pick up
your resources
certainly you'll keep
prevent their starving what's more
important birth control or picking up
the resources
well picking up the resources is there's
just a limit to that too there's just so
much take japan
and she cannot feed they've had the best
experts come there when macarthur was
there the best experts say they have 20
million more people and they can feed
she's got to be fed outside and some in
some way she's got to have that kind of
help if she's going to keep them
from fighting but certainly around the
world there is uh there is potential
agricultural land that is not being
properly used now just this past year on
may 21st the new york times summarized
an important study of the world's food
resources made by professor james bonner
of the california institute of
technology
professor bonna says the world is not
using one billion acres of potential
agriculture land and he adds
that if this land were used
and present agricultural land were
improved the entire world could be fed
adequately even if the population
increased by one-third
in the next 50 years
oh mr wells you hear so many fantastic
things what can happen what may happen
uh this and that i've heard it for the
last 30 years anyway to what could be
done but it's never done
and the thing is what is it now what we
got today
a very distinguished woman
spoke to me about arizona
and she said i wish you wouldn't talk
about population
said all the population in the united
states could be put in one state and i
said what state
she said arizona
i said did you ever hear of caliche
she didn't know that i was talking about
the delicatessen or a what
i said well
caliche
is harder than any rock
and it is about three inches
below the ground where it looks
beautiful it looks if you could have
food looks if you could have corn or
wheat or cotton but as a matter of fact
you have to dynamite
caliche out of the ground in order to
have a little shrub have you
a little grass or a few flowers so many
problems that when it comes to that and
the demographers
i never heard of anyone that would agree
with that that we could have another in
the world another another thing another
third well
you say that originally the opposition
was in all law and you have to fight
against that today your opposition stems
mainly from where from what source
well i think that the opposition
uh
is mainly from the hierarchy of the
roman catholic church of the church
of the hierarchy of the church you feel
that the the parishioners themselves the
lay people in the church are not against
birth control they come to all of our
clinics just the same as their
non-catholics do
exactly the same well let's look at the
official catholic position
opposition to birth control i read now
from a church publication called the
question box
in forbidding birth control it says the
following it says the immediate purpose
and primary end of marriage is the
beginning of children
when the marital relation is so used as
to render the fulfillment of its
purposes impossible
that is by birth control
it is used unethically and unnaturally
what's wrong with that position well
it's very broad it's not normal
it's not uh it has the wrong attitude
toward marriage toward love for the
relationships between men and women
well the natural law
they say is that first of all the
primary function
of sex in marriage is to beget children
do you disagree with that i disagree
with a hundred percent
your feeling is what then my feeling is
of love
and the attraction between many women
in many cases the very finest
relationship
has nothing to do with bearing a child
it's secondary
many many times we know that you see
your birth rate you talk to people who
have very happy marriages and they're
not having babies every year
yes i think that's a celibate attitude
a celibate attitude but you agree that
catholicism according to the tenets of
catholicism they rule that birth control
violates not only the church's position
it isn't the church's position but they
say that it violates a natural law as i
have just explained
therefore birth control is a sin no
matter who practices it
now the violation of the natural law
according you certainly can take no
issue with the natural law as the
hierarchy
of the uh catholic church regards it
well i certainly do take issue with it i
think it's untrue and i think it's
unnatural
well let me everything bears it out that
is an unnatural attitude to take and how
do they know
i mean after all they're celibates
they don't know love they don't know
marriage they know nothing about
bringing up children or any of the
marriage problems of life and yet they
speak to people as if they were god
let me let me ask you this question
suppose a healthy a well-to-do couple
decide for some reason never to have
children
use birth control all their lives
would you say that your methods are
being misused mr sanger
now if they're intelligent people
and they had some reason for thinking of
children is responsibility or some
disease that they might have that they
wouldn't like to pass on to a child
and i think it would be a very uh
unselfish attitude for them to take if
there is a disease no i say a healthy
well-to-do couple a couple that just
doesn't want children and for that
reason they use birth control all the
way
do you think that that
is a as a misuse of your methods i don't
think it's a misuse i think if they're
intelligent adults but they must know
what they want they must manage their
lives themselves and certainly there's
nothing in birth control then there
isn't other things that you might deny
yourself i've asked you your motives a
little while ago at the beginning of the
program your motives in working for
birth control as hard as you have for as
many years as you have you reject the
principle catholic argument against
birth control as being totally invalid
what do you think
is the reason
the motive of the church
in forbidding birth control
you'd have to ask catholic that i
couldn't take their motive is
well i you you couldn't say officially
what their motive is but you certainly
must have an opinion about it mr sanger
well i'm i don't have much to do with
with the
the hierarchy and i know that the people
that come to our organization and want
to have
the same methods or whatever it is that
one can have to prevent a pregnancy that
those women will say to us i was we
asked their religion very often and they
say i am a catholic i've raised the
catholic church this my church is wrong
and this this is the one thing i will
never be anything else but my church is
wrong and this one thing and that is
said over and over and over again
so what the motive is well you won't
hazard a guess
i don't care too thank you
may i ask you why now i know that in
private and uh in actually in public
discussions i think prior to this time
you have been willing to state your
understanding of what the motives of the
church are
and now you would you would rather
remain silent may i ask you why well
simply because i don't think that
the church has changed in its attitude
some of the hierarchy have changed their
attitude you can't say the same thing
that you might have said a year ago or
two years ago
as to your belief rest in your opinion
have you heard it said that the reason
that the church is against birth control
is because they want more catholics
i've read it
do you believe it well they if you read
their papers where they point out boston
that that's what has happened in boston
in massachusetts they have simply
outbred the protestants
and they're
in boston and massachusetts they have
control i've read that in their own
papers
of course the church's answer
the church's answer and i read now from
a pamphlet published by the redemptive
redemptorist fathers in missouri says as
follows
it says that point of view about wanting
more catholics is nonsense
quote the catholic church does not
command catholic husbands and wives to
have even one child
the church considers it more than
normally meritorious for them to have no
children if they mutually and
perpetually give up the use of the
marriage right
for the love of god
all right
i
what they what they do so they i think
that the question in my mind is that
they they do
and order
their own people to do as they wish but
i object to their uh having the same
rules for people who are not the same
religion well they believe you see that
it is a natural law not a catholic law
but a natural law and therefore a sin
not just
for catholics but a sin for all peoples
and i think that there are other
religious groups the very very orthodox
jews feel the same way about birth
control
uh
let's look at another argument against
birth control mrs sanger published in
red book magazine in march of 1956
it says birth control is a devastating
social force
which tends to weaken the moral fiber of
the community
immunity from parenthood encourages
promiscuity particularly when unmarried
persons can so easily avail themselves
of the devices
do you doubt that i doubt it
you do certainly
then let me read from a news story in
the philadelphia daily news on june 10
1942
the story quotes you as urging the
women's army auxiliary corps to give its
members quote preventive measures
against pregnancy end quote and you add
quote
abortion and illegitimacy are bound to
result
if the government doesn't recognize
human nature
end quote
in other words you were not advocating
uh christian morality but rather ways
for single women to avoid bearing
illegitimate children where was this
taken from philadelphia daily news june
10 1942 direct quote from margaret
sanchez i doubt it
i don't believe i ever made such a
remark
well
in the same vein in your autobiography
which you cannot disavow you wrote the
following about sexologist havelock
ellis
you said he's been able to clarify the
question of sex
and free it from the smudginess
connected with it from the beginning of
christianity
now
what do you mean by the smudginess
connected with sex and why do you blame
it on christianity
well
there's many reasons of course to say
that we have more records of it from the
dawn of christianity
and i think i was speaking of hamlet
ellis as having clarified the question
of homosexuals
making the thing
uh
not exactly a perverted thing but a
thing that a person is born with
different kinds of eyes different kinds
of
structure and so forth that he didn't
make all homosexuals uh perverts and i
felt that he helped clarify that to the
medical profession and to the scientists
of the world as perhaps one of the first
ones who did to do that
that was one of the things that i meant
in that
mr sanger do you
disagree that catholics or do you do you
feel that catholics
should not have a right to have a say
when a city administration
contemplates spending their tax dollars
on birth control or the dissemination of
birth control information something the
catholics believe is simple
if they have a right to say do you feel
that they don't have a right to have a
say when a city administration
contemplates spending their dollars tax
dollars on birth control for instance
here in new york catholics comprise
about forty five percent of our
population they're the largest single
group or don't you think they should
have the democratic right to lobby
against having their money spent their
tax money spent for something they
consider evil well i suppose they have a
right they certainly do it but so have
the others if they're only 45 percent of
the population that's that is not the
the majority but they have a right to
get up and certainly i'd have no
objection to their having said that but
i think we should have the same right
i say we i mean non-catholics
well of course this is a little bit of
variance with something that you told
our reporter earlier this week you said
earlier this week it's not only wrong it
should be made illegal for any religious
group to prohibit dissemination of birth
control even among its own members in
other words you would like to see the
government legislate uh religious
beliefs in a certain sense
where these strange things come to that
i said them is what i should like to
know when well now uh you know that my
reporter spent a good deal of time with
you he's a
very accurate young man yes and this is
a this is a this is a specific quote
well i don't think i said it quite that
way
what are your religious beliefs mr
sanger do you believe in a god in the
sense of a divine being who rewards or
punishes people after death
well i have a different attitude about
the divine
i feel that we have divinity within us
and the more we express the good part of
our lives and the more the divine within
us expresses itself
uh i suppose i would call myself
episcopalian by uh
by religion
and there's a many other
if you've traveled around the world you
get quite a bit of the feeling of all
all religions have so much alike in the
divine part of our own being
and i suppose you just couldn't put that
in a book or you couldn't put it into a
phrase or a sentence do you believe in
sin
when i say believe i don't mean and
believe in committing sin do you believe
there is such a thing as a as sin
i think the greatest sin in the world is
bringing children into the world
that have
diseased from their parents that have no
chance in the world to be a human being
practically
delinquents prisoners all sorts of
things just marked when they're born
that to me is the greatest sin that
people can can commit
but sin in the ordinary sense that we
regard it
do you believe or do you not believe
what would they be do you believe in
infidelity as a sin
well i'm not going to specify what i
think of sin i've stated but i think
it's the worst sin
but then you asked me to say what and i
and i said what and and uh you refuse to
answer me yes i don't know about
infidelity that has so many
personalities to it and what person's
own belief is you can't i couldn't
generalize on any of those things as to
be in sin murder isn't it
well that's naturally thing where it was
a it's a sinner now it's a terrible
act
in just a moment mrs sanger i'd like to
ask you about another
social problem here in the united states
divorce
nearly 400 000 couples get divorced in
this country each year
and i'd like to get your views on the
cause and possible prevention of this
problem
and we'll get mr sanger's answer to that
question in just 60 seconds now then mrs
sanger there are nearly 400 000 divorces
or annulments in america each year
what
and this is hard to do in the short time
of course that we have what would you
recommend
to cut down our divorce rate
well
as
a great many of our cities are including
in the work
that they do in birth control clinics
having marriage counseling
so when the woman or the man come and
complain of their marriage and the skids
we invite them to come and have special
talks with some of our psychiatrists or
others who are making a study of that
all over the country where we have about
500 clinics they almost all include
marriage counseling and marriage
direction may i may i ask you this could
it be that women in the united states
have become too independent that they've
followed the lead of women like margaret
sanger
by neglecting family life for a career
let me quote from your biography
describing your second marriage to
noah's sleeve
quote in new york mrs sanger maintained
every clause of their compact of
independence they had separate
apartments they telephoned each other
for dinner or theater engagements or
passed notes back and forth
would you
call this a sound formula for marriage
mr sanchez uh different people yes it
certainly was for me
and for my husband we had a very happy
marriage counseling he had different
friends than i had and uh i don't
believe in forcing the fellow we were
two adults
and forcing your friends and another
person who may have an entirely
different book it's worked out very well
i know that it did
you have two sons one final question you
have two sons
how many children have they would you
like to see them i would indeed
as well
how many children that's six in this
family five boys the girl in that family
and in the other family two girls two
girls
miss sanger i thank you so much for
taking time out and coming and talking
mr wells i've never smoked but i'm going
to begin to take up smoking and use
philip morris as my
as the cigarette for me to take
well i thank you very much
indeed in the eyes of some margaret
sanger has been a heroine
in the eyes of others she's been a
destructive force
the purpose of this interview has been
not of course to try to resolve this
issue but to open it to a little
sensible discussion
this was done with the feeling that all
of us regardless of our beliefs
can do nothing but profit from a free
exchange of ideas
if it already hasn't
[Applause]
retired air force general george kenney
appeared on the mike wallace interview
program in 1957 soon after the launch of
the soviet satellite sputnik kenny
discussed his views on why the satellite
threatened to the national security of
the united states and raised the
possibility of a third world war this
program runs 25 minutes
tonight we had planned to interview one
of the great fighters of our time sugar
ray robinson
but because of the alarming turn in
world events this week sugar ray has
consented to a postponement of his
interview
so that tonight we can go after the
story of the struggle between the united
states and the soviet union
for control of outer space
our guest will be one of the great air
force generals of the second world war
george kenny
douglas macarthur's air force boss in
the pacific
and we'll try to find out why general
kenny believes that the soviet earth
satellite
brings us very close to a third world
war
my guest's opinions are not necessarily
mine the stations are my sponsors philip
morris incorporated but whether you
agree or disagree we feel that none will
deny the right of these views to be
broadcast
and now to our story
ostensibly for security reasons our
military leaders have kept more or less
mum
about the soviet earth satellite
the most important advance in science
since the atomic bomb
therefore for tonight's interview we
have chosen retired air force general
george kenny because of his reputation
as a fearless
military analyst
his world war ii commander general
douglas macarthur told us yesterday
general kenny has no superior as an air
commander his creative imagination and
his brilliant leadership
mark him one of the unique figures in
aviation
general kenny first let me ask you this
it seems to be a big question
in the minds of most of us as to just
how serious a threat
the soviet earth satellite is to our
national security last wednesday
president eisenhower said it did not
raise his apprehensions not one iota
what is your reaction to the president's
reaction
well i hated to hear that reaction
because i think that
it should raise the blood pressure of an
awful lot of people
especially those people that are
concerned with the defense of this
country
but what is the significance of the
soviet satellite why should we worry
about the fact that the soviet union has
beaten us by a few months
in launching a satellite something a
sputnik that goes around the world
the weapon that we're all uh after even
that is when i say all i mean ourselves
and the russians
is the intercontinental ballistic
missile
and the job of an in making an
intercontinental ballistic missile is to
get enough power back of that package so
that you can drive it across the ocean
now you can shove this satellite up 560
miles
you have enough power back of that thing
to drive it across the ocean
so that they have the the propulsion
that is necessary to shove an
intercontinental ballistic missile
so the satellite itself is not what
worries you but the power that was able
to put that satellite up there in the
air now that confirms what true chef
said some time ago
that they then had uh well i guess that
was about a month ago he claimed that
the russians had an intercontinental
ballistic missile and about a week later
he said that there was no place on earth
that
was now uh safe from an air from a
russian missile
nikita khrushchev said just this week he
said it must be realized in the west
that the soviet union is no longer a
peasant country it is dangerous to take
this view
do you think that this dangerous view
that the soviet union is a peasant
backward country
may be partly responsible for are being
caught napping well i think we've been
too complacent and too apathetic about
the russian ability to make weapons and
and produce them in quantity
uh ever since uh
the end of world war ii
you remember that people said they
wouldn't make an atomic bomb for another
15 years
it was only about three years later that
they made one
earlier this week general kenny i talked
to the high ranking air force general
who knows you quite well
and he told me that in the past one of
your favorite phrases was quote
the russians don't know the difference
between borscht and lubricating oil
end quote general kenny now could it be
that you sir have been guilty too of
underestimating the russians
i don't remember saying that but if i
did it's about time that i woke up and
got up to date
uh
let us say that the soviet union
is somewhat ahead of us in rocket power
but still i gather
from what you say that you're that you
feel that we may be in grave danger of
attack
now why should we be in this danger when
we have the h-bomb president eisenhower
said back in 1954 general kennedy said
the soviet union
faces no greater deterrent to war
than the retaliation that would
certainly be visited upon them if they
were to attack any of our nations or any
part of our vital interests end quote
from
president eisenhower in 1954.
i think in 1954 there was a good
statement but
since 1954
they've had about three years to make
some more hydrogen bombs and right now
they have
they have a lot of hydrogen bonds as
well as atomic bombs their stockpile is
a good size stockpile
the only thing that they like uh and i'm
convinced they like it or else they'd
use this thing
is the means of delivery of those
hydrogen bombs
they're building uh a good long-range
bomber right now the bison which is as
good as our b-52
and uh
when they get enough of them then we'll
have something else to worry about in
other words you
you believe that the russians intend to
attack us i think the day that the
political and military staffs get
together in the kremlin
and talk this thing over and decide that
they can win they'll pull the trigger
you genuinely believe that they are out
to beat us to the ground to knock us
senseless uh all you have to do is to
read their bible which is lenin's
selected works and
you'll find that thing confirmed all the
way through
and remember that still is their bible
they're still following the sacred
teachings of marx and lenin
khrushchev reiterates that point every
time he makes a speech
well i know that you have no crystal
ball general but how soon how soon do
you think
do you imagine that this might
that they might be ready to come after
us
they a lot depends on the production of
their uh their airplane depends on
whether or not some new means of
interception is developed
uh something that might scare them from
an attack because they might be afraid
they'd lose all their airplanes
but in a few years and uh by a few years
i don't mean getting up as far as 10 i'd
say it's under five
they ought to have enough bombers to uh
to lug those hydrogen bombs across here
why do they need the bombers if they
have the if they have the rocket power
to shove a satellite up to 560 miles why
can't they send the h-bomb that way well
the uh there's a little period that has
to elapse between making one and getting
into production
when you uh when you shove up one of
these things you're not ready for
production turning on the things out by
the thousand of course it could be sir
that you're painting too bleak a picture
way back in 1950 may 1st 1950
the associated press reported
you
as follows
ap said air force general george kenny
said today he believed war with russia
was coming
he declared russian leaders probably had
gone so far as to set a year for the
attack end quote
seven years have passed since then
without a war with russia is it possible
that you're looking for skeletons
under the bed if i may mix a metaphor i
think that prediction was justified then
because remember at that time nobody had
an h-bomb
as soon as the h-bomb came into the
picture which was a couple of years
later
the avon was out of date it was just the
same as trying to declare war against
somebody that had just invented a
machine gun when you had a lot of very
good bows and arrows
so that
if there was a date set
and if at that time they did have enough
a-bombs to start something
they immediately had to change their
plans and get into production of an
h-bomb
well tell me this sir
what would you think of prevented war
of our attacking russia before
theoretically she attacks us first no uh
you can't sell a preventive war whether
anybody believed in it or not you can't
you couldn't sell it i'm not asking
whether you can sell it i'm asking
whether you george kenny
believes
in preventative war no i believe more in
the same theory that
kept a lot of this country straightened
out several years ago when the sheriff
didn't shoot the bandit as soon as he
saw him
uh he notified him he had so much time
to get out of town an hour or two
and if the bandit didn't want to get out
of town and started reaching for his gun
the sheriff beat him to the draw
i think what we've got to do is to
is to rationalize this thing to the
point where we are ready to beat them to
the draw
but they take the first act
in that case i know but but uh
is there any possibility of retaliation
that they were to take the first act
let's say that they were to send up
their bombers or send
via rocket power or
as an intercontinental ballistic missile
a hydrogen bomb isn't it perfectly
possible that they could destroy us
before we could get up off our backs to
defend ourselves or destroy us to such
an extent that that we would be to all
intents and purposes out of business if
this crisis waits until the russians get
uh oh say a thousand of these
intercontinental ballistic missiles with
hydrogen heads in them
and we haven't found some way of
countering that thing
intercepting it and destroying it before
it gets here
then an opening attack would destroy us
we'd be out of business there wouldn't
be any retaliation because
we'd have a hundred million dead people
in this country and you don't retaliate
when you're dead well that's the point
mind you i'm not i'm not espousing
preventive war but i'm just
talking about it if you will
philosophically now under those
circumstances if it's just a question of
two men in a room both armed with the
deadly weapon and one is going to get to
the other as soon as he feels that he's
ready then isn't it just plain good
common sense
to go after them before they come after
us
now it'd be very much like uh if you
challenged me to a duel and i said all
right i have the condition so we'll both
sit in a in a grave that is six feet
long and two feet wide and six feet deep
and each have our loaded pistol and then
each fire when somebody counts three
well you know very well that uh you
wouldn't fight a duel under those
circumstances neither would i
so that we've got to get in the same
position that we are so that if they
push a button or a lot of buttons
we've got to be ready to push push some
buttons and we aren't in that shape now
all right we've got to do something and
that's the number of the question why
do you feel
why are we
behind the soviet union in the race for
earth satellites and rocket power and
defensive or if necessary offensive
strength
well because we've neglected the problem
we didn't take this uh this
intercontinental missile or an
intermediate missile or any rocket
driven missile very seriously
for several years after world war ii was
over
and uh even today we've cut
appropriations this last uh budget cut
appropriations on
development of the guided missiles
well now this so we've let this thing go
to the point where now it's an emergency
situation
and uh i hope that the advent of this
satellite uh sputnik has
scared people or worried people enough
so that we'll have some emergency
appropriations and
get ourselves back in the groove
what what i don't understand is this
certainly you're not accusing or
suggesting bad faith lack of patriotism
stupidity or perhaps you are
of certain people who have been
responsible for our defense and
potential offense
over the years who
specifically in your mind
who are responsible what men are
responsible for the fact that the united
states is laggard
the people of the united states
people of the united states are the
bosses of this country they elect their
congressmen and the congressmen will
carry out the wishes of the people
they elect
everybody from the president all the way
up
and if the people of this country really
want
defense they can have it all they've got
to do is demand it
that is that the feeling uh in
washington is that they want the the
budget balance they want taxes reduced
they want uh bigger social security
benefits and more pensions
more better roads all kinds of things
well you know as well as i do sir
however the leadership is what is
important i i i'd like to ask you quite
seriously and i hope that you will not
evade me
about some certain men
i would like your opinion
i'd like your opinion of charlie wilson
as our secretary of defense the man who
has just left the job
i think that he did
a pretty fair job there but i think his
estimate of the situation was wrong
whether he was given a good estimate of
the situation i don't know
but assuming that he was given all the
information that was available
uh i think that his
final conclusions were wrong on the
necessity for
spending some money on national defense
and you're glad he's out of there
well uh i don't know uh i expect his
successor will
will carry on his policies for a while
maybe he'll change his mind
the uh
the news out of washington indicates in
the last two or three days
that they are going to do some emergency
work on this thing when you say that uh
the information that he's been given
either he hasn't been given sufficient
or correct information or else he's
acted upon it incorrectly who is
responsible for giving him the
information which would
lead him to to act is it the pentagon oh
there are all sorts of all kinds of
sources of information army and navy and
air force all have sources of
information and then there's the uh
the combined intelligence outfit
there was an assistant secretary of the
air force for research and development
to resign back in february 3rd 1956
trevor gardner he resigned in
disappointment of the way the guided
missile program was being handled
do you know this man
i know uh i know of him i've met him
they don't know him intimately
but i know the story you think that he
was right in resigning yes
he didn't agree with the uh the
department so he
resigned
and you think that probably he was right
and wilson was wrong in this particular
i think he was right
colonel john nickerson
who was senior officer at the ballistic
missile agency of the redstone arsenal
believed that the army was doing a
better job in the air force
and as a result i gather
i hope i say this
properly
uh leaked certain documents
with a view to seeing that the army had
a chance to continue with their guided
missile development
and uh
he was in a sense anyway broken
you sympathetic with nickerson or no not
a bit why not
because i don't uh agree that the army
project was as good as the
as the thor the air force missile
this couldn't just be old school thai
being an air force man uh no i think i
can look at the problem objectively
in your opinion general kenny how does
this soviet victory reflect on reflect
on president eisenhower
for instance columnist john o'donnell
in the new york daily news wrote the
following just a few days ago on october
9th he said
the national illusion of eisenhower as a
great military leader
has gone down the political drains since
the world learned that the russians had
beaten this nation to the punch with
their earth satellite
how do you feel about that charge oh i
don't think that makes too much sense
uh he still is a
an ex-military leader he still knows
what he did when he was running the show
in europe
he doesn't have to be an expert on
guided missiles
and he might very easily have
made a wrong estimate on
the threat of the russian investment
you seem unwilling
to fix the blame and it is not our
function here tonight to fix the blame
or to point the finger at anybody in
particular you say the blame is really
belongs with the american people
i think so but sensibly doesn't the
blame belong with the american people's
leaders who are their elected
representatives
no
you're asking for a man on horseback in
the white house we've never had them
i'm asking or i'm not asking for anybody
i am suggesting
that our leadership has perhaps
obscured from the american people the
seriousness of the situation perhaps
even obscured it from themselves and as
a result
we're in second place
no i don't think so i think that all of
the information
has been in the newspapers from time to
time
and the american people just hasn't paid
any attention to it
well how
how now do the american people make them
make their point of view felt
i imagine there have been plenty of
congressmen that have gotten lots and
lots of wires and postcards and
telegrams and letters and i hope they
keep on getting them too
time magazine october 14
quote center to styles bridges as
follows
senator burgess said the time has
clearly come to be less concerned with
the depth of pile on the new broad loom
or the height of the tail fin on the new
car and to be more prepared to shed
blood sweat and tears i gather you
aggressive i certainly do
people don't like this uh guns or butter
slogan but
it might not be a bad idea for us to
think about the guns for a while how
about making things better easier more
attractive for scientists
well i don't know any reason why the
scientists have anything to kick about
they've been treated all right the story
goes that
secretary wilson was not particularly
interested in basic research and basic
research is what led to the development
for instance of the atom bomb he was
more interested in the production right
now than in
than going to the books and and
developing material which will lead to
new and interesting developments in
science which can be used eventually for
defense or offense
well i think there is uh there's some
justification for that statement i think
he was interested
in uh production more than research
that was his nature he'd been brought up
doing that all his life what do you
think about the government's making
unavailable the work of dr j robert
oppenheimer they didn't say that he was
disloyal but they said that possibly he
was a poor security risk and as a result
one of the men most responsible for the
development of the atom bomb
was cut off from any possibility of
working on defense
ethics
well they had plenty of other scientists
to pick up the work and if there was the
slightest question
in regard to uh abner or any other
scientist
there was no necessity for fooling
around with them
now the the scientist that that is
kicking about this uh may be kicking
because he has a guilty conscience
i know quite a lot of these scientists
and i don't get any kicks out of them i
don't understand what you mean well if
uh the scientist that is complaining
i'm afraid uh
may have a guilty conscience back of his
complaints
general kenny
in just a moment i'd like to ask you
about your views on what the united
nations should do about russia views
for which i am told the soviet
government newspaper isvestia
called you a high-ranking lunatic
now then general kenny earlier this year
the soviet government newspaper as
vestia said that you were a high-ranking
lunatic adding
most lunatics are harmless but kenny is
a violent and dangerous lunatic
who should be placed in a straitjacket
because that's all that science can do
for george kenny at the present stage of
its development
now i understand this stems from your
idea of what the un should do about
soviet russia what do you think it
should do about soviet russia
well uh stated by his bestie was made
right after i made a speech in chicago
in which i offered
a plan
it was a possible solution to the mess
that we're in
and in this i advocated that
the united free nations get together and
throw all the dictators out of the
united nations and as they went out
through the door
tell them that they were through and
call for their resignation
uh immediate disarmament and that all of
this
and free elections to be held and that
the free elections and the disarmament
would be supervised by united nations
teams
who would be sent into those countries
isn't this a naive suggestion on your
part general kenny and you don't seem
like a naive man no i don't think it's
quite so naive uh it's a difficult thing
to get the united nations the so-called
free nations well isn't that going to be
invasion aren't we going if you suggest
sending inspection teams let's say into
soviet russia you know how in the world
are we going to suggest they're going to
let us in we're going to have to fight
our way in if they don't let them in uh
then they have declared war against the
free world
throw the soviet union and various other
out of the united nations they don't
belong in the united nations they
haven't lived up to the
the charter from the very start
and it's about time they were expelled
and then the uh while you might call it
an ultimatum it's the same ultimatum
that the cop gives to the crook that is
holed up in a warehouse
when he says come on out with your hands
up
if the crook wants to come out shooting
the cop shoots it out with him
way in the sense that is kind of
preventive war with a
with a twist isn't it possible by at the
same time that our inspection teams were
starting to go into soviet russia their
planes would be coming on over uh
to hit us i'd notify them those
inspection teams were going in
accompanied by fighters and bombers
well now even at the
u.s let's say would go along with this
plan do you think that countries like
india great britain france
would go along with this well in this uh
in this speech that i made i said this
would be the difficult job
to get these nations to band together
even for their own self-preservation but
that simply because it was a difficult
job was no reason for not trying it
general kenny you retired from the air
force several years ago
how come you haven't taken a an
executive job in private industry where
your
influence would be valuable let's say an
aircraft say an aircraft country a
company or an outfit that worked on
guided missiles
no i wouldn't belong in that because uh
any company that hired me would expect
me to be
down in washington helping sell their
stuff
and uh
i couldn't do that if one of the the
competitors of the company i was working
for had a better missile or a better
engine
airplane some top brass works for other
aircraft companies other defense
companies are you suggesting that they
do less than
no the best thing for the country no
it's just an idiosyncrasy that i have i
don't blame anybody else for not being
the way that i was and you work with the
arthritis foundation instead you know
what do you know about arthritis
a surprising amount for a
non-medical person
no i know enough to listen to the uh the
lectures and the papers that are
presented and understand what it's all
about
and uh talk intelligently or rather
listen intelligently
to a lot of these doctors when they
discuss the problem
and right now you're at the beginning of
your
fundraising campaign for the arthritis
foundation yeah we start the first of
november on our annual campaign
general kenny i thank you for coming and
talking to us tonight i'm sorry we don't
have more time sir i wish we did
the full significance of the soviet
earth satellite now whirling above us is
a matter of conjecture president
eisenhower has said he is not alarmed
general george kenny disagrees with the
president the purpose of this interview
has been to throw some light on the
minority point of view held by the
general so that americans may consider
and make up their minds of comments or
suggestions regarding our programming
please email us at c3history at
cspan.org
eleanor roosevelt appeared on the mike
wallace interview program in 1957. she
shares her views on various american
leaders including then president
eisenhower and then vice president nixon
as well as harry truman adlai stevenson
and her own husband franklin roosevelt
this program runs about 25 minutes
good evening
tonight my guest is a woman who has been
called the first lady of the world she
is mrs eleanor roosevelt
i shall ask mrs roosevelt to talk about
dwight eisenhower
nikita khrushchev
west brook peggler
and garlic pills
at the age of 74 eleanor roosevelt has
seen a lot of the world and the world
has seen a lot of her tonight i shall
ask mrs roosevelt about some of the most
pressing world issues about america's
leadership or lack of it
about the soviet menace and indications
that we may be losing our strength as a
nation to resist it
later in the program we'll talk with mrs
roosevelt about her code of values
and her family life
mrs roosevelt first of all let me ask
you this you've seen
great leaders
like winston churchill mahatma gandhi
your own husband
i wonder if in capsule
fashion
you can tell me what qualities enabled
these men
to shape the course of history as they
did what did they have that made them
the leaders they were
i never met mahatma gandhi but i think
everyone
felt they knew him even if they hadn't
met him i think one thing they had
in common all these men was great
courage both spiritual
mental and physical courage
mahatma gandhi i would say had a perhaps
a greater
spiritual quality
whereas
winston churchill
had
besides
the courage
um ability
and above everything else the ability to
put into words
what his people felt so that he could
always lead them
and my own husband i think had great
patience which you need in a democracy
because you have to come
to do fundamental things you have to
have the patience to have people
educated
and
then i think he had a deep interest in
human beings as human beings
what about
intellectual capacity and physical vigor
how important do you think those two
qualities were in these three i think
it's important to have both of course
mahatma gandhi you might say did not
have
so much physical vigor but he certainly
seemed to have extraordinary resistance
which perhaps is rather different from
physical vigor yes
and intellectual capacity oh i think
they all had intellectual capacity all
of them perhaps in different ways but
they all had intellectual capacity well
now quite candidly on all of the things
that you've talked about now
how do you think that dwight eisenhower
measures up
well that's of course a very difficult
thing to say because i barely know the
president i've seen him as a general
when
he was in germany
i've seen him in london as a general
i would say that he was
a diplomat
i would say that he was very good at
carrying out
things that had been planned
and
probably a fine general though he was of
course and in the field under general
marshall's general direction
from the
standpoint of intellectual capacity
i am no judge except
that i would say
that he probably had less
what i would call intellectual interest
in a
la great variety of subjects than either
again i can't say about mahatma gandhi
but i the winston churchill or my
husband tell you
i ask you this
what i'm trying to do now is to find out
about our present leadership
president eisenhower in a
two or three years now
will no longer be our president
can you name for me mrs roosevelt
any leading democrats
or republicans
who are in the same league with a
churchill or a gandhi or a roosevelt
who have the stature
to lead our free world against the
threat of communism
well at the present time
i don't think it would be fair to name
any
particular people because
it is very often the opportunity
which brings out the qualities in a man
and
most of the leaders
on the democratic
side have not had the opportunity
to
meet the responsibilities and to show us
whether they have
the
leadership qualities that are needed at
the present time
many of them have shown
ability
and
certain
different qualities but we have not yet
seen i don't think anyone in a position
and to show uh whether they had the full
leadership qualities that the present
day seems to require now on the
republican side of course
the only one who stands out is mr nixon
and he has made no mistakes of late he's
been extremely careful
i would say he had ability
how much conviction
is another question
well you mentioned mr nixon in your
column in the calls magazine in january
of 1956
you wrote about republican leaders and
about mr nixon you said the following
richard nixon would be the least
attractive
i know that driven of that given great
responsibility men sometimes change
which in a sense is what you're just
saying you say i know that given great
responsibility men sometimes change
but mr nixon's presidency would worry me
you said
why
do you reserve this special criticism
for mr nixon
because i think that in great crises
you need to have
deep rooted convictions
and i have a feeling
from the kind of campaigns that i have
watched mr nixon
in in the past
that his
convictions are not very strong
but you do admit that over the past year
in particular mr nixon seems to have
changed possibly to have grown with the
times
i have no idea whether he is grown i
would say that he was a very intelligent
person
and that he had
a very clear idea of what he wanted
and had
conducted himself wisely to achieve the
ends he desires
well by the same token would you have
said
that harry truman had shown great
conviction
prior to his being thrown into the
presidency
no i would not have again i did not know
him very well before
i would say
of mr truman that he rose to
the responsibilities thrust upon him
in
in a manner which was
very remarkable really
and that his
big decisions
very likely are going to mean that he
will go down in history as one of our
very good presidents
with with really
insufficient background to expect that
he would have acted that way yes
quite certainly well now i'm not
obviously asking you to endorse any
politician here and now
but the fact is that within the next 10
years or so the fate of the free world
may very well be decided and the
president of the united states may play
a major role
as a democrat then i put this to you
do you see even the beginnings of the
makings
of a washington or a lincoln or a wilson
or a roosevelt
in jack kennedy
or stuart symington or robert minor
or sophie williams who are the four men
most talked about as potential
democratic presidents
i i cannot tell you in in what will
happen in the next two years at the
moment the only person i see those
beginnings in is adjacent who has twice
run for the presidency and who has said
he would not run again
why
do you feel
what lack was there in mr stevenson that
caused the american people to reject him
not once but twice and reject him more
severely if you will the second time
than they did the first well i think
partly it is not so much a lack in him
as it was a hero worship of the
president
and perhaps a little bit the mccarty
period that we were still close to
but also in him
a
perhaps an inability
to
quite
put the things he believes in
in the language
or in the emotional
way
that will come home to the average human
being
i think possibly that you'd go along
with me
when i say that it will be difficult
should mr stevenson decide to run again
to sell the democratic party on
nominating him once again
in view of this let me read you from
something written by the new york post
columnist william shannon
on november 11th
writing of
two of the so-called glamour boys of the
democratic party
he said as follows he said about jack
kennedy's qualifications as a
presidential hopeful quote
kennedy at 40 is utterly without
executive experience he's never bossed
any operation bigger than his own
congressional office
and of new jersey's governor bob miner
shannon wrote miner at 49 is debarred
not by the thinness of his experience
but by its provincial character trenton
new jersey cannot by itself be a
training ground for a world statesman
and yet i
we have to agree in all conscience that
these are the men
that the democrats are talking about
right now mrs roosevelt men who would
have to sit down opposite
nikita khrushchev
i think
i
i don't know but i think we can among
them find one that can sit opposite
nikita khrushchev but i think the thing
we must look for
actually
is a growth
in
our people
and in whoever comes in
a quality
of
courage to tell our people
just what will conditions are
let me ask you a bald question
uh
do you think walter ruther would make a
good president of the united states
i had never thought of it but i
have a high regard for walter ruthers
intelligence
and
given
the opportunity and the responsibility
he might because
he has a knowledge of of the world's
peoples he's been around
the whole world as a worker and has
worked in almost uh every country of the
world and
that is a good background for knowing
about people and countries
i had never really given this much
thought before
but i think he might
be
um
a person able to grow
and whoever takes it has got to be able
to grow
you talk about the necessity for the
american people to grow
now what seem to be if we are to believe
a good deal of what we read what seem to
be the main preoccupations of the
american people today
bigger and better tail fins on
automobiles
westerns on television
sex drenched movies
fur coats
push buttons
alcoholism continues to increase
our mental institutions are full
perhaps it's a grim a too grim picture
but nonetheless
a reasonably accurate picture
when we talked with architect frank
lloyd wright
a few weeks back
he told us that because of all this
the united states is in grave danger of
declining as a world power as a
civilization and he underlines that in
his current book testament
do you think that mr wright is
completely wrong mrs roosevelt
i i think that estimate to the american
people is completely wrong
i feel quite sure that what the american
people lack is knowledge
i feel quite sure
that
the american people
if they have knowledge and leadership
can meet any crises just as well as
they've met it over and over again in
the past i can remember the cries of
horror when my husband said we had to
have 50 000 aeroplanes in a given period
but we had them
and the the difference was that the
people were told
what the reason was and why
and i have complete faith
in the american people's ability
if they know
and if they have leadership
no one can move without some leadership
and for the time being you feel that we
are bereft of leadership yes
during the depression your husband said
the only thing we have to fear is fear
itself
don't you think
[Music]
let me put it this way do you think that
it's that simple today
do we have anything concrete to fear
from the russians
yes
we have
to fear
the fact that they have
a
definite objective
around which they have built their whole
policy
uh we have met crises as we came to them
but i would find it hard to answer the
question of what our
future objective was for the world and
how we were building our policy to
achieve it
and that's what i think we need in order
to meet the
communist objective um i think that is
something we have to fear they have a
distinct objective
and they have
patience in planning and they plan a
long time ahead
and also they are dealing
with a situation
where
everything
that
comes to a people
is better than it was before so that
they have
a constant feeling that they are moving
forward
is it possible mrs roosevelt that
communism
state socialism anyway
is the wave of the future and that
capitalism is on its way out
well that is what mr khrushchev says
i don't know much about capitalism but i
do know about democracy and freedom
and if
capitalism may change in many many ways
i'm not really very much interested in
capitalism i'm enormously interested in
freedom
and retaining the right to have whatever
economy we want and to shape it as we
want
and
having sufficient
democracy so that the people actually
hold their government in their own hands
then you do not think if we wanted it
that it would be a catastrophe if
socialism came peacefully to the united
states as it has come to other nations
in the world
to a certain extent i don't see any real
need for socialism in the united states
immediately but
but things change and it may be that
there will come a need
for partial changes in our economy i
don't know i'm not an economist and i'm
not a financier
but i
i'm not worried by
that side of it i'm intensely anxious to
preserve the freedom that gives you the
right to think
and to act and to talk as you please
that i think is essential to happiness
and
and the life of the people
mr roosevelt in just a moment i'd like
to get your reaction
to the charges made by perhaps your most
severe critic westbrook peggler he once
wrote this about you
he said this woman
is a political force of enormous
ambitions i believe she is a menace
unscrupulous as to truth
vain
and cynical
all with a pretense of exaggerated
kindness and human feeling
which deceives millions of gullible
persons
in a moment i would like to get your
opinion
your reaction
to westbrook peggler's charge
and your opinion of mr peyton
and we'll get the answers
to those questions in just a minute
now then mrs roosevelt your reaction to
that charge by
westbrook peddler i don't feel that it's
necessary to repeat it i'm sure that you
heard it the first time around
well
it seems to me a little exaggerated let
us say
no one could be quite as bad as all that
and um
as far as
as
political ambition goes i think that's
rather answered itself because i've
never run for office and i've never
asked for an office of any kind so i
can't have much political ambition
but um
i can see
that mr pegler probably
believes all these things
and
i'm not
i suppose one does things unconsciously
that
makes you seem like that and perhaps
perhaps i do seem like that to him
and i think it must be terrible
to hate as many things as mr pegler
hates
um and i i would be unhappy i think and
therefore i'm afraid that he is unhappy
and i'm sorry for him because
after all we all grow older and we all
have to live with ourselves and
um
i think that must sometimes be difficult
for mr peggler
mrs roosevelt
i'm sure that you understand the sense
in which i put this question to you
but i think that you will agree
that a good many people hated your
husband
they even hated you
yes great many do still why
why
well
if you take
stands in any way
they and people feel that you have any
success in it in
in a following
uh why those who disagree with you
uh are going to feel very strongly about
it but there's more than just
disagreement involved there are people
who disagree with mr eisenhower and yet
they do not hate him
there was i lived in the middle west for
a good many years while your husband was
president and there was a real
core of of more than just disagreements
there no there was a real core of hatred
the people who would call him that man
and the people who would uh
gladly i remember one man
who rejoiced actually when he died
but
i i suppose that that is just a feeling
that certain people had that he was
destroying
the thing that they held
dear and and felt touched them
and uh naturally
you react to that
that with hatred and i suppose that's
what brought it about they still fight
him i mean i sometimes think that
campaigns are largely fought on my
husband rather than on the actual person
who's running
and um
as far as i was concerned i think
mine was largely again for that same
reason i was touching something which to
some people seemed
a a sacred
uh
thing they had to keep hold of
and a
major part of my criticism has been on
uh
the negro question of course and
uh i've had many others but that is the
major part
and i think that that is quite natural
because to some people that seems to be
destroying something that to them is
very dear
one of the things the press leaped on
last year was the fact that your son
franklin
acted as legal representative in the
united states for the dominican dictator
trujillo
as a crusader
for democracy and for freedom yourself
how did you feel about your sons working
for trujillo
well i asked my son about
what he was doing and he told me that he
was representing the government not mr
trujillo personally
that he felt that it was a legitimate
thing for him to do as a lawyer
and that he was not doing it for any
political reasons but for pure business
reasons as a lawyer
i do not as a rule
interfere
and i did not feel that i was
entitled to interfere in this case with
my children i leave them to do after
they are grown
on what they think right as i think all
young people have a right to do
do i
detect then that you would have been
just as happy had he not
represented trujillo
as it turned out i think it might have
been uh wiser yes but that is not uh i i
do not
stole my judgment above his he was doing
what he felt was legitimate to do and i
think he had a right to make his own
mind upon that subject
and now the final question the one that
i
promised at the beginning that i was
going to ask and that is about
garlic pills
i understand that you i don't know if
you do still but that at one time in the
not
too distant past
you ate garlic pills and i'd like to
know why and how they've worked out my
doctor told me to take them to help my
memory doesn't help my memory much but
nevertheless that's what i was given
them for
and do you still oh yes
and in spite of the fact that it hasn't
helped your memory well that's of course
age you gave me one more year and at my
age um
you don't like to add to your years
because they come too quickly anyway
i beg you but um that doesn't matter as
many ways only that they go so fast when
you get to be my age
and um
i suppose that it's that that gives me a
poor memory not the garlic pills
mrs roosevelt i thank you for taking the
time for coming and talking with us this
evening
because she'll fight courageously for
what she believes
eleanor roosevelt has had to pay a
certain price
bitter criticism a lack of privacy
the infighting of partisan politics
but eleanor roosevelt has also reaped
what must be the most satisfying of all
rewards the respect and with it the
affection
of
[Applause]
syndicated columnist drew pearson
appeared on the mike wallace interview
program in 1957 on the 16th anniversary
of the japanese bombing of pearl harbor
he discussed a number of subjects from
the dangers of a third world war to
whether or not president eisenhower
should resign because of his health
this program runs about 24 minutes
good evening tonight on the 16th
anniversary of pearl harbor
we bring you a special interview from
washington dc
we shall examine the dangers of another
pearl harbor a third world war with the
most controversial correspondent in
washington
drew pearson
drew in a moment i shall ask you whether
you think there's going to be a third
world war
we'll get your view on president
eisenhower's uncertain future and i
shall confront you with a charge made by
two past presidents of the united states
that you are a chronic and a vicious
liar with pipelines in the pentagon
congress and the white house mr pearson
has raised
storms of controversy by disclosing
secret government information and by
openly attacking
government officials he not only reports
the news
he makes it
drew first of all
do you have any late
inside information news
either as to the
russian sputnik the rocket part that is
reputedly fallen either in alaska or
someplace in the west coast of the north
american continent according to moscow
or about our vanguard fizzle at cape
canaveral down in florida
mike to the best of my knowledge
uh the sputnik did not fall in alaska or
the north american continent and
khrushchev is wrong i'm
fairly sure that
on the second point our recent failure
in cape canaveral
uh one important point
i'm not sure about this latest test but
in three other
secret
attempts
there was trouble
uh over the mechanism and a lot of
rivalry between general electric which
made the engine
and martin which made the rocket each
one claim the other was to blame a
complicated business including heat
spots in the engine
you mentioned three secret tests prior
to this last one how do you account for
the tremendous publicity given this last
test
down at cape canaveral because in the
first place president eisenhower is
october 9th press conference said that
the test would take place the first week
in december
and because uh
the
newspaper men were a little uh
eager about highlighting it and the
pentagon went along with them
crew this is the 16th anniversary of
pearl harbor
and not since that december 7th has
there been so much anxiety in the united
states about our being
destroyed in a war
you say that your predictions are 80
accurate
how do you weigh the danger of a third
world war
mike
[Applause]
at the moment i don't think there is too
great a danger
because
i think that the russians
and we both realize that another war
would be catastrophic
and the no side would win
furthermore i think the russians figured
that they can get what they want without
a war
by the cold war by psychological warfare
by economic warfare
but
there is a danger that some
trigger happy person
outside russia outside the united states
possibly the near east
might start a brush fire war which would
start a world war but i i'm i'm i'm
fairly optimistic maybe i'm optimistic
by nature but i don't think there's
going to be a war well then if what you
say is true why is everybody so worried
about sputnik
the icbm just last week you told our
reporter
america has become a second-class
military power
this apparently gives you
considerable concern why should it
if you believe that there is no real
danger of war because the united states
can't bargain with russia
except from strength
we are in a position to gradually lose
the cold war
lose our allies in western europe
president eisenhower has wanted to go
over to paris to hold our allies we can
lose piece by piece a war without having
the shop fired so the only the
psychological effects of sputnik
are more important the diplomatic
effects this sputnik isn't too important
militarily at the moment it may be later
on
but the effect on our allies is terrific
that's why and on the uncommitted
companies that's why yes
throughout the world
i was
the the
the uh
the british the french our best friends
are just worried for further nato
alliance is falling apart
because of this crisis of course has
been a good deal of talk that the
president in view of his failing health
should resign
last week the vice president said i
would like to scotch once and for all
rumors that the president is in such a
condition as to make it necessary for
him to resign and he referred to the
convalescent president as acting like a
caged lion and champing at the bit
direct quotes this would seem to be the
official administration position how
does it strike you
uh as to whether it's true or not that
he should not resign or that he doesn't
want to resign i don't think eisenhower
does want to resign for the moment
i think he's had in the back of his mind
and uh of nixon naturally is not going
to make a faux pas
uh such as he was reported as making
after the denver heart attack
uh
then uh nixon is is a
is much more qualified today than he was
before is is quite able well wait just a
second we'll get to that in a moment
first of all you say the faux pas that
he was reported to have made he was
reported to have made that by drew
pearson all by himself and i gather that
that was later found to be untrue but he
had not uh try to take over the reigns
the way mr pearson suggested not
entirely mike i was not the only one who
reported that
uh mr nixon behaved as if he was just
ready and anxious he denied it very
categorically you're quite right about
that
but
he had the
lawyers looking up the law as to whether
he could temporarily take over not not
completely but temporarily take over
there's been a lot of a lot of argument
all through american history as to
whether the vice president can take over
in case of
uh the indisposition of the president
drew do you think the president should
resign i do
because he is not well london instead of
my stating it that no for what reason
because he's bound to have more
illnesses he's had three difficult
illnesses more other minor illnesses he
has been
out of the white house a total of about
725 days which is approximately two
years out of five years in office and
you simply cannot run the presidency
unless you're a full-time president now
it's quite true that he said when he's
running for election that he could not
work as a full-time president the people
a lot of people don't remember that he
was honest with the people but
the fact is that he can't be a full-time
president in this time
of crisis and at any time you've got to
have a full-time president prediction
will he resign
well my prediction is
that uh
and this is a little bit not quite the
way you uh
stated it
but i predict
that mr nixon will become
president of the united states
within approximately a year
within approximately a year
and i gather from what you started to
say and from conversations
uh
with you but you don't think it's a bad
idea that you will
not that you don't think it's a bad idea
it's inevitable if the president
resigned that uh nixon be the president
or take over
uh but that you think that nixon will
make a good president
i think mr nixon will make a better
president than mr eisenhower
now the reason i say that
is that mr nixon has trained for this
job
very few vice presidents have ever
trained for the job harry truman
complained publicly
that it was difficult for him when he
first got in there to take over it's an
extremely difficult job as i don't need
to tell anyone
and this man nixon has gone out and
worked at foreign affairs has been been
pretty good at it
he's worked on the hill and uh
he's worked on atomic energy and
missiles well that we're all aware of on
this program two weeks ago though mrs
eleanor roosevelt said that in her
opinion while mr nixon had ability she
questioned his conviction
she described him pretty much the way
that you have described him numerous
times in your columns
she in a sense
it didn't trust his conviction well i
think said that she has a point there
and you asked me whether i thought he
would be a good president i said he
would be a better president than
eisenhower
because eisenhower is not making
decisions he doesn't know what's going
on in the white house on many many
things
uh i would describe mr nixon as a young
man with a wet finger in the wind to see
which way the wind is blowing
though in the last year
i do give him credit
for being right
on many many things that are of
importance the december 6 issue of
united states news and world report says
that in washington quote mr nixon often
is called the man nobody really knows mr
nixon has never sought to cultivate a
circle of close friends members of the
white house staff refer to the vice
president as an enigma end quote
how do you drew dope out this so-called
enigma
well
uh
a very ambitious young man
who has been on every side of every
political fence he started out as a new
dealer a member of opa under roosevelt
he became a member of the extreme right
wing the taft wing of the republican
party all his votes in the house and in
the senate were against labor against
the farmer
with big business recently he has become
uh a semi
uh liberal a member of the eisenhower
wing of the republican party do you
think these changes have come from
conviction or rather going i'm not sure
i i agree with mrs roosevelt i don't uh
i don't know about his convictions when
a young fellow
and he's relatively young changes that
fast
i i i just don't know but i do know that
in time of crisis at least i believe
that in time of crisis he would be a
pretty good president for this reason
that
most of his life he's played for his
ambition
now he's realized that ambition at least
would if he became president and he
would be playing for the history books
to make his name in history and to make
this country a great country
we hear about power struggles going on
inside the white house
drew
among nixon sherman adams
jim haggerty secretary dulles's name is
sometimes mentioned what do you know
about that
well my best knowledge is that there is
a definite power struggle
that nixon and dulles are on one side
that haggerty and sherman adams on the
on the other
uh
they have definitely not wanted nixon in
there
for for what reason
well they uh they feel that perhaps that
nixon is
pushing the president i don't think he
is at the present time
they don't like nixon they probably
share the view that uh mrs roosevelt has
held that uh perhaps he isn't a man of
conviction
i know that there's a lot of feeling
against nixon inside the white house but
not for the present well how do they
feel about how does the president feel
about nixon personally do you know
uh yeah i believe i know the the next uh
mr president feels very kindly to uh the
the president feels kindly toward nixon
whenever nixon has had a break
given any assignment it's been
through largely the president
sometimes through mr dulles on these
trips abroad but with the president's
blessing
mr nixon would seem to be the
glamour boy of the republican party the
democratic
glamour boy would seem to be senator
jack kennedy
in your column on october 27th you wrote
that senator kennedy's
and i quote
millionaire mccarthyite father crusty
old joseph p kennedy
is spending a fortune on a publicity
machine to make jack's name well known
no candidate in history you wrote
has ever had so much money spent on a
public relations advance build-up end
quote
what significance do you see in this
aside from the fact that uh joe kennedy
would like to see jack kennedy president
of the united states
well i don't know exactly what other
significance other than the fact that i
don't believe you should have a
synthetic public relations build up for
any job of that kind jack kennedy is a
fine young fellow very personable fellow
but he isn't as good as that public
relations campaign makes him out to be
he's the only man in history that i know
who won a pulitzer prize on a book which
was ghost written for him which
indicates the kind of public relations
build up he's had who wrote the book for
him i don't really call it the present
moment i
i know for a fact
that the books i do know profiles in
courage was written for senator kennedy
by somebody else i do and he got a
pulitzer prize for it and
and
he has never acknowledged the fact
no he is not there's a little wisecrack
around the senate
about jack who's a very handsome young
man as you know who
some of his colleagues say jack i wish
you had a little bit
less profile and more courage
and they refer to some of his voting
records
drew the last time i interviewed you
which was about a year ago you charge
that the president's press secretary jim
haggerty was muzzling white house
reporters you said that newsmen wouldn't
write stories
that would reflect badly on the
president because they were afraid to
antagonize jim haggerty
why should
sensibly know why should white house
reporters be afraid of jim hagerty
mike have you ever covered the white
house no i have not
well it wouldn't be very hard to
you wouldn't ask that question when you
are covering
uh a place like the white house where
you have to get certain
where you're trying to get inside news
and certain special privileges and so on
and so on uh jim haggerty is a very
powerful gentleman i think i may have
given you in that other interview i
forgot whether i did or not did i tell
how
the president got
no i did not because it hadn't happened
at that time but as an illustration
down at uh
secretary of the treasure humphreys
ranch or farm in georgia
mr eisenhower
lost his temper
with a gulf golf shot
took his golf club and threw it
against the golf mobile right across the
room right across the uh the putting
sport or whatever you call it i'm not a
golfer as you can see green
and
there was only one newspaper man now
that was that was important
the newspapermen were all there watching
here is a man who has a heart trouble
and is inclined uh
with uh with he has had high blood
pressure and when he loses his temper it
can be
symptomatic and at that time he had not
made up his mind whether to run again
this was in february 56
only one newspaper man wrote that story
that that man was marilyn smith no that
was andy tully well
general chain the scripts howard papers
which owns the united press i have
called up andy tully and i asked him
whether this appeared
whether this took place in front of the
other newspapermen he said yes it did i
said why didn't the others write it well
his only answer was when i
knew myself well
jim haggerty wouldn't like it
you know marilyn smith he's the dean of
the white house news an excellent man we
spoke about this same thing with him
last week here's what he told us he said
some people are upset by the fact that
they have to work to get their stories
you can't just call the president up on
the phone you have to work to find news
if you're willing to work there's plenty
of stories to be gotten at the white
house nobody stops you from going after
them it's up to the individual and his
skill
so could it be drew that your complaint
is
the sour grapes no i don't think so i
have no trouble getting stories from the
white house but barryman smith is in
large part correct mariam smith is a
very fine newspaper man
but uh the general tendency up until
recently
has been exactly as i described it
before
and it was not only true in this
administration it was true with steve
early was true and under under uh
roosevelt less true under truman it
depends somewhat of course on the
newspaper that a man is working for
and his publisher what his political
views are but believe me the press
secretary and particularly jim haggerty
is a very powerful person don't make any
mistake about it
drew i think that you will agree that
you have a rather remarkable record for
being called names that's right
president roosevelt once called you a
chronic liar president truman called you
an sob at one time and a vicious liar at
another time
the late tennessee senator kath mckeller
called you an ignorant liar a
pusillanimous liar a pee-wee liar a liar
during his manhood a liar by profession
a liar in the daytime and a liar in the
night time end quote he used up six
pages of the congressional record
calling me different types of liars what
is there about drew pearson that
inspires such bitterness
in presidents
and other statesmen
well mike um
i can't give an objective answer on that
you don't really expect me to do you
well i you want me to give a
self-serving answer is there obviously
you you'd almost have to give a
self-serving well could it be that
you're a liar
uh i i hope i'm not i don't believe that
i've ever knowingly told a lie but i
have made some mistakes
in the case of mckellar i made no
mistake
i did make a mistake once in regard to
harry truman which i was very sorry for
in which i apologized i had i had
forgotten frankly that he ever called me
a vicious liar because i remember the
other one so vividly
the s.o.b that i'd forgotten but mr
truman was a uh his head
has a pretty good vocabulary let me say
it was after you you reported that
truman allegedly accused new york jews
of disloyalty to the united states that
he called you a vicious liar
well
you're correct i had forgotten that
thank you for refreshing me
but uh i was i was um
i was correct on that
he changed his mind about that he never
really felt that i'm sure because he was
a great friend of israel and a great
friend of the jewish people but he did
lose his temper frequently
and sometimes he said things that he
regretted
now to come back to your question though
and it's an important and a legitimate
one
why do people call me a liar well
for one reason
when you hit the truth
sometimes
it hurts most
i've made mistakes
but look at some of the fellows who call
me a liar parnell thomas congressman
went to jail
congressman andy may of kentucky went to
jail congressman bramblet of california
later convicted
congressman bram
i'm not putting them in the same class
with roosevelt i dearly loved roosevelt
and hurt me deeply when he called me
a chronic liar which he did
and i
didn't particularly enjoy being called
that by
uh truman either but
uh
truman and truman uh
after all he he had vocabulary
drew
i'd like to ask you about another grave
charge made against you and that is that
you wantingly publish top secret
government information when you can get
your hands on it through devious means
and that you thereby endanger the
national security
in a moment i'd like to know where you
get such classified information why you
publish it against government's orders
and what you think of the recently
proposed legislation that would clap you
in jail should you do it again
we'll go after the answer to that
question in just 60 seconds
drew the next session of congress will
consider legislation that would impose
jail sentences on any person who
discloses or news leaks secret
government information this legislation
has been proposed by the commission on
government security whose chairman lloyd
wright has accused you specifically
of disclosing such information in your
columns
have you disclosed such information i
have
and will you news leak secret government
information in the future when you get
your hands on it
only if i am sure it will not upset the
security of the united states how can
you tell
i can tell
in two ways number one
the former head of the censorship bureau
in washington during the war described
me as
publicly as knowing more about the rules
of censorship and what would affect the
security of the united states than any
other newspaper man in washington he's
matt howard the now the editor of the
cleveland
news
second
i go
if i have any doubts to
the pentagon or any uh qualified agency
for instance the nickerson
document
which told certain things that never
should have been published and i never
did publish it it told the date when our
thor missile
would be fired so the russians could
have come off come right off the
atlantic coast and and watched it in
submarines if i had published that
i took it out of the pentagon
uh they
confiscated the document later i
published certain parts of it but not
those
sensitive parts what do you think of
proposed legislation drew that would
make you or any person liable to five
years in jail
for doing this kind of thing in the
future
no well i'm against it and the american
society of newspaper editors and every
other responsible newspaperman is
against it because
take right now
the missile race that we're where we're
behind russia why has
eisenhower suddenly spurred this up he
knew
three months ago that we were behind
russia in the icbm but only when the
public began to put pressure on him has
he really begun to the press has got to
uh serve as a gold as impetus as a spur
to the public
drew it's been said
look for the men piercing praises in his
column
they are his news leaks the men who
furnish him with information
how do you plead
i plead not guilty i have praised a lot
of people that i
uh never get any information from
charles wilson the former secretary of
defense
uh i have it on occasion to praise vice
president nixon him he has never given
me any news believe me
i sometimes praise people and sometimes
the opposite
drew i thank you for spending this time
with us this evening
on the anniversary of pearl harbor
and i congratulate you on your 25th
anniversary as a columnist which comes
up next friday
when you will have i'm told some 600
newspapers across the world as regular
subscribers to the drew pearson column
drew pearson has written exposes that
have helped send men to jail
he has stepped on toes in high places
and as he himself puts it
i have been sued more times than i can
remember
but especially at this time
when as he says the country needs an
aggressive fearless press
mr pearson is a good man to have in the
fourth estate
coming up
conservative newspaper and radio
commentator fulton lewis jr sat down
with mike wallace in 1958 to discuss his
political views and concerns for the
country
lewis also offered his opinions on then
president eisenhower and vice president
nixon
this program runs almost 25 minutes
good evening tonight we go after the
story of the political right wing in the
united states
senators jenner noland and goldwater
general douglas macarthur the late
senator joseph mccarthy
our guest will be a major spokesman for
the militant right wing newspaperman and
radio commentator fulton lewis jr
if you're curious to know why fulton
lewis jr attacks both democratic
liberals and eisenhower republicans
what he thinks of mccarthyism today
and how he explains the attraction the
far right has for crackpot fascist
groups in america we'll go after those
stories in just a moment
a mike wallace interview
and now to our story
before lewis jr
is perhaps the leading spokesman for the
militant right wing in america every
weeknight over 300 or perhaps even 400
radio stations from coast to coast and
daily in his syndicated newspaper column
fortes blasts everything politically to
the left of vice president dick nixon
a personal friend of such senators is
william jenner and brilliant nolan
mr lewis is to sum a fearless and
prophetic patriot to others
he is america's golden voice of reaction
let's try
to find out why important first of all
in order to chart your position as a
major spokesman for the militant right
wing in america i would like your
capsule opinions
of the following
president eisenhower
a very sincere individual who is trying
to do a job unfortunately does not have
the equipment by experience because he
uh has been raised in a school in which
uh when he calls for
a general g2 he gets a general trained
in g2
when he moved into the white house this
was the only form of administration that
he knew he called for people expecting
to find confident people come up to him
and what he got was politicians and
people who had made a campaign
contribution
a man fitted for his job
a man uh
uh a man morally fitted for his job
certainly and uh emotionally and so far
that he
in so far as he intends sincerely to do
a good job and tries to do one dick
nixon
dick nixon
is a young very aggressive probably the
best trained man
that has ever stood
impossible line for the presidency
a very sincere individual a very fine
clean family man
and an ardent anti-communist a man you'd
like to see president i would like very
much to see dick nixon president among
other people general douglas macarthur
general douglas macarthur
a very brilliant figure
a very cold figure
and one who stays behind
a very very thick high stone wall would
he have made a good president i think
perhaps in his younger years he would
have made a very excellent uh president
because
he's done a good job at anything and
everything that he's ever undertaken so
far as i know
generalism or frankly of spain very
interesting character
uh i wouldn't want him uh here in
america uh heaven knows uh
we want no dictators here
uh i do think that he has however done a
great year for spain
time magazine march 21st 1955 quote
among dictator franco's journalistic
admirers few have been more dedicated
than fort lewis jr
lewis has repeatedly charged that
criticism of franco's dictatorship came
from left wingers and pickles end quote
i cannot be responsible mike for what
time magazine they may or may not print
time added that when lewis visited spain
franco snubbed you therefore you may
change your tune this is no more
treating the first statement as a matter
of fact i had an interview with mr
franco enjoyed it very much it was a
very excellent interview the things that
he said i don't think would please you
from an american standpoint but uh they
told the truth so far as mr franco was
concerned gerald l k smith
there's one rule in my office
and this is the only person in the world
of whom they're surprised but i've only
met gerald l k smith once in my life
that was by accident on the train
in 1933 of four
about jlk smith alone among all people
alive today there is a rule in my office
that if anything any mail comes in or
telegrams come in that bear on the
outside of them any identification is
coming from gerald l k smith they go in
the waste paper basket without even
being open
adlai stevenson
adlai stevenson a very brilliant uh
figure but i'm afraid in his politics a
rather unstable one uh i don't mean
mentally unstable by this i mean
uh uh um wavering um
pottering uh
not holding to a single line the late
senator joseph mccarthy i think george
mccarthy did a great deal good for the
country
i think he was one of the most
courageous fighters against communism
that uh i have ever seen on the national
picture
uh i did not agree with everything that
he did and told him so on frequent
occasions when i disagree
i do think however that he gave his life
for the cause of anti-communism in
america
and for this i think he deserves great
credit
using senator mccarthy's appointed
departure fulton and you certainly were
one of his staunchest supporters during
his heyday between 1950 54
i'd like to ask you this question
what has been happening to people of
your political beliefs since mccarthy's
meteoric decline
what i mean by that is this we don't
hear very much about the far right
anymore
could it be that the far right is
discredited but you're a vanishing race
well now mike uh you have uh introduced
a matter of semantics in here
uh
i have not taken issue with you as to
this uh definition of the far right but
i would have to ask you what do you
consider the far right well i and i also
wanted to understand that i don't report
to uh speak for the people that you have
mentioned here they are my friends and
we think very much alike on many issues
but i am not
a spokesman for them well now uh when i
mentioned earlier the names of jenner
merlin
goldwater that's right
bricker rickard
uh styles bridges style bridges
the late herman welker the late
uh it may be that you consider them uh
of the far right and you certainly
aren't perfectly entitled to consider
them that way i call them the right but
i don't call them the far right
well uh would you
then care to differentiate between
the right
and will not circumstance what they are
what what do they stand for well they
stand first of all
uh universally
for
opposition to communists
subversive activities
subversion in government
this is only one of the things they also
stand for a resistance
against the ever-encroaching uh
uh octopus of um
bureaucracy
the ever-increasing power of uh
of a bloated uh
civil service
[Music]
they stand for
reasonable economy and government
they stand for progress when progress
uh
promises a desirable and a worthwhile
delivery
but not progress just for the sake of
progress with uh when the outcome and
the probable achievement is entirely
questionable well who
perhaps we can best find out who they
are and what they stand for by finding
out what and who they're against
who are they against
uh
nolan
well i i don't i don't follow your
question mike i don't see how
by uh
asking who bill nolan is against i don't
know who he's again well all right again
i'll tell you one place these again and
that's good tonight in california well
let me ask you this when i said earlier
that you were against eisenhower
republicans and eisenhower republicanism
and democratic liberals is that an
accurate statement no it is not because
i'm not against the
eisenhower republicans or as such
well
just last december 4th fulton you wrote
a column
bemoaning the fact that the kind of men
that you admire
the mccarthy's
the bob tafts you mentioned welker and
querrey
and indiana's right-wing isolationist
senator william jenner
you've remained the fact that these men
are vanishing from the scene
and you wrote this you said there are
not many left in their stead have come
mostly men of less rugged breed
now what did you mean by that
i meant by that that the people who have
taken or attempted to take over the
republican party are such as mr paul
hoffman
uh mr harold stassen who didn't succeed
very well
uh mr sherman adams
uh but then these are eisenhower
republicans these these happen to be
what they call eisenhower republicans
they do not however represent what mr
eisenhower purports to represent
as well and there are many more
eisenhower republicans you further said
i gather that you are a jenner man
jenner man and that he is a friend of
mine and we think very much alike on
many issues on most issues i should say
and you wrote of senator jenner's quote
deep-seated disgust for ike's palace
guard and what he jenner considers the
compromising double talking super
internationalist modernism that has
gained control of the administration now
i'm proud of those lines yes these are
your words
the point is that you seem to be worried
about the fact that these men are
disappearing from the scene why are they
disappearing well you asked me to ask me
about this writing here you presuppose
mike and this is a very dangerous uh
demonstrable dangerous uh assumption to
make
you presuppose that the so-called palace
guard actually represents the eisenhower
republican thinking it does not
you want to leave it there yes
let's look at the stand of the far right
and your role in it let's put your own
words back in your mouth i would like to
see exactly what you do represent and
what you are against
for instance in your writings and
broadcasts they are full of attacks on
what you call quote
the ultra liberal eastern crowd
the new york park avenue pink set
the left wing fund for the republic
the cio backed communist left-wing
crackpots
adlai stevenson and his ultra-liberals
of americans for democratic action now
these are all quotes from fort lewis
columns that's right and i suggest that
uh you certainly don't want people named
and specific application to those uh to
those things because there might be an
element of libel involved exactly now
what i'm after actual important is this
i listen to you almost every night
on my car radio thank you mike i watch
this show every saturday i'm glad to
hear that now i get the impression
fulton
that you are seriously distressed at the
state of this country
that you think that we are constantly on
the brink of
maybe communism but certainly socialism
that uh the government is being run by a
bunch of evil crackpots or men who are
less than patriotic certainly less than
confidence now then we're in a heck of a
state now let me ask you a question when
i say that
you say that i think the government is
being run by people who are something
less incompetent
what people are you talking about when
you say uh the government is being run
do you realize that the government is
not run by the cabinet and by the
president
it's being run by home it is being run
by the civil service structure of the
government that has been in there for
many many years it is so firmly
entrenched
the eisenhower administration might go
only down through the level of
secretaries and assistant secretaries
below that level everything is civil
service
and it functions the same just the same
in this administration as it functioned
in the past administration but the
policies certainly aren't made are they
by the civil service the policies are
made by the president
and they are passed on down to the civil
service people at which level the civil
service people do exactly as they please
as they have done in the past and much
of the policy itself
the policy planning staff of the state
department he's not in the hands of mr
dallas at all the policy planning staff
of the state department is in the hands
of the foreign service
in other words foreign services mr
dallas is just to charlie mccarthy for
the men who are the the career man in
the state department was at the point
considerable degree that's exactly true
exactly true
as was his predecessor and his
predecessor before him
john foster dallas and dwight eisenhower
are not making the foreign policy and
broad overall top side they are but they
uh
the president himself said that if he
were to give a directive
about a change
in the operation of a certain bureau or
agency
it would be at least two years before
his orders ever got down to the
operating level that's what i'm talking
about well then what would you like to
do about all of this virtual if what you
say is true
well i think you're very
definitely that certain things are
indicated the most important of them is
to do a realistic
uh objective overhaul of the civil
service system and make it into the
thing that it was supposed to be how
would you suggest that we go about this
in the first place there should be in
order to make government responsive to
the will of the people to the expressed
will of the people through the congress
and through its elections for president
the president himself ought to have the
power to appoint everyone who has any
part in policy making all the way down
into the into the ranks of the
department i don't mean
clerks i don't mean technicians i don't
mean scientists in the department of
agriculture
i most certainly do mean everybody below
the level of secretary right on down who
is in any wise connected with policy
making and that means
go ahead you wanted to well i don't want
to i did want to interrupt because if
this were that important to you and as i
said i listen to you every night uh
chances are that over the past months i
would have heard more of this from you
than i have because nightly when i
listen to you i get the impression that
this country as i say is an awful state
that we are leaderless that we are being
betrayed and i don't mean in a
traitorous sense that we are being
betrayed by incompetence in our
government we are
well in what sense i don't i don't
follow uh we are being betrayed by the
bureaucracy of civil service these
people
but forth over the years and years and
years are used to doing the same thing
in the same way and following the same
pattern and they have come to believe
that they have
a vested interest in their particular
job they are protected from removal they
are protected from firing
and the elected representatives of the
people
eisenhower and his cabinet who are not
elected obviously but uh
the senate and the congress
of the united states are simply
powerless to change the course of events
the congress of the united states is not
powerless to change the course of events
but the president certainly is
a year he is the prisoner of the civil
service system
over the years you've been accused of
many things as oh many have has every
stormy petrol life magazine has accused
you of a quote disgraceful abuse of the
news
an article in harper's magazine speaks
of your quote headlong one-sidedness a
journal called the public opinion
quarterly has carried an article about
you called quote what constitutes
irresponsibility on the air a case study
these are just a few it was laughing
public opinion quarterly carried an
article about you called
what constitutes irresponsibility on the
air a case study end quote did you take
the trouble mike you get the copy of the
following uh edition of that quarterly
the following edition of the following
edition would you like next quarterly
uh i don't have it here with me person
i'd do that with the other side of the
story in which i
exposed the writer of the original
article for his complete and total
irresponsibility and prove the
misstatements which he made throughout
how do you feel about this kind of
criticism
it rolls off my back like water off a
duck
truly truly
uh
let me ask you this how do you feel when
men like gerald l k smith whom you
profess to abhor
whom i do uphold and you do abhor
are so frequently or is so frequently an
admirer of the same men
that you admire
general douglas macarthur senator
mccarthy
and for a while even vice president
nixon although he's changed his attack
on nixon and it should be said here that
nixon is dismissed uh has denounced
smith as a hate monger too
uh as i have as you have
tell me this what what is the appeal
that these men
has for the lunatic fringe in america
now with these men uh you just mentioned
it gerald l k smith yes macarthur
mccarthy and then nixon for a while
i don't know it certainly is true
however that the conservative side of
the picture has attached to it
a lunatic fringe make no mistake about
this
and is the thing that disturbs me
you uh use the term extreme right i
prefer the term conservative
but uh i find a very considerable amount
of lunatic friends that adheres
like lint to the coattails of the
conservative
side of the american picture
why i can't say unfortunately mike you
can't uh control who follows you down
the street or who writes your letters
answer me this if you will sir
earlier this week my reporter spent some
time with you in washington had lunch
with you very nice young man by the way
well he said that you said as follows
this is a quote
if the political lines were drawn
sharply between left wing and right wing
in america and there was an election
the entire nation would go right except
new york state
you said and your reason was this quote
because of the kind of people there who
are inclined or have been led toward the
left
they are the puerto rican imports and
the people of european origin who are
looking for something for nothing
people who have the dog eat dog
philosophy end quote
now in a moment
i'd like you to tell us what you mean by
that
and we'll get the answer to that
question in just 60 seconds you want me
to read that uh quote to you again or do
you think you have it well in mind uh
yes i'd like to have you read it mike if
you will uh
if the political lines were drawn
sharply between left wing and right wing
in america there was an election the
entire nation would go right except new
york state because of the kind of people
in new york state were inclined or have
been led toward the left there are the
puerto rican imports and the people of
european origin who are looking for
something for nothing people who have
the dog eat dog philosophy they're
looking for something for nothing uh
this was a very excellent reporter and
that's almost correctly looking for
something for nothing
uh is not quite an accurate appraisal i
have not done not this that in mind what
i did tell the young man and with the
very delightful young man
was that new york and some of the uh
large population centers have been
taught
because of selfish uh political
techniques have been taught
to try to get something for nothing to
have been taught to believe that they
are entitled uh to something for nothing
and in that sense there is a dog-eat-dog
philosophy but you really believe that
if there were an election between
extreme right and extreme left the
extreme right would win all over the
country except new york is not what i
said i said between a clear-drawn
election between the right between
conservatives i didn't use the right
between conservatives
conservatism and liberalism and this is
the thing that i have been driving for
for years and years and years and until
we get it the american people are not
going to be able to uh have a free
expression
if we could get a an election between
the conservatives and the liberals there
is not any question in my mind
whatsoever you speak of a small minority
no question in my mind whatsoever that
the balance would be sixty to seventy
five percent on the conservative side
uh
and new york state would go left
city would go uh left new york state
certainly would not uh
uh
city what about men like paul douglas or
hubert humphrey or wayne morris or
richard newberger certainly these men
are not conservative all of these men
were elected against people who were
just as uh just as liberal as they were
well then while you said the answer to
your question mike lies in the fact that
every time every time the republicans
have put up one of their liberal
uh candidates the candidate has lost in
uh except in the case of javits of new
york well then why don't you why do you
belong the fact that men of less rugged
breed to use your own words
are replacing men like mccarthy worry
welker
uh jenner now
uh
this is your own statement yes but i
didn't mean that they were replacing
them in the senate i meant that they
were replacing them in the councils of
the party do you really believe that
what you conserved uh consider to be the
right is a strong group i believe in 75
percent of the people of the united
states and if they ever get a chance to
express themselves they will well this
is a democracy why don't they have the
right to do
because both parties have been so
infiltrated by
uh those who think that uh they can give
or buy votes
but both parties have ended up to be the
same thing explain to me
mike if you would be so kind as to
as to how uh jacob javits
and uh bill nolan the members of the
same republican party and how uh
uh john stennis of mississippi and wayne
morris are members of the same
democratic party does this make sense do
you respect jacob jarvis as a senator i
respect jacob javits as a senator and
i think he had no course other than to
adopt the policy policies that he has
adopted if he is going to expect to get
the new york city vote which is
necessary for him to get in new york
state in order to win
fourth and one last question we have
just about a half a minute you have a
son fulton lewis iii 22 years old i
believe i certainly have i'm told in
reliable authority that when he attended
the university of virginia he joined a
liberal club or group of some sort and
that you heard about it you got to saw
that you went down there and gave him a
good balling out and apparently
frightened him into quitting true or
untrue that is just about as untrue and
is diametrically the opposite of the
truth he joined a very ultra
conservative organization
uh got some bad editorials from the uh
local newspaper down there i went down
there and tried to persuade him not as a
freshman to force his way into a
communist hunt on the campus of the
university of virginia and persuaded him
to do so
i must say that the story that we got
was from a very good friend of yours in
washington in any case i thank you for
coming and spending this half hour with
us here in new york tonight
hilton lewis jr reflects the thinking of
a small but significant force
on the american scene
maybe it's larger
than we have been led been led to
believe
but he does perform an even more
important function
he challenges those of us who are
indifferent to politics or too lazy to
bother
he challenges us
to make up our minds
coming up retired blackhawk helicopter
pilot michael durant be
starting that momentarily we'll be
heading over to the capitol in just a
few minutes
mike wallace interviewed writer and
nobel prize winner pearl s buck in 1958
about what he described as a major
social problem in the united states what
he termed a battle between the sexes
this program is about 25 minutes
good evening tonight we'll talk about
men and women in the united states at
home at work and in love
our guest will be one of the most
successful women in the world the
pulitzer and nobel prize-winning
novelist pearl buck a writer who is also
a wife and mother
if you're curious to know what pearl
buck thinks of american women and their
husbands why she says
most women make their homes their graves
and why she attacks our devotion to sex
appeal and romance
we'll go after those stories in just a
moment
the mike wallace interview
and now to our story ever since she
began writing as a young woman in china
where she was raised by her missionary
parents
provoke has been intrigued by the battle
between the sexes
this contest has become a major social
problem in the united states
as women find themselves torn between
career and marriage between independence
and security
between emancipation and conventional
morality
as a wife and mother
and author of good earth and about 40
other works pearl buck has apparently
had
the best of both possible worlds
ms buck in view of your remarkable
career first of all let me ask you this
earlier this week you told our reporter
this you said
most women are making their homes their
graves
what did you mean by that
but i suppose i meant that they bury
themselves there when they don't need to
of course i believe in home you know
well of course you believe in home but
when you say they bury themselves there
would you be more specific so that we
could understand it
uh what i meant by that was that they
can
fulfill all the obligations and joys of
home and at the same time be citizens of
their nation and of the world
and you feel that women insufficiently
do that is that the point well to an
extent i think so
you said if i may
he said
that you had said you have women who can
think only how to flatter their men and
who cater to their stomachs and their
every whim that's an insult for any
woman
well i think that's an insult for a man
and i think many men feel it so as a
matter of fact i don't know that
many women actually just treat their men
that way
but i don't like in general for the sake
of men to
have it said that the approach is
through the stomach or even solely
through the heart
well
the approach can very well be fully
fulfillingly just through the home a
woman doesn't do you feel that a woman
has to be uh has to go downtown or
necessarily has to work in government or
in something of the sort in order to be
a complete woman really i'm very glad
you asked that question because
certainly i don't
in fact she can fulfill
everything in the nature of being a
citizen
by being
a woman at home and she certainly must
be at home while her children are small
well then i then i find it difficult to
understand how you can say that most
women make their homes their graves
but i think because they stopped reading
or reading
books that would enlarge their minds the
minds of their families
for example
approximately one-third of all the jobs
in this country are held by women uh
miss buck half of these women are
married we have wives who belong to
clubs work for charities play cards
true
quite true
is it not even a fact that possibly
uh
the fact that women have to split
themselves so
their job being tougher than that of men
is partially responsible for the
weakening of family ties and the
degeneration of the family in america i
quite agree
well we can have no argument there at
all
then how then how would you suggest that
then let us go to the root of the
problem which is to try to understand
how a woman can successfully
enter both worlds
but i think she has the same problem
that men do really
because
actually
if we're going to go to the root of the
problem
i think it isn't so much the isolation
from one another men from women and
women from men and the fact that you
know it is very difficult to be an
american did you realize that
we're actually uh
we're in a sense we're
committed to loneliness when you have
these great ideals of independence and
of freedom
many of the old bulwarks that the oldest
civilizations have
are thrown away
and
it's a great adventure so to speak
i'm not sure that i i'm not sure that i
understand not understand well
if you've lived in an old country such
as china or japan or even in the old
countries of europe you have so much
tradition of family
uh church
the same church perhaps at least not
such a variety of religions as we have
so much less choice as an individual
that you are you have supports that we
don't have in our civilization i think
it's our strength that we don't have
them but i think that oftentimes what we
think of as the loneliness of women or
the loneliness of men is really a sort
of human loneliness
which our freedom and independence
uh commit us to
and so often we think we're lonely
because we're women or we're lonely
because we're a man but we're really
lonely because uh we are living in a
country with no boundaries so to speak
and no patterns
and an immense ideals
which are difficult for us to follow
and yet which give us an enormous
responsibility in the eyes of the
world's peoples
let's come back just to women
and look at what some people say is
happening in america apparently because
of feminism of which i believe that you
are a champion no you're quite wrong am
i yes
i'm not a feminist
i was under the impression now i'm happy
to be corrected i was under the
impression that you are
rather militant in your desire that a
woman find herself as an independent
free spirit and that you feel that she
cannot find herself or is not finding
yourself as an
independent free spirit currently in the
hall
no i think of of the fact that i i think
that what i feel is that women have to
find themselves as human beings just as
men do
and that
they will find themselves
as these three spirits that you speak of
when they are really fulfilling
themselves as human beings
cooperative fashion can a career woman
for instance
do you think successfully have her
career and have her home
certainly she can she can't always have
them both at the same time
because there are always years you know
when you must devote yourself to your
children
i'm lucky because i've done my work at
home
but there are years when the woman
certainly cannot go out to offices or so
on and
take care of her children at the same
time she may employ other people to do
it well then you would suggest that the
average woman who has young children not
make any effort
to go after a career at one at the same
time
well if she wants a career it will come
and she will have it she may have to
postpone it for a few years but those
years need not be what i might call
graveyards i mean bury herself but let's
be let's be uh perfectly sensible an
awful lot of families need the extra
money
that uh or or think that they need the
extra money that the woman can bring in
the husband by himself cannot bring
enough of the labor-saving gadgets they
cannot lay enough money aside and these
uh
days of high taxes and so forth for
future education for vacations and for
some of the pleasantnesses
of life therefore they go downtown
oh well that's an individual thing if
they have to have more money of course
sometimes they do have to have it
and i think women will have to work out
some means of
of uh taking care of each other's
children or some such thing as that
but i think ideally these things can be
worked out
i think that
you're regarding this in perhaps a
rather olympian fashion you say you
think perhaps
this can be worked out
is it as easy as that for instance in a
life magazine article just a couple of
years ago robert coughlin said
here in new york city the career woman
can be seen in fullest bloom
and it is not irrelevant that new york
city also has the greatest concentration
of psychiatrists
she dislikes housework he says she has
never learned how to cook she turned the
children over to nurses as soon as she
could
she never gives much of herself to her
husband and he wishes that she would do
more of the things that women are
supposed to do he wishes she were more
of a woman
well
of course that is rather a large
statement too and i think of course we
women hear a great many things that men
say about us
and i suppose many of these things are
true
but the fact remains nevertheless
if i have a criticism of american women
and i must tell you that i think
american women are remarkable
and i'm not going to uh run them down
because i i think they're
really a wonderful and the extraordinary
thing is that european women and women
of of asian countries are more or less
taking uh
american women as models
and they're enlarging their own lives
seeing american women
if i did make a comparison however
between the american woman and the asian
woman
i would perhaps say that
the asian woman has learned long since
not to measure her men and her children
in terms of whether they make successes
according to the
accepted idea of success
in our american world of money
money and position and so on and she is
more inclined to
enjoy them as they are and
be interested in them as individuals
rather than as instruments
toward general success
and when i happen to say that to an
american man he said well i'm not sure
that that's a good idea
because the american man needs this
feminist and look how much further along
we are as a nation than the
chinese are saying science for example
so there are things to be said on both
sides well what is it that you admire
then so much about american women as
you've said that you
as you have just said that you what i
don't admire is the fact that they uh
tend to allow themselves to slap a slump
uh mentally
because they are housed housewives but
it's so difficult perhaps you don't have
to perhaps you truly
undoubtedly you truly are not an average
american woman and they
they have so many problems that kids to
take care of and no help to help them
take care of them the husband to console
the infinite number of chores during the
course of the day and you at the same
time say keep your mind alert keep
abreast of current affairs
read books
where in the world do people get the
time and the energy
to do all these things miss buck by
organization of time i have to organize
my life very highly too because i have a
large family and i have a full-time job
and i do other things
but it means you eliminate the things
that are not essential and concentrate
on the few essentials it can be done if
one wishes to enough and if one feels an
obligation you know and an interest
in being a human being and a citizen as
well as a mother spark also you told our
reporter it's a terrible shock to hear
women when they get alone and talk about
men now pardon my simple curiosity but
i'd like to know what do they say don't
think i'm going to tell you what they
say because i'm not why not
well i don't think that would be cricket
but nevertheless uh i think that i'm
sometimes rather appalled i quite
confess
by the fact that uh while our women
adore their men
and uh wouldn't be without them
they
[Music]
don't sufficiently respect them shall we
say why don't they respect their men
i you would have to tell me that
oh now come yes you certainly know
yourself why
i don't know whether you're reflecting
your own point of view or the point of
view of women around you with whom
you've talked and so forth they don't
respect their men why why well i don't
know i can't imagine
is it because women themselves try to
emasculate men and therefore
build i'm quite serious about this and
for that reason
uh
i don't mean to go over psychological
here
but they
they want to usurp the place of men
no i don't think any women really want
to usurp the place of men i think we do
have a peculiar circumstance in our
country
in that we have we educate our boys and
girls exactly the same
and so that
the fields of success are the same
and i think that uh women have the
obligation and the right to do anything
that they wish but to do it as women
and not as men
but having exactly the same education
sometimes they don't know how to do it
as women they don't know what their
contribution is
by the way i've just the reason i'm
interested in this particular subject is
i've just written a play on this very
subject
of what a woman is and how what are her
functions and what is what is she as a
human being
yes it is it's been lots of fun writing
it's called the white bird
and it's going to be produced in the
fall yes good can you capitalize what a
woman is for us
or would you rather not she's a human
being a woman human being that's all our
common denominator is human being well
aside from biology what are the
important differences between
men and women miss buck
you're asking me that in this little
while well we have uh 15 minutes if
you'd
care to discourse
well i think that women
if i must discuss
what whatever you whatever you want to
say
i think women do have a particular point
of view
it isn't competitive with men at all
i think they're less romantic than men
less emotional
much more practical
uh much more independent
than men are you're talking about
american women uh women anywhere in the
world this is common woman
uh state
uh they tend towards they they they are
interested in life and not in death i
think oftentimes men have
if we are to generalize and i'm doing
what i hate is to generalize
because we we can't say that
these things are true of all individuals
of course but i think that uh women
believe in life it's natural that they
sure they create
they're creative people because they
create children
and i know it's commonly said that they
don't create they haven't created great
works of art
but their reasons i think for that i
think the time will come when they will
but nevertheless
it's um
a life interest the life urge and i
think that the men in general don't have
that
miss buck if i may say this
i asked you before what women
think about men what they say about men
when they get together
and i gather we have gotten a rather
elevated version
of what they say about men i i would
gather from what you have told me now
for the past minute or two
that you don't respect men very much
well i think i respect individual men
very much i don't say
i would never say i don't respect men
well i know you can't generalize but but
look at all of the things that you've
said over the past minute or two i think
that you think that men are infinitely
superior really or not infinitely but
considerably superior to men women are
superior to men
as human beings yeah you mean women you
said men who are affected no but that
that women are superior to men yet no i
don't think so i think they're
complimentary the two complement each
other i'm not going to be uh in legal in
the saying
don't be vegan into saying anything
i understand i understand as a writer
you are constantly approached by
publishers to write about young love
and we do have in our society an
emphasis on romance and external sex
appeal
makeup revealing clothes
erotic advertising how do you account
for that
well i think we're interested in youth
in our country
we're very young
and
we haven't really lived long enough to
to understand the joys of being old or
mature let's say
let's talk and we also love that the we
we perhaps don't realize that that
ecstasy of first love is uh is not the
only form of love nor even the most
interesting
well let's talk a minute about a mature
relationship between a husband and wife
yeah the french
philosopher simone de beauvoir wrote
this she said man and wife reach a
compromise
they live side by side without too much
mutual torment too much lying to each
other but there is one curse they very
rarely escape it is boredom
a thousand evenings of vague small talk
blank silences yawning over the
newspaper and retiring at bedtime
how can that be avoided in modern
marriage
well i don't understand that passage at
all except for this very french perhaps
the french are easily bored
you don't think that this is a national
uh i don't think so occupational or
marital hazard boredom is not i don't
think so
in fact i am quite interested in the in
the fact that women and men do do a
considerable number of things together
do you think we are bored with each
other at home
i i do i think
i'm here to listen to you
tell me this if a man and a wife
well perhaps there's no point in going
on with this uh
you uh
you said
a little while ago
i i can't reconstruct it let me ask you
this way you told our reporter again
earlier this week you said i'm beginning
to think of my own death with excitement
and zest
now in just a moment
i would like to hear why
now then this buck earlier this week you
said i'm beginning to think of my own
death with excitement and zest
that sounds rather contradictory doesn't
it yes yes
well that's uh taken out of context as a
matter of fact it's so interesting to
have these things brought back to you
and sort of pills the bits out of what
you had it's a little difficult what i
was said really was that in relation to
this idea of romantic love and editors
do want you to write stories so often
about romantic love not seeming to
realize that each age has its
compensations
and its companionships and its mature
relationships and i use as an example
the fact that
young people especially well i won't say
especially women in this case perhaps
but children young people are very
frightened of death
and yet as you grow older
that fear naturally passes away
until as you get to be really
interested
in the next phase of whatever it is to
be
you find this fear of death is gone
and you begin to have a certain
excitement as to what comes after i've
often said that i hope uh when i die i
won't say i often say it but i i hope
that when i die that i won't be
unconscious i want to be sure that i
know what's going on
so i understand every step of life
because of course death is a part of
life
uh at some end or other
your parents were presbyterian
missionaries in china were there yes
does formal religion
give you any consolation
or any other
i don't think i have a i feel any
particular need of constellation i've
had an extraordinarily happy and good
life and expect to have considerable a
little bit more of it
and of course um having lived in china
so long i had uh tutors and other
religions too
and to me these religions are all
approaches to the same
end
there's so little time left but with
your experience in china i would feel
remiss if i didn't ask you this
on a totally different subject
do you feel the united states can do
anything to lessen the menace
that red china would seem to be to the
west at this time certainly
of course i always have to speak in
human terms you know being a writer an
artist and not interested well i must
say i'm not interested in politics but
i'm not a politician but any human
approach
helps toward this end a small or large i
do my own small approach through welcome
house
which is an adoption agency for mixed
blood children a mixed asian american
children i think that helps in its own
small way i should like to see for
example
all sorts of contacts human contacts
begin between ourselves and china or any
country why not and of course you
believe that red china should be
recognized i say of course because
you've said that publicly what i said
was that i believe that the united
nations
should be made up of all nations and
peoples
and that would include whatever nations
there are in the world
what what do you understand to be our
reluctance when i say our the united
states reluctance to deal with regional
direction i really am not uh competent
to say
uh not thinking in those terms i suppose
we are committed
uh to various other persons that we have
military bases and so on but i'm that it
seems to me none of that keeps us from
human contact
if we really set ourselves to it
contacts perhaps similar to those which
have recently been arranged between our
state department and russia
do you think the chinese people as a
whole on the mainland
want chiang kai-shek to drive the
communists out and head their government
again
i don't know i have no contact with that
mainland at all
today i was cut off from it as though
i'd never been there an amazing thing
are you i imagine a little wistful about
it no no it's inevitable
and you are not wistful about what is
inevitable
no i've learned better
final question to come back to our
original subject
uh simone de beauvoir
talks about the second sex do you feel
that women in america are the second set
does that mean inferior regarded as
inferior not in facts now
i don't think so i think women
really here are are on their way they're
in transition
they have all sorts of problems of
course but i think that as fast as as
fast as they want to grow men want them
to grow don't you think so
i'm not sure but i thank you for
spending this time
when i say i'm not sure what i mean of
course is that
i'm not sure that the vast majority of
men want them to grow that fast that
they will come out of the
out of the home and don't say leave the
home you know i don't mean leave the
home no you suggest that they fracture
themselves and leave half there and
bring the other half downtown you think
it can be done
despite vast strides in recent years
women in america are still considered by
some
if not by pro buck the second sex and
faced with double standards too
curl buck is obviously an exception she
thinks speaks and acts for herself and
somehow in the process
she would seem to have become not less
but more of a woman
[Applause]
abba eben the israeli ambassador to the
united states in 1958 appeared on the
mike wallace interview program on the
10th anniversary of israel's founding
eben reflected on israel's creation the
arab-israeli conflict and the role of
american jews in israel's future this
program is about 23 minutes
good evening tonight
we go after a story that has been
thousands of years in the making the
story of israel
the country which celebrates its 10th
anniversary this month our guest
abba eban israel's ambassador to the
united states and its chief delegate to
the united nations
if you're curious to hear ambassador
even's views on the recent mergers by
arab nations which are hostile to israel
his views on egypt's president nasser
and the arab refugee problem
on american jewry
and the charge that israel threatens
world peace with a policy of territorial
expansion
we'll go after those stories in a moment
and now to our story abba eben israel's
ambassador to the united states is a
scholar a linguist
a persuasive orator
a veteran statesman at the age of 43
he has been called the voice of israel
which is also the title of his book
tonight in order to clarify israel's
problems her hopes and her aspirations
we shall put to ambassador eben
questions raised by israel's critics
some of them
by her enemies
mr ambassador in its
ten years as a nation
israel has been involved in repeated
violence major border incidents two open
wars with the arabs the first in 48 the
last in 56.
what do you foresee for the next 10
years do you foresee continuing violence
well mr wallace the last 10 years have
not only been years of violence
they have been incomparable years of
joyous creation of sovereignty restored
of the people gathered in of a land
revived of democracy established but
there has also been violence imposed by
the hostility of our neighbors
for our second decade we devoutly hope
for a period of peaceful consolidation
we hope that there will be no recurrence
of the
violent conflicts which marked our first
decade but that we and our kindred
neighbouring people
will devote all our efforts to the
development of our respective countries
and of our common region
all over the middle east too though will
you not find that the
huge majority of the arab peoples
are interested in the extermination of
israel
we find that the governments of arab
countries still articulate the aim of
our extermination
but i think it's beyond their powers to
achieve it and of course in any
international system which respect law
and morality there must be resistance to
any such policy do you think that we are
currently going through a lull before
the storm our former secretary of the
air force thomas finletter told zionist
leaders in america just a month ago that
the present middle east situation is
a lull before a possible storm and he
added that we have good reason he said
to be apprehensive
over the ultimate direction of the arab
mergers i think his great degree of
vigilance is called for so long as arab
policy continues
to be devoted if only verbally to the
vision of israel's destruction on the
other hand if this lal as you call it if
this tranquility can be preserved
if passions are calmed if israel gives
an ever increasing demonstration of her
permanence and stability
i don't exclude the possibility that the
present lao might merge into a climate
more conducive to peace well
allah
will emerge into a climate more
conducive to peace if perhaps some of
the issues behind the arab israeli
hostility can be settled let's take a
look at first the refugee problem
an estimated 700 000 palestinian arabs
were left homeless during the arab
israeli war of 48.
israel refuses to read them
they live in bitterness
and such men as historian arnold
has said this
the evil deeds committed by the zionist
jews against the arabs
are comparable to crimes committed
against the jews by the nazis
how do you feel about that well about
professor tineby's statement i can only
repeat what i've written that it is a
monstrous blasphemy
here he takes the massacre of millions
of our men women and children
and he compares it to the plight of arab
refugees alive
on their kindred soil
suffering certain anguish but of course
possessed of the supreme gift of life
this equation between massacre and
temporary suffering which can easily be
alleviated
is i think a distortion of any historic
perspective what but the refugee problem
mr wallace isn't the cause of tension
the refugee problem is the result of an
arab policy a narrow policy which
created the problem
by the invasion of israel which
perpetuates it by refusing
to accommodate them into their expanding
labor market
and which refuses to solve a problem
which they have the full capacity to
solve there is i think a basic
immorality in this attitude of arab
governments to their own kinsmen whose
plight they could relieve immediately
once the will to relieve it existed all
world opinion admits that the problem
can only be solved on a regional basis
by opening the vast resources of the
arab world to this arab refugee
population and if there were such an
effort on their part
to approach a regional settlement israel
would make its due and just contribution
of course the problem with the refugees
is alive with the problem of territorial
expansion on the part of israel a major
arab spokesman here in the united states
dr fires syed says this he says the area
of the territories held by israel today
exceeds by about 40 percent
the area of the territories given israel
by the united nations
most of this added area he says was
taken by force and should therefore be
relinquished by israel
well i think this gentleman need not
lose any sleep at night worrying about
whether the state of israel is too big
really there is nothing more grotesque
or eccentric in the international life
of our times
than the doctrine that little israel 8
000 square miles in area
should become even smaller in order that
the vast arab empire should still
further expand there are really two
aspects mr wallace to every territorial
problem the legal aspect and the model
aspect
the law is clear
the present territorial frontiers rest
on agreements between israel and the
arab states which cannot be changed
except by consent the arab states have
signed those agreements which give them
and us a veto power
against any territorial change to which
we do not agree so that there's no legal
abuse in the present situation well you
and the arabs have hardly signed a
territorial agreement that involves what
what territory israel took as a result
of the 48 wars oh yes we have the
present agreements between israel and
the arab states to limit the precise
territory which we hold now israel does
not possess a single inch of territory
beyond the valid agreements which she
has signed and which the united nations
has ratified and under the terms of an
armistice pending final settlement yes
but in that final settlement as it is
written in the agreements no changes can
be accepted without the consent of both
parties so we are within our rights and
they are within their rights in
accepting or refusing any change so
there's nothing whatever illegal about
any aspect of the present territorial
question but the moral issue is the most
important here well now that's the point
that i would like to talk to if i may
the fact remains when we talk about
morality the fact remains that israel
benefited territorially from a war from
armed violence yes i'm glad to say that
i hope that whenever countries wage a
war of aggression as the arab states did
that they should be the losers by waging
that war of aggression well as a member
of the judaic faith which cherishes
social justice and morality
do you believe that any country should
profit territorially from violence mr
wallace i'm not going into the history
of other countries and i'm not going to
analyze how the frontiers of countries
which i've seen or in which i've served
were achieved
but we have certainly achieved our
territorial settlement as a result of
agreements not as a result of violence
it was they who decreed
the method by which the present
frontiers were achieved they rejected
the 1947 recommendation
we said let us have boundaries by
international agreement they said let us
fix our boundaries by war
and they made the war
but following the war we reached
agreements and these agreements define
our boundaries and we and they have
agreed that they may not be changed
except by mutual consent but much more
important even than history and law
is this basic model question here we are
8 000 square miles perhaps the smallest
state
in the international community here they
are 11 sovereign states
three million square miles
four hundred times our area and we have
the fantastic doctrine
i will admit it isn't sponsored by any
serious government but one does hear it
the doctrine that this vast sated fat
huge lavish arab empire
should expand at the expense of tiny
israel nobody in the world need
lie awake at night worrying about
whether israel is too big when you talk
about the huge stated fat arab states
the 11 sovereign states
it is barely possible that you're guilty
of some overstatement there is also in
that area tremendous poverty tremendous
desolation yes i'm speaking mr wallace
purely in territorial terms
they really have no reason to envy us
our 8 000 square miles mr ambassador do
you
do you foresee further territorial
expansion by israel
well i don't like the word further mr
wallace because as i've said our present
boundaries rest upon agreements beyond
which we have not encroached
but we
certainly do not desire
to expand our frontiers i doubt the
reality of this issue we are prepared to
accept a guaranteed settlement with the
arab states
on the present frontiers are they so
prepared i wonder whether the issue
isn't one of our expansion here sit i
the accredited representative of israel
and i declare that israel will sign a
peace treaty with the united states on
the present frontier now you get an arab
ambassador sitting here to say that he
will have a settlement with israel on
the present frontier and you'll really
have a story of course there is one
political party and a fairly substantial
political party within israel the herod
party with 15 seats in your parliament
to the ben-gurion party's 40 seats
one of the herod's major spokesman dr
joseph schechtman wrote this recently he
said zionism is more than israel for
zionism israel's present territory and
population are but a partial
accomplishment and the herald party is
dedicated to territorial expansion is
that not so uh yes but when you've said
mr wallace that they have 15 members
dedicated to expansion
you're really saying in other words
there are 115 members not dedicated to
expansion in other words 85 percent of
the israeli electorate
has put its trust in parties which do
not advocate territorial expansion
therefore i think one can say that
within our democratic process
the concept of territorial expansion has
been rejected
let's move along
recently in the middle east
i spoke with the president of the
national bank of egypt hussein fami
who's a member of the egyptian economic
council and he told us this he said
israel as a nation is doomed to go
bankrupt because the resources are
pitifully limited some olive and orange
groves a little pot ash no fuels no raw
materials to speak of
and its industry he said is unable to
make enough products to export at a
significant profit
israel can exist only on charity from
other nations what's your answer well
i'm deeply touched by this gentleman's
concern
but i will say with
a definiteness which may surprise you
that there is no reason whatever for any
skepticism
about israel's economic future
let me just say what the main facts are
which built up into a certainty of
success
takes seven years
1951-1957
during that period our population has
increased by four percent per year in
other words by some 30 percent
in seven years population increase of 30
percent what has happened to our
national product in those seven years it
has increased by 75 percent
what has happened to our export trade it
has increased by 250 percent
from a figure of 75 million dollars a
year export earnings in 1951 to 203
million dollars export earnings now
in other words all the trends
all the lines are converging towards
success and we think that our
difficulties are are transient these are
impressive basic facts they are
impressive facts but the fact that the
matter is that the the balance between
imports and exports is still way in
favor of imports oh yes there is a a
very um imposing
uh deficit in the balance of payments it
becomes less imposing if you analyze it
the new york times it includes if i may
just surely refer to this all the
machinery that we're importing all the
capital goods all the tractors
the machines the irrigation pipes to
make our productive uh our economy
productive these are all included on the
deficit side in other words you're not
furnishing your house we're like a man
who's furnishing a workshop while he's
building the furniture and the equipment
of course his expenditures are heavy but
he's incurring those expenditures in the
cause of ultimate fruition the new york
times summed up your economic problems
at the end of 57 in this fashion they
said the trade deficit remained between
300 million and 350 million dollars
which meant that for another year israel
continued to depend upon the
astronomical contributions of world
jewelry and particularly united states
jewry to keep her head above water
we're now faced here
with talk at least
and probably the fact of a recession
where there to be a serious
recession not only here in the united
states but in the world this could be
disastrous for israel could it not well
we do depend for this transitional
period in which our economy is being
built
upon external aid and of course if we
were cut off from that aid
we would suffer but we would not be
alone in that our economic future
depends on very clear guiding posts
agriculture we can become independent
of all agricultural imports except a few
staple products minerals to give you an
example we're earning one or two million
dollars a year from our potash resources
this could become 15 million dollars for
that single item
industry where we're opening new markets
in asia and africa
and science
where we look to the new fuels
and the new
forces of nature to compensate for our
relative scarcity in conventional fuels
talking of america's involvement in all
of this
because of the arab-israeli conflict the
united states finds itself on the horns
of a dilemma we want
israel's survival and friendship
but we also need the friendship of 40
million arabs who might otherwise turn
to russia
do you think that it is in the united
states best interest
therefore to befriend israel
and risk thereby losing the entire
middle east to russia
i think mr wallace that your country's
only course if i might suggest it in
response to your invitation
is to follow a policy of constructive
friendship for israel and for the arab
states
america has sponsored and stimulated the
independence of many arab states
you would have been false to your own
traditions of justice and equality if
you had enabled them to become
independent in 11 countries and not
enabled our people at the climax of its
agony to achieve its modern domain of
independence i think that if your policy
makes it clear
that you seek the friendship of israel
and of
her neighbors
not at the expense of each other and
that you regard these friendships as
reconcilable within your policy
i believe that that would be respected
by us and by them you don't believe that
friendship for israel on the one hand
and the arab states on the other are
necessarily mutually self-cancelling i i
think not mr wallace in many countries
manage as your own country does to
reconcile these two elements in its
policy ambassador eben in a moment i
would like to ask you about the role of
the american jew
in israel and zionism's future according
to a leading anti-zionist here in the
united states rabbi elmer berger
the zionist israeli access he says
imposes upon jews outside of israel
americans of jewish faith included
a status of double nationality
which he charges is both artificial and
dangerous
in a moment i'd like to get your opinion
of that charge
and we'll get abba even's answer in just
60 seconds
now then mr evan regarding the american
jew and the state of israel
as i said the anti-zionist rabbi dr
elmer berger has written
that the zionist israeli axis imposes
upon jews outside of israel americans of
jewish faith included a status of double
nationality the status which he deplores
what's your answer mr wallace i have so
many pressing duties that i don't follow
the wisdom of this gentleman perhaps as
closely as i should
i will only say this that we ask no
allegiance
we seek no loyalty from anyone who is
not a citizen of israel
there is a kinship of spirit of emotion
of historic memory
between us and those who share our faith
throughout the world
if american jews wish to express that
kinship it is for them so to do
if not then that also is their decision
we
as a free nation speaking to a free
nation set forth the reasons
why we believe they will find it
infinitely rewarding
to draw upon our common heritage and to
sustain us
in our great historic enterprise but it
is their decision and we impose nothing
on them at all your own prime minister
david ben-gurion wrote back in 1953
this he said when a jew in america
speaks of our government to his fellow
jews
he usually means the government of
israel
while the jewish public in various
countries view the israeli ambassadors
as their own representatives
wouldn't that appear any way to support
rabbi berger's state i think not mr
wallace i'm sure the prime minister was
speaking in these
terms of historic sympathy we do evoke a
certain affection certain impulses of
responsibility
but the clear division of political
allegiance is i think fully understood
on both sides
we impose nothing upon them
we seek as i've said no allegiance from
them
there is a kinship of history which both
they and we
seek voluntarily to express and for
which there are so many examples
both in our own tradition and in yours
what a jew
in your estimation would a jew be
any of the lesser jew if he were opposed
to zionism and to israel
well we're dealing here with subjective
terms
more of a true war less of a jew i think
it is for jews outside of israel to
determine the exact degree and measure
of their intimacy and with us
we believe that uh israel's emergence is
the greatest collective event in the
history
of the jewish people and that there is
no pride and no dignity for a jew
such as those to be found in giving aid
and sustenance
to israel in the great hour of her
resurgence
i still if i may say so sir do not feel
that you've been responsive to that
question though can a jew be a good jew
and still be opposed to zionism and to
israel i think that's for him to to
decide i would say this but in your
essay in my own personal interpretation
i would say that a man who opposed the
state of israel and the great movement
which brought it about
it would be in revolt against the most
constructive and creative events
in the life of the
jewish people and it's a fact that the
great majority of our kinsmen everywhere
are exalted and uplifted
by these events but judaism is a
religion sir
it is a religion and it is a peoplehood
and it is a civilization
and it is a faith and it is a memory
it is a world of thought and of spirit
and of action and it cannot be
restrictively defined therefore in your
estimation again
to be a good jew
one has to be more than just a religious
practicing
one has to enter the religion and the
peoplehood at one at the same time to be
a fulfilled jew i believe that religion
uh has been the field in which the
genius of our people has been most
profoundly stirred
about that being jewish goes beyond this
vital domain and covers a whole
conflicts of spiritual and
other emotions and that to live within
the fullness of jewish history
is a deeply satisfying experience
recently david ben-gurion said i still
don't believe it's possible to enjoy the
full jewish life outside of israel
well
to be quite frank mr wallace we think
highly of our country
we believe that we have achieved a
reunion
of the conditions of its greatness this
was the people this was the land and
this was the language
out of whose previous reunion a great
event flowed for us and for mankind
and we believe that the perfection of
our destiny in the world
can only be found
through this
great act of restoration which has
happened in our lifetime we wish well to
our brethren outside our frontiers but
we do believe that there is a special
historic and spiritual quality
in the life of a free jewish citizen in
israel reborn
i thank you sir for coming and spending
this half hour
with us
i congratulate you upon your 10th
anniversary thank you very much
the state of israel was conceived 10
years ago in hope
it has lived in good measure in peril in
the future
if it is to survive and realize its
dream of plenty it must live in peace
to that the free world says amen
william o douglas then associate justice
of the united states supreme court was a
guest of the mike wallace interview
program in 1958.
over the course of a half hour douglas
discussed post-war threats to american
freedoms this program runs about 27
minutes
this is william douglas associate
justice of the supreme court of the
united states
not long ago justice douglas wrote in
recent years as we have denounced the
loss of liberty abroad
we have witnessed its decline here in
america
we'll find out why in a moment
the mike wallace interview presented by
the american broadcasting company in
association with the fund for the
republic
brings you a special television series
discussing the problems of survival and
freedom in america
good evening i'm mike wallace
america prides itself on its freedoms
chief among them freedom of expression
freedom to exchange ideas
these freedoms have the blessings of our
civic leaders our newspapers our
politicians but in practice are we
always granted those freedoms
and do we always use
the freedom we have
our guest justice william douglas of the
united states supreme court
justice douglas in your new book the
right of the people you write this you
say
in recent years
as we've denounced the loss of liberties
abroad we have witnessed its decline
here in america
where have our liberties declined
recently here in the united states well
after world war
ii we had a real problem on our hands of
of the subversive operating uh for the
communist
orbit of influence in the world
and uh
necessary problem of of ferreting them
out and getting them out of important
positions in government
but instead of going about it like the
british did in a very discreet rather
silent behind-the-scenes manner
we started having public trials of
people and the whole question not only
of what they had done but their beliefs
and attitudes
began to be looked into and so people
became more and more frightened and
people uh to get a job or to keep a job
wanted to be safe and so i think that
there has been a general contraction
of the feeling of ability to speak
freely
and
a general uh
leavening
a
general lowering of the
of the standards of free expression that
we've enjoyed in earlier days
well now
is it understandable that in our craving
for security if you will in a cold war
that perhaps
uh it is understandable that the
american people might be willing in a
sense to give up a few of their freedoms
because of a fear that they're going to
lose their security i don't think
there's any such thing as a conscious
choice or any such imminence
of that kind of a crisis developing but
i think that uh the ten the trend to
conformity
uh has been great uh in america due to a
number of reasons since world war ii and
the hunt for this subversive i think has
been one of them i was sitting on a
plane just the other day
uh riding into washington and a lady
spoke up to me a stranger and said that
she had found a subversive in her
child's uh public school room
and i asked her what her definition of a
subversive was and she said her
definition of a subversive was a person
who was a socialist and she was
convinced that the man who taught art
in this public school was was a
socialist and therefore a subversive
it's that kind of non-discriminating
analysis that has been more and more
common i think in american public
life should the freedom of speech
according to your understanding
include the freedom to challenge the
very basis of an existing government
well uh in the jeffersonian uh sense of
freedom of expression
there should be no horizons on on on
debate on
on talk
people should
be tested not by
their loyalty not by
belief
not by utterances but by but by their
actions jefferson would draw the line
between speech on the one side and
actions on the other and in the field of
speech
uh tom jefferson i think would put no
limits on it there would be no horizons
and the way to combat error
according to one of his classical
statements was
uh with reason
to fight one idea with another idea to
fight one doctrine with another doctrine
to fight one belief with another
belief but never to make any idea taboo
and put it beyond discussion to suppress
it because once you start suppressing
ideas then you get developing in a
society a very unhealthy influence most
people who expressed fears that america
was losing its liberties
seemed most fearful four or five years
ago as you have pointed out
when as they claimed our hysteria over
communism put our respect for civil
liberties somewhat into the shadows
but we would seem to have recovered
somewhat from that period of three four
or five years ago
do you think that our regard for liberty
has been declining even since then
justice i don't know that has been
declining but i i do have the feeling
that we've become a little more
insensitive to inroads
and that uh the uh inclination to look
for
a teacher who is a
so-called safe a minister who is safe a
congressman who was safe
uh the the leveling down process i think
has continued when you say safe what
does that word mean i mean uh who
doesn't have unorthodox ideas who
conforms to the pattern of general
thought and thinking
who is uh
not a contentious character whose ideas
are
readily acceptable
who is not apt to draw the wrath of
people who disagree in the field of
ideas
and i imagine you what you're saying in
a sense is that this becomes startifying
to the american culture great influences
in the american life that has have been
invigorating have been
the dissenters the unorthodox people who
challenge
an existing institution or way of life
or
a way of doing things and makes people
think about uh
what they are doing and the values in
implicit in what they're doing and to
the constant re-examination is a healthy
thing
one of your major concerns in this area
in the area of freedom of expression of
course is freedom of speech which is
guaranteed under the first amendment of
the constitution
now in your
book the right of the people
you say that even this freedom is being
modified restricted somewhat
just how in what sense sir
well the uh theory is developed in uh
some circles that the freedom of speech
which in terms is absolute
in the first amendment uh is subject to
regulation to reasonable regulation by
the legislative bodies
the first amendment says congress shall
make no law bridging freedom of speech
freedom of press or freedom of religion
it would be unthinkable in the
jeffersonian sense
that uh
freedom of press could be regulated by
reasonable or unreasonable regulations
that when
the law says that the constitution says
that an editor is
free to express himself
that apart from the such laws is the
laws of libel that
are implicit exceptions that he
has not to does not need to submit his
editorial page before publication to any
board of censors
that he can write what he wants even
though it's against the
uh opinion of the government or the
majority of the people that he can
present to the to his readers any point
of view whether it's a minority or a
majority point of view
whether it's orthodox or unorthodox sam
johnson said samuel johnson said and i
would i wonder if you would give us your
opinion of what i'm to read to you now
he said every society has a right
to preserve public peace and order and
therefore has a good right
to prohibit the propagation of opinions
which have a dangerous tendency that was
uh an idea that sam johnson had and it's
still widely held in some parts of the
world but we got away from that when we
adopted jefferson's and madison's ideas
of a doc of uh promoting a written
constitution
now the written constitution that we
have says congress shall not do certain
things states shall not do certain
things certain things shall not be done
to the to the citizen
uh it they had in mind the protection of
minority views they had in mind
protection of
racial minorities religious minorities
political minorities against all
forms and sorts of persecutions they put
up in other words little no trespassing
signs
and said government shall not walk here
and that is uh how weird our government
is inherently different from many other
governments different from england
because england has no written
constitution well if i understand your
understanding correctly you believe that
no you believe the constitution says no
abridgement of speech is permissible let
me see if i understand
further what exactly what you mean by
freedom of speech and i'm sure that
you've heard this question before
should freedom of speech be granted to a
man who simply perhaps for the fun of it
leaps up in a theater and shouts fire
and thereby causes a panic
well that's been one of the classic uh
illustrations uh in some of the legal
literature
of course that would not be protected
uh of course a man who
uh does a thing like that would uh
commit a crime and properly so
uh such a uh
such a pronouncement is uh more than
speech it's uh it's really producing a
riot
it's such an announcement is uh is not
the
dissemination of ideas it's not
discourse it's not
a discussion of
public events or or controversial issues
that that certainly would not be uh
protected by by the first amendment but
when it comes down to sociological
matters political matters
economic matters farm prices
criminal laws deportation policies
foreign policy the wide range of public
affairs then there there should be no
regulation or limitation even in the
case of a communist or a fascist or a
racist who gets up in a meeting and says
things that are repugnant to the great
majority of society
and even if uh
if he takes off after a minority group
in a vile and unspeakable way you still
believe
that he is entitled to freedom of speech
because he's talking within the area of
sociology or economics or politics
that was jefferson's view and is covered
by his first inaugural the way to combat
those noxious ideas is with other ideas
the way to combat the
falsehoods is with truth brandeis made a
classic statement in one of his famous
historic opinions in the court
once you start saying this man shall not
talk about this or this other man shall
not talk about that then you inaugurate
a regime of a real censorship and the
question is
where are you going to stop and nobody
is wise enough to to stop at the right
place
i don't mean to carry this sir to a
ridiculous extreme
but for for instance
would you want to permit a fascist then
i gather you would to get up on the
soapbox in front of the white house call
for the overthrow of our government for
it's being taken over by a dictator as
far as you're concerned that's perfectly
sensitive well the from the white house
is a poor place to make a speech
we have traffic problems and
and traffic problems uh
cannot be
allowed to be disregarded by people who
want to make a speech at a busy
intersection
but you know the
the uh the british in hyde park i've
been there probably you have many times
have set aside a place where anybody can
get up and talk about anything and there
they are all the crackpots that you can
imagine
making uh these stirring uh moving and
passionate speeches in favor of some
lost cause or other it's a good healthy
thing for for a society to have a place
like that
and while the in front of the white
house would be the poor place to have it
the idea that you're talking about is i
think a sound one now the fact is is it
not sir that some judges and other
government officials who are loyal
americans
do not fully share your views on freedom
of speech they want more restraint more
modification
than you do that's right we're we're in
an area that uh
is uh subject to a great debate and uh
this is one point of view well what is
the difference in the basic philosophy
between these gentlemen and yourself as
you see it
that is uh
that the citizen is is uh and his
beliefs and his ideas and his conscience
are superior to government that the
great abuses throughout history have
been when government intrudes
into the privacy of a man's thinking
when government lays its hand on his
shoulder and said you shall not worship
this way you shall not think this
thought
you shall not read this book
those have been the great oppressive
chapters in human history and and the
great achievement of the of our bill of
rights was to
put up as i said no trespassing signs
and indicate places where government
could not intrude
but from the other point of view these
are men who feel that for the common
defense or the common security perhaps
it's a good idea to put a little bit of
a break from time to time yes but i
should not represent their point of view
because i don't agree with it
the military and political analyst
walter millis tackles this issue in a
pamphlet called individual freedom and
the common defense and he says that some
of our freedoms are being restricted
because of the cold war but he says
another factor
is what he calls the pressures of
personal ambition
and partisan fury
and the reactions of those who see in
communism less a threat to the free
society
then to their own positions of power and
profit
would you care to comment about that do
you see any of that in america i haven't
seen very much of that in america i
think that uh
the influences
suppression of minority views
towards orthodoxy and thinking
about public issues has
been more of the subconscious
unconscious
influences coming from
the uh to a very great extent from the
[Music]
tendency among americans to conform to
the
picture of the of the man in the arrow
collar ad to be uh
safe and and sound and uh
and not to deviate or depart from
an orthodox point of view to have no not
much original thinking
to uh
not get away deviate very far from
what the uh
the official policy is as respects red
china india
uh israel the arab world or what have
you
to be rather safe and and and not get
into controversial issues so that he
won't be called before his
uh hit a board of government uh to
be asked questions or raise problems
with his private employer
what you're saying in a way is that we
have freedoms as americans that we don't
lose
so we have a great uh reservoir freedoms
the greatest reservoir freedom of any
people in the world and the great
reservoir freedom that we have is after
all the one one outstanding thing that
distinguishes us from the communist
world
the communist world as i've seen it is
would be a terrible place to live
because there's no place for the spirit
of man for his soul no place for his
conscience no place for
individual utterances of dissident views
you read what is on the book stands and
the book stands is uh made up of
material that's gone through the russian
censor and it's all safe and secure
stuff from the russian point of view
from the communist point of view
and the man uh they seem to thrive and
flourish justice douglas
we ask the question is freedom necessary
no evidently freedom is not necessary to
a thriving and flourishing russian
society i wouldn't call russia a
thriving and flourishing place
to be sure they can put up a sputnik but
when you get down into the field of the
humanities when you get into the field
of religion when you get into the field
of poetry and literature it's a very
stullifying place there are no no ideas
there's a great revolution
going on silently inside russia among
the lawyers and the law professors and
the judges to get more freedom for the
courts but they can't get anywhere with
their methods for re proposals for
reform because the communist party
doesn't want reform they want
complete control complete security
complete uh monopoly of of of all the
powers so they're very unwilling to give
anything up it's not a flourishing
society and it's the one thing that
makes our society flourishing is not
only the great production lines of
automobiles and other commodities but
but the right to
worship to believe what you think to
speak as you
as you want to
to say on television the things that uh
you want to say and not be censored all
right we live in a democracy and the
majority ostensibly in a democracy rules
let's look at this freedom of speech
angle therefore from that point of view
a couple of years ago a survey by a
harvard professor showed the following
the majority of the people in the united
states would not want a communist to
speak in their community
the majority of americans believe that
communists
should be deprived of their citizenship
this is a democracy
why should
the will
of the majority in a democracy therefore
not be realized
well when our court
sit down to make a decision on on an
important case
we would never think of first taking a
gallup poll to find out how people felt
about the question because that that is
an irrelevancy we live
what people think about it is is
irrelevant because we live under a
government of laws
and we uh
under a written constitution
our written our constitution
was premised upon the sovereignty of the
people
but the men who drew it were wise men
and knew that even a majority can can be
a tyrannous group
that even a majority
can
be guilty of great oppressions as much
as a king
or the central soviet committee
so they set up safeguards for minorities
and the
the greatest uh
glory in our constitution i think is
apart from the sovereignty in the people
is a check upon what government speaking
for the people
can can do to to to the individual to
the minority
whether it be a racial minority whether
it be a religious minority or whether it
be a minority
in the branch of literature or
in
radio or television or or economic
theory
let's move to another area sir
talking of freedom of expression in your
book you say
literature and morality
should enjoy competitive coexistence
what did you mean by that
well
i think that uh
of what i had in mind was the uh
evils
that we run into when government assumes
the role
of being a censor of imposing upon a
community
some officials idea as to what is right
or decent
what uh what the people should read
you and i as parents have uh i think
great responsibilities to be censors
uh it's what comes into the house for
the children
i think we have a great responsibility
to see that they get exposed to the
great books the great literature of the
world and spend their time on that in
the bible and
other great books rather than just the
trash that is turned out
and i think that uh
that the church groups can properly
become interested in things of that kind
it's when government steps in
and uses the police and the powers of of
imprisonment
uh to become the censor
that uh
uh
uh that i i that's where i object that's
where i think the line the government
integration but you do because all the
constitution speaks about all the way
through is
is what government may not do they were
thinking in terms of protection of the
citizen against the government but you
do agree or you do feel i should say
that uh pressure groups of sorts
religious social or commercial have the
right to bring pressure to bear on books
or magazines let us say or motion
pictures which they consider offensive
or lurid or immoral they can do what
they like as long as they don't enlist
the arm of the law
to put the the law that is government
the sheriff or the police
behind one social creed be behind one
religious doctrine behind
one moral code in preference to others
that uh
that's what i meant by
literature and morality being being
competitive
you've written justice douglas that
restrictions on freedom of speech and
expression have been partially
responsible for the fact that we have
lost ground in science
what did you mean by that
well i think that uh
the uh that has been uh only one of
several reasons why we've lost ground in
science but i think that the restriction
upon communication with
the rest of the world with uh people
from various various uh walks of life
and points of view
and ideological differences has uh
has uh slowed up uh the communication uh
the the communication is extremely
important in any intellectual field you
feel communication
among scholars and there should be
uh for uh
for advancement rapid advancement
continuous advancement in the field of
science as well as the humanities i
think unlimited
unlimited discourse unlimited the
communication between
experts
without putting uh barriers up for our
men to contact others in other words if
i may uh become the specific sir you
feel that our scientists should have the
right to talk freely about science with
russian or red chinese scientists but
everyone
uh
uh espionage of course is one thing uh
and
all of these things involve certain
amount of risks
uh england turned up with uh with a fox
who was a crater and so on
uh
but those things are are
are uh risks that must be taken this is
uh being alive is is itself quite a risk
uh but to keep the avenues open between
these scholars i think is very important
and
i when i was in russia i was uh
amazed that the extent to which
uh the uh russian libraries are filled
with american scientific magazines
everything's there that we publish and
uh so very little of the russian is here
justice douglas we have just about two
minutes left and i would like if i may
to cite one more poll this one from a
recent book called the american teenager
taken a couple of years ago the polls
showed that 41 of our teenagers
disagreed
with the principle of freedom of the
press
34 were against the the principle of
freedom of speech and a few other
guarantees in the bill of rights were
also disapproved of by a large
percentage of teenagers
now then the question i'd like to put to
you sir is why
do you believe that we are apparently
failing to raise a new generation with a
respect for basic freedoms
well i think that we're we're not giving
it enough emphasis to it in our schools
i think the the too many uh
students come out of grade school in
high school without knowing what really
what the bill of rights is
uh
that they don't get it uh
emphasized in the in their classrooms in
their textbooks
uh i don't i think that uh what we need
is a great educational program
uh what we need is uh
awakening of the people to the to the
values
that are uh
that are that are in our civilization
the great values and those great values
are not uh
our standard of living and fine as that
is but it's in our
ideas of freedom the idea of the dignity
of man the idea of equality of man the
idea that government
cannot do certain things to the
individual that his beliefs that his
conscience
that his ideas are his own and there's
nobody's business what he thinks
are you saying sir that
a good many of the people perhaps even
the majority of the people listening to
you tonight
are insufficiently concerned with their
own freedoms
i don't know that they're uh
that putting it that way that they're
uh
they're in default
but i think that we're all in default in
uh in not being alive to uh the to uh
the encroachments that have been going
on
without being alive to the dangers of
continuous encroachments and without
being willing to stand up in the in this
in the school hall
or in the auditorium or in the courtroom
and uh saying this this should not be
done
we disagree with this man but let him uh
speak his mind and uh we'll answer him
with our own good arguments
justice douglas i certainly thank you
for spending this half hour with us
talking about freedom of expression
and if i may quote from page 54 of your
book the right of the people i believe
this is your
these are your words in the case of term
in yellow versus chicago yes i think i
wrote that
a function of free speech under our
system of government
said justice douglas is to invite
dispute
it may indeed best serve its high
purpose
when it induces a condition of unrest
creates dissatisfaction with conditions
as they are
or even stirs people to anger speech is
often provocative and challenging he
said
it may strike at prejudices and
preconceptions and have profound
unsettling effects
as it presses for acceptance of an idea
the lifeblood of a free society is
freedom of expression cut off this
lifeblood
and a free society withers and dies
if we are to live as free men
we must think and speak like free men we
must affirm
and not abridge
our freedoms
coming up james mann
[Applause]
in 1958 henry kissinger appeared on a
program called the mike wallace
interview mr wallace questioned mr
kissinger about relations between the
united states and soviet union the
concept of limited war and how to
prevent a nuclear war
it's just under 30 minutes
this is professor henry kissinger a
military and political analyst for the
revolutionary concept of nuclear war
and a constructive concept for peace
he's a man whose ideas have prompted the
highest officials of our government to
re-evaluate our defense policies
we'll get his criticisms of our current
strategies in war and peace
in just a moment
the mike wallace interview presented by
the american broadcasting company in
association with fund for the republic
brings you a special television series
discussing the problems of survival and
freedom in america
good evening i'm mike wallace
tonight we'll tackle the immediate issue
that will decide the fate of our freedom
certainly and possibly even of our
survival
we'll discuss the conflict between the
united states and the soviet union
and the chances of war our guest
professor henry kissinger
associate director of the center for
international affairs at harvard
university
and the man whose recent proposals
substantially influenced president
eisenhower's plan
for military reorganization
dr kissinger last year
your attack on our foreign and military
policies was apparently found so
disturbing that the new york times
carried this front page story they said
for the first time
since president eisenhower took office
officials at the highest government
levels are displaying interest in the
theory of the little or limited war the
theory of massive retaliation is being
re-examined
that was
a year ago
what has come of the re-examination
i think the theory has been re-examined
the practice has not been the theory has
been found wanting then the theory has
been found wanting but i don't think we
have made the effort to spend the money
or made the sacrifice it's necessary
for
uh to get a capability for limited war
well now in order to better understand
your proposal for limited war perhaps it
would be well for you to define what you
understand to be
our current
united states military policy what is
our military policy well our current
military policy is based on the doctrine
of massive retaliation that we threaten
an all-out attack on the soviet union in
case the soviet union
engages in aggression anywhere
this means that against almost any form
of attack
uh
rebates our policy on on a threat that
will involve the destruction of all
mankind and this is
too risky
and i think too expensive
you obviously think it's wrong
dangerous to our security i wonder if
you would expand on that just because of
what you say the risk and just because
of the expense it is not worthwhile no
it is what it will mean is that in
every crisis an american president will
have to make the choice whether a given
objective
is worth the destruction of american
cities the american president will have
to decide whether by root
or whatever the issue may be is worth 30
million american lives
in practice i'm afraid the american
president will have to decide that it is
not worth it and it will therefore
encourage piecemeal
for the piecemeal taking over of the
world by soviet aggression because you
believe the soviets
understand our
unwillingness or inability certainly our
unwillingness to wage an all-out war the
soviets will understand our increasing
unwillingness to engage in this kind of
war
and therefore their task will be to
present us with a challenge which
doesn't ever seem worth taking the final
jump
but which the accumulation of which is
going to lead to the destruction
of the free world
in place of that policy what do you
believe our
military political policy should be well
the first thing i'd like to say is that
military policy can't be
a substitute for other measures it can
only be the screen behind which other
measures are possible
now with this qualification i think that
we must have a military capability
that permits us to react to soviet
threats
at the same level of intensity at which
they present it
so that we don't always
have to choose between the destruction
of the united states and the defense of
the countries that may be threatened but
rather that we can defend the areas
which are threatened
at the place where the threat occurs how
is that actually translated into if i
may into more simple language is this
are you simply talking now about a
policy which includes limited war
it's a policy that yes that we are ready
to engage in limited war that we have
tran troop transports air transport that
gets
enabled us to get into position
quickly and that we have the forces to
engage in limited war which we do not
now have can you give me an example
of how this might actually work out
well at the moment we have 13 divisions
it is clear that with 13 divisions we
are incapable
of resisting soviet attacks when the
soviet union has 175 divisions
if we had more divisions and if we had
air transport
then in case of a soviet attack say
on iraq
we could airlift a few divisions into
the area and together with local sources
attempt a defense
president eisenhower
you advise limited war or you suggest
the the the uh the use of limited war
limited nuclear war indeed president
eisenhower said about two years ago
is that war in our time has become an
anachronism whatever the case in the
past war in the future he said can serve
no useful purpose
a war which became general as any
limited action might he said
could only result in the virtual
destruction of mankind now that's the
rub
it would seem that any limited nuclear
war might boil over into a total war and
so the question is we must put to
ourselves is dare we take the chance
well let me answer this question in two
parts you say i i advise a policy of
limited nuclear war
i do not advise that we initiate war the
question of war will arise only if the
soviet union attacks
then if the soviet union attacks and in
fact we are
very much more afraid of total war than
they are they will gradually blackmail
the free world into surrender
uh everything that i say is based on the
assumption that we are as willing to run
risks as the soviet union if this is not
the case
uh we are lost
and i think we ought to face that fact
let's look at some of the measures
let's look at some of the measures which
you propose for keeping a limited war
limited
you say for instance that in the midst
of a limited war
each side could be required to list its
strategic air bases which would then be
immune from attack
all cities within 500 miles of the
battle zone would be immune from nuclear
attack if they were declared open and
certified so to be
it could be proposed that no weapon
larger than 500 kilotons will be
employed unless the enemy uses it first
and so forth
now
two nations which up until now have been
unable to agree on armament control
during peace time
according to dr kissinger are expected
to engage in uh fairly complex
marques of queensberry rules in the
midst of a nuclear ward
it doesn't sound sensible sir i know it
doesn't sound sensible and nor does the
destructiveness of modern weapons sound
very sensible
uh what is required here is a completely
new order of thinking i hold no
particular brief for the specific
limitations which i recommended
what i am saying is this
both sides if they know one thing they
know that an all-out war will mean the
destruction of civilization
of their own as well of the other
they also know
they will therefore have a an interest
in keeping any war that does break out
to the smallest possible proportion
if they're looking for an excuse to
expand it they will expand it
i am assuming they are looking for an
excuse to limit it
what we have to do is to bend our
ingenuity and to find it towards finding
means
to limit
any war that might break out either
through accident or through design
but at this particular limitations are
absolutely the right ones i wouldn't
maintain
but
the great difficulty has been the
traditional military thinkers
trained with
conventional strategy have simply
dismissed
all
new forms of thought and have not
addressed themselves to what seems to me
to be a very real and serious problem
then you think american strategy should
be reevaluated to restore war
as a usable instrument of policy
american strategy has to face the fact
that it may be confronted with war
and that if soviet aggression confronts
us with war and we are unwilling to
resist it will mean the end of our
freedom
we will this is it boils down then to a
value choice in these terms yes i think
war must be made a usable instrument of
policy
let me throw another
argument at you if i may dr kissinger
i'd like to quote from a study that has
been released just a few hours ago
called foreign policy in the free
society written by walter millis and
father john courtney murray
in it
analyst walter millis writes as follows
he says the concept of limited war
presents a simple fallacy in logic
we can resort to limited war he says
only when the objective is not vital to
either side
in which case we would be unlikely to
resort to war in any event as happened
in indochina suez and hungary he's
obviously talking about the united
states when he says we what about that
i
am a great admirer of mr militias i
cannot agree with him there
every one of these instances were
instances where the western position was
eroded
if it is really true that we can never
engage in limited war while the soviet
union can engage in limited war
uh
i can only repeat that our
expulsion the collapse of the free world
is inevitable
moreover to say that limited war is a
logical fallacy
it doesn't mean very much if you look at
the period from 1945 to 1958
which has had the berlin blockade the
korean war
indochina suez hungary
constant threats of nuclear attacks on
other countries
the fact
cannot be explained away on simply
logical grounds
tell me this sir
suppose the communists were to march
into west berlin next week
would you personally and do you think
the majority of the american people
would want to
take a chance on protecting west berlin
with a limited nuclear war
i am not saying that every soviet attack
must be answered with nuclear war
uh in an attack on west berlin i would
certainly
react in some manner
and in some manner that involves the use
of force
uh
if we do not
no one will ever believe in our
protection again or in our word again
whether the american people would
support this or not would depend to some
extent on their leadership
if you had taken a public opinion poll
on say june 20th 1950
whether the american people would
support
the defense of korea
you might have gotten an entirely
different answer than the one you had a
week later
when the president decided that it was
his end was essential to our interests
to defend it
then i
take it what you envision is if the
government were to follow your point of
view
they should announce publicly
that from now on
the possibility of limited nuclear war
should uh should be seriously considered
by all americans and by all of our
potential enemies i would announce that
our primary purpose is to avoid war that
if we are forced into war through soviet
aggression we would attempt to keep it
to the smallest proportions necessary
that we would not use more force than
was absolutely necessary
to defend the safety of the free world
but that we would use the amount of
force that was necessary to defend the
free world
as long as we're in the realm of
speculation here let's speculate a
little further what do you think the
reaction of the soviet government would
be to an announcement of that kind
well they would be very likely
to
deny that a war can be limited
because atomic blackmail is one of their
most effective means of expansion
if they can create the impression that
any resistance to soviet aggression
inevitably leads to the destruction of
the country concerned
then many countries will prefer
surrender to defending themselves
if they were faced with a real situation
however
all past experience indicates that this
is not a regime that gambles everything
on one throw of the dice
in the field of foreign policy and
military affairs dr kissinger you're
acknowledged to be one of the most
penetrating minds in the country
last year as i have mentioned you
published a military analysis which
rocked washington
yet
you devoted it almost exclusively
to framing a war policy rather than a
peace policy
could this be indicative
of what is happening to our thinking
here in america isn't this
indeed what many of our allies
criticize us for
well
i would reject this description of my
book uh
i did not frame a war policy i framed a
policy which i think is the only one
that is going to preserve the peace
i am afraid that
weakness is certainly going to lead us
into a position
where finally we will be forced to
engage in very extreme measures to
defend ourselves
i would therefore reject the description
of my of my recommendations as a war
policy
our problems abroad are more complicated
than this because on the one hand we are
accused of an over emphasis on military
factors
on the other hand the fact of the matter
is that we are not strong enough to
defend most of our allies
and
one of i would at least suggest that one
of the difficulties is that our allies
are both worried about our general
political posture and at the same time
feel that we are not capable of
protecting them
if a showdown comes
what policies let's move from more
policies to positive peace policies
what policies do you believe generally
that we should adopt
to help keep the peace and at the same
time
contain communism well i i hate again
to
to differ with you but i cannot accept
the distinction between war and peace
policies
defense policies are essential to
maintain the peace
they are not however going to solve the
political problems of the world they are
only going to give us a shield
behind which we can engage in
constructive measures
what is essential right now is that we
identify ourselves with the
tremendous revolution which is sweeping
across the world
that we have some image for the
construction of the free world
which is based on other motives and
simply
defending the world against communism
we must make clear what we are for
rather than what we are against
if we were clearer about the kind of
world we want to bring about
if we could project this concern to
other people then we wouldn't always
seem so intransigently
uh
militant
then we would be identified with
positive measures rather than with
simply military alliance well let's talk
about some specifics
how do you regard our conduct
in regard to the algerian situation of
the past few years
i think the algerian situation is an
extremely
complicated and difficult one
in general
we should stand for the freedom of
people
in general we should oppose
colonial regime
on the other hand we should come up with
ideas which an independent algeria
cannot survive as a purely independent
state the great paradox of this period
is that on the one hand you have a drive
towards more and more sovereign states
on the other hand there is no such thing
as a purely independent state anymore
the thing that has always attracted me
therefore would be that we would
advocate a north african federation
which would be tied together
economically and for other development
projects and that algeria would find its
place as part of that
rather than as a purely independent
state do you
look to the inclusion of nasa and his
peoples
uh in this north african federation
well initially i would group i would
recommend grouping tunisia algeria and
morocco
there might be another grouping of
powers in the middle east which includes
egypt
and some of the
states which have had a somewhat
different history than the uh than
algeria would you say that our posture
visa of the egypt has been a realistic
one
do you not agree that the peoples of
africa would seem to respond to nasser
and that we seem to
support governments
in the middle east
uh which do not always have the support
of their actual inhabitants and that
perhaps nasa has more support than some
of the other governments from the people
themselves
well uh policy lisa v nasa has uh has
been has suffered from indecisiveness we
have neither been conciliatory enough
when we were conciliatory nor
intransigent enough when we were in
transition
uh we
were not friendly enough to make him
a friend and we were not hostile enough
really to bring him down with the result
that we have suffered from the worst of
both worlds what i'm saying is we have
no policy
that we've been governed by events
and
rather than attempt to shape them i
would think however that even saud does
not represent the force with which we
should be identified in the middle east
let me come back again to the study
called foreign policy in the free
society
in it philosopher scott buchanan says
our problem here in the united states
is to exist as a capitalist society
in possibly a completely socialist
revolutionary world
now it would seem to a certain extent
anyway that that's the way the world is
going
is it possible that we cannot exist in
such a world
well you know you could argue that the
identification of socialist and
revolutionary is not a very good
identification
you could well argue that
a capitalist society or
what is more interesting to me a free
society
is a more revolutionary
uh
phenomenon than so than 19th century
socialism
and this illustrates precisely one of
our problems i think we should go on the
spiritual offensive in the world
we should identify ourselves with the
revolution we should say that freedom if
it is liberated can achieve many of
these things
well what is keeping us from going on
the spiritual offensive as you see it
uh
because we've suddenly been projected
into a situation for which very little
in our history has prepared us and
because i'm afraid many of the
leadership groups that are engaged in
foreign policy
uh have had a set of experience which
make experiences which make it rather
difficult for them
to come to grips with a
really revolutionary situation well now
in that regard earlier this week you
told our reporter that as far as current
leaders are concerned you said
we have an administration of old men
happy with the life they have led
and you considered this dangerous
oh you smile now what did you mean and
why is it dangerous and why are you
smiling
well
uh i made this statement
uh
i think
that the groups i was referring to are
very well meaning very sincere very
patriotic people
the difficulty they have is that
they think that the world in which they
grew up it's the normal world
their tendency is
when a crisis arises to try to smooth it
over and then to
wait
and then to expect that the normal
forces would reassert themselves
they therefore they conduct policy
uh a little bit
like
uh oh maybe small town bankers who think
that one can always draw interest
on a good situation
we conduct very often our policy is if
arduino would live forever despite the
fact that he's 82 years old
when there's no crisis it's always
very difficult to get agreement on a
constructive step
conversely it often requires a crisis to
make us engage in a in in any action
do you see any political leaders in the
united states
you believe have a clear grasp
of america's current place in history
i think one of the very worrisome
features of the situation is that
i don't find
any great moral dynamism on either side
when you say on either side you mean
either a democrat either in the
democratic or in the republican party
how do you account for that dr kissinger
i think we've been
we've been assuming for too long that
all we had to do
but first of all we're a nation of
specialists
we tend to think that a problem is
either economic or political or military
many of your questions early in the
program seemed to me to indicate this
when you said
this is a policy of war and that is a
policy of peace
it is hard for us to understand that we
have to be able to do military political
economic and psychological things all
simultaneously
then we
have been rather satisfied with the
situation in our country as it is
and with the world in which we have
lived
our response to the world has usually
been
to to an overpowering threat from abroad
therefore even when we have engaged in
constructive steps like the marshall
plan the greek turkish aid program
which were very great efforts
nevertheless we've always justified them
on the basis of a communist threat
very rarely on the basis of things we
wanted to do because of our intrinsic
dynamism
i believe for example that we reacted
very wrongly to the riots in latin
america
rather than saying these are communist
inspired and we must react to
we must keep latin america from going
communist we should have set this recall
test to our duty these are things we
want to do because of the values we
stand for not because we want to beat
the communists but the question the
question is
why
are we as unaware
why are we as unavailing is it because
we have been projected into world
leadership in too much of a hurry
unprepared for it is that one of the
reasons it this is one of one of our
very basic reasons is that we've been
projected too much in a hurry and it
must also be said in fairness that we
have done rather well
considering uh all the challenges that
have been thrown at us it is
too bad that rather well isn't good
enough
another problem is that the people who
emerge in leadership positions in this
country
usually come from a lifetime of
experience which doesn't prepare them
for
to conduct a foreign policy they may
come from business or from law
or even from the universities well
certainly not in the case of john foster
dulles
how would you evaluate the overall
impact of mr dulles on the world
position of the united states
i think that
mr dulles is a very skillful tactician
that he shows extraordinary ingenuity in
escaping from specific crisis situations
unhappily
the real problem in the world at the
moment is to prevent the crisis from
arising
it is to project an image of american
concern and of american purpose
this he is much less successful in doing
he
often gets the impression of being so
infatuated with the
mechanics of foreign policy and
with the negotiation aspect of foreign
policy
that he has
not succeeded in projecting
the deeper things we stand for and often
has created great distrust abroad
who if any
are the men in public life whom you
admire you personally admire and look to
for leadership for the united states dr
kissinger well i must say first of all
that i'm here as a non-partisan
uh that i'm an independent understood i
i don't stand for either party
in this
uh
this depends uh
i've respected mr stevenson
uh in many of his utterances
respective mistakes in many of his
utterances although i've disagreed with
him uh very much
on other things
it's very difficult
for a party out of power to prove what
it can do
but there is no there is no republican
who comes readily to your mind in whom
you have that
that confidence
that that man has an understanding
the understanding that we need to lead
us at this time
i hate to to engage in personalities i i
think that mr nixon in his public
utterances recently has has shown
awareness
of the situation but uh
it's i'd rather not deal in in
personalities if you ask me
yes of course we're going to have to
we're going to have to deal in
personalities because
personalities are leaders
and personalities are the people who
eventually have to enunciate
the issues i'm sorry sir but our time
has run out and i'm very grateful to you
for coming here from cambridge to spend
this half hour with us dr kissinger
our survival and freedom of thorny
undertaking at best
become even more difficult to hold on to
in onto in the nuclear age
for this reason we run the danger of
seeking easy answers or of despairing
that there are any answers at all
dr kissinger has suggested a tough
challenging answer part of the answer in
limited war
but as he himself has put it
history will